la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
c'est avec une grande tristesse
que nous avons appris ce matin le décès
de notre collègue olivier léonard
sénateur de l'essonne depuis 2010 cette
mère pendant 16 ans de la commune de
sainte geneviève des bois
il fut également président de la
communauté d'agglomération du val d'orge
devenu coeur d'essonne agglomération
jusqu'à son élection au sénat
olivier renard voyez dans le mandat
parlementaire une occasion de poursuivre
ses combats locaux notamment celui des
départements de la grande couronne
dont il voulait conforter la place
au sein de notre assemblée il
appartenait au groupe ira saultain et
j'ai une pensée particulière pour les
membres de son groupe
membre de la commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable sont arrivés au sénat il pu
notamment s'investir sur la loi
d'orientation des mobilités plaidant
pour un rééquilibrage des
investissements en transport au sein de
la région ile de france
depuis 2001 il était membre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales j'ai souvenir ses souvenirs
d'un entretien avec lui au sujet de
l'égalité d'accès à la santé qui pour
lui était essentiel
investi dans la lutte contre le racisme
il était un des fondateurs de sos
racisme
défenseurs de nos valeurs républicaines
dont nous partagions ensemble la
dimension universaliste je l'avais nommé
membre de l'observatoire de la laïcité
olivier léonard comme pour beaucoup
d'entre nous le mandat de marc était au
coeur de son engagement républicain
à l'occasion de son départ de la mairie
de sainte geneviève des bois il exprimé
avec beaucoup de justesse qu incarne la
fonction de maire je le cite une passion
pour l'intérêt général
l'amour de sa vie il est aussi encore
ses mots le dévouement total pour nos
concitoyens dans tous les moments qui
ponctuent leur quotidien au nom du sénat
tout entier je sais que ses collègues de
l'essonne dans leur diversité ça ceci à
mes propos je veux assurer celle qui l'a
accompagné que j'ai eu au téléphone tout
à l'heure ses trois filles et tous ceux
qui l'entouraient de notre sympathie oui
je veux
leur dire notre sympathie et nos pensées
et leur présenter nos condoléances les
plus sincères
je vous demande d'observer quelques
instants de recueillement la mémoire
d'olivier narc était parmi nous et qui
amenait un rude combat courageux contre
la maladie
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
ça casse très attentif au respect
du temps de parole et au respect des uns
et des autres je donne la parole
au président patrick kanner pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues m'associer bien sûr d'abord à
l'hommage rendu à notre collègue olivier
léonard
monsieur le premier ministre en ayant
aussi une pensée pour le brigadier
alexandre martin décédé le 22 janvier
2022 je veux également rendre hommage
aux 57 autres militaires français morts
au sahel depuis 2013 la déliquescence
des relations entre la france et le mali
est aujourd'hui plus que préoccupante
l'expulsion de notre ambassadeur
monsieur joël meyer née la dernière
illustration vous ne pouvez pas faire
endosser au mali seule cette dégradation
de la situation tout comme revendiqué
seuls les succès mais mutualiser les
échecs la france est en première ligne
il faut l'assumer certes l'instabilité
de la région népal de l'unique
responsabilité de la france mes chers
collègues mais le constat est simple les
menaces sont difficilement contenue à
déstabilisation de l'afrique de l'ouest
se poursuit après le burkina c'est
aujourd'hui le tour de la guinée-bissau
le président de la république n'a pas
cessé de fixer des lignes rouges qui ont
toutes été franchi force est de
constater aujourd'hui que face à son
impuissance la france n'a plus grand
chose à proposer le président de la
république a choisi le conduire cette
politique en solitaire au point que dans
la situation actuelle les ministres
français les affaires étrangères et de
la défense navigue à vue dans la tente
de la parole présidentielle les français
peuvent ne peuvent se satisfaire de
cette méthode de gouvernance brouillonne
nous pouvons pas nous contenter d'une
information fractionné donné au fil des
interviews des ministres concernés il
nous faut des réponses claires sur la
stratégie de la france aujourd'hui dans
cette partie du monde monsieur près
ministre je vous le demande quand allez
vous associez les français par leur
représentant par leurs représentants et
consulter le parlement sur notre
engagement au mali pour clarifier la
position de la france
disposer notamment de l'article 50-1 de
la constitution pour cela allez vous
vous en servir
pour répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne se présent
patrick kanner permettait mon nom du
gouvernement tout d'abord de m'associer
également
aux propos de condoléances et de peine
que vous avez exprimées monsieur le
président suite au décès du sénateur
léonard monsieur le président patrick
kanner
vous avez raison la situation au mali et
au sahel en général et dans cette partie
de l'afrique est extrêmement
préoccupante je n'ai pas besoin de
rappeler ici au sénat que l'engagement
de la france dans ces territoires qui
date de plusieurs années est liée à sa
volonté de participer à la lutte contre
le terrorisme qui sévit dans cette
partie du monde et qui menacent
directement nos intérêts s'agissant des
situations plus particulières du mali
vous dites le mali n'est pas seule
responsable
je rappelle ce que vous savez toutes et
tous il ya eu un coup d'état au mali à
l'été 2000 20 qui a donné lieu à une
jeune coup d'état que la france et bien
d'autres que la communauté
internationale cher président a condamné
la même communauté internationale à
commencer par la cedeao et les états
africains ont demandé à ce que la junte
s'engagent le plus vite possible sur un
prix un processus aboutissant à des
élections pour rétablir un
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics maliens
après s'y être engagée
la junte malienne vous le savez qu'il y
avait donné des délais est revenu sur sa
parole
cette même jeune malienne qui tout le
sénat le sait
a sollicité un groupe dont je n'ai pas
ici besoin de citer le nom mais qui
s'est déjà illustré dans d'autres états
africains par des exactions totalement
condamnable et c'est cette même jeune
malienne qui a fait l'objet
d'une condamnation unanime pour la
gestion de son processus démocratique
notamment de la cedeao kiwis à
expulser notre ambassadeur
qui oui à expulser le représentant de la
cedeao et kiwi a expulsé dans le cadre
de la force takouba le danois c'est un
pays qui s'isole qui cherchent la
confrontation
pour cela la position de la france
puisque vous m'interrogez ça a été
rappelé par le pnr public c'est d'abord
comme toujours la recherche d'une
réponse multilatérale avec les états
africains principalement concerné et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec l'union
européenne et je vous rappelle que
depuis
l'engagement initial de la france 12
avons su fédérer autour de nous
plusieurs états européens sans compter
bien entendu le rôle des nations unies
avec votre autorisation président
tonnerre puisque je dois également
répondre à une question du président
comme boum je compléterai ma réponse
dans un instant sur le président keller
je préviens ministre manifestement le
prénom de république et votre
gouvernement n'a aucune responsabilité
dans ce qui se passe au mali de nous y
étions en responsabilité depuis 2013
aujourd'hui la situation se dégrade vous
ne voulez pas constaté le triple échec
du président de la république en matière
diplomatique mais aussi en matière
militaire en la matière l'heure du bilan
va bientôt sonner je tiens à vous le
dire très simplement ce que nous vous
demandons et vous n'a pas répondu à ma
question c'est un débat 50-1 pour nous
permettre d'avoir un débat de fond sur
la question du sahel dans cet hémicycle
la parole et notre collègue véronique
guillotin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président pour ce
belle et méritée hommage à notre
collègue olivier léonard les membres du
rds se joignent à moi pour exprimer leur
tristesse et leur condoléances à la
famille de notre collègue
madame la ministre
la journée d'hier a été synonyme de
mauvaise nouvelle pour de nombreux
français avec l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité et des péages l'inflation
est bien là et elle pèse sur le budget
et le moral des français s'agissant du
gaz après une augmentation de près de
50% sur les dix premiers mois de 2000 21
un gel des tarifs réglementés a été mise
en place depuis octobre pour en bloquer
les prix sans ce bouclier tarifaire le
tarif réglementé aurait augmenté de 73 %
depuis octobre et encore de 22 % en
février or madame la ministre cette
brutale augmentation reste une réalité
pour un certain nombre de français car
le bouclier fiscal qu'on tient
malheureusement des brèches j'ai
rencontré ce lundi les habitants d'une
résidence à longuyon dans mon
département facturé comme une grosse
entreprise cette copropriété de plus de
400 logements disposent d'un chauffage
collectif qui entraîne une consommation
de gaz trop élevée pour la rendre
éligibles au bouclier tarifaire aussi
après avoir déjà subi des augmentations
difficilement supportable la copropriété
a dû relever son budget prévisionnel de
600000 euros soit une centaine d'euros
en plus par mois et par ménage dans
cette résidence de 1200 habitant sur
cinq mille habitants que compte la
commune beaucoup ne peuvent déjà plus
régler leurs factures
s'ils concernent 5 millions de ménages
ayant souscrit individuellement un
contrat avec un fournisseur le blocage
des prix exclut les foyers du parc privé
et du parc social qui sont chauffés
collectivement au gaz et règle ce poste
de dépenses via leur charge pour des
régularisations douloureuses sont à
venir qu'ils vivent bien sûr et
légitimement comme une véritable
injustice votre ministre de tutelle a
affirmé vouloir je cite protéger tous
les consommateurs aussi ma question est
simple que comptez vous faire pour
limiter la hausse du gaz pour ses
millions de ménages souvent modestes qui
font face à une augmentation
insupportable de leurs dépenses pour
vous répondre la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs là les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice guillotin cette question sur
laquelle vous nous interpeller et je
pense également aux députés pas l'udc
est vif qui travaillent sur ces sur ces
sujets nous avons effectivement à coeur
d'y répondre vous le savez d'abord
l'état a déployé des aides sans
précédent pour amortir ces hausses du
prix de l'énergie et notamment celle du
gaz avec d'abord le chèque énergie
supplémentaire de 100 euros à presque 6
millions de foyers qui s'est ajoutée aux
chèques énergie versé au printemps de
150 euros en moyenne avec ce bouclier
tarifaires que vous le savez nous
destinons à limiter l'augmentation des
prix réglementés de vente d'électricité
et à geler le prix du gaz avec également
face aux tarifs du gaz qui aurait
augmenté de 66% depuis octobre si nous
n'avions trouvé ces dispositifs une
prime inflation de 100 euros qui a été
versée à 38 millions de français ce sont
au total 15 milliards dead que l'état
déploie pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français dans cette période difficile ce
sont des aides sans précédent vous en
conviendrez alors nous agissons
également évidemment de manière plus
structurelle en rénovant les logements
et pour faire baisser la facture
énergétique avec ma prime rénove et
quelque 660 mille dossiers engagés pour
un montant de près de 2 milliards
d'euros avec également et vous l'avez
rappelé la situation de ces copropriétés
et ces grosses copropriété puisque les
petites copropriétés sont déjà concernés
par ces par ce dispositif et ce bouclier
ces grosses qu prier copropriété pour
lesquels nous devons trouver des
réponses le premier ministre nous a
demandé de 10 travail et de travailler à
ce que pourraient être des dispositifs
dead les concernant sachant vous le
savez que le bouclier nécessite lui une
mesure législative
nous travaillons donc à ce format
sachant que les concernant les
situations sont très diverses et
hétérogène vous le savez ils sont régis
par des contrats les liant à des
fournisseurs de gaz ou à des
prestataires nous devons donc trouver
des solutions au cas par cas et à la
demande du premier ministre nous y
répondrons dans l'est dans les jours ou
semaines qui viennent merci la parole et
codes leurs collègues peuvent à deux
fûts pour le groupe et que le vif
solidarité qui emploie
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
sports et porte sur les jeux olympiques
de pékin dont l'ouverture aura lieu ce
vendredi je tiens tout d'abord à
souhaiter tous mes voeux de médailles à
la délégation de sportives et sportifs
français et particulièrement à celles et
ceux domaine ronald grande région de
sports d'hiver mais ce n'est clairement
pas la passion des sports d'hiver où l'
envie de faire découvrir au monde un
formidable domaines skiables qui anime
la chine on a pu voir les pistes de ski
chinois 100% artificielle installé ceux
des montagnes arides en plein milieu
d'une réserve naturelle en réalité la
chine affirme sa toute puissance au
monde grâce à l'esprit olympique tout en
accentuant sa politique brutale de
répression des droits humains le en même
temps chinois à hong kong où depuis juin
2020 la presse est mise sous coupe
réglée et où les jeunes démocrates sont
traqués contre taïwan sous menace
permanente pour sa sécurité et sa
souveraineté et bien évidemment contre
les ouïghours entre 8 et 3 millions sont
internés dans des camps de rééducation
les femmes de ce peuple sont victimes
d'une campagne de stérilisation forcée
et la pratique de leur religion et
fortement réprimée par le gouvernement
de pékin la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale avec l'appui de la
majorité on a reconnu que les violences
exercées contre ces populations sont
constitutifs de crimes contre l'humanité
et d'un génocide s'il ya un génocide en
cours alors se pose à minima la question
du boycott diplomatique des jeux c'est
la voie qu'ont adopté les états unis le
royaume uni le canada ou encore
l'australie
le 20 janvier dernier franck riester
déclaré face à la gravité de la
situation la france dénonce avec force
et de manière constante ces pratiques
inqualifiables et injustifiable ma
question est donc la suivante madame la
ministre cette force et cette constance
s'arrête-t-elle à la porte des tribunes
officielles des jeux de pékin allez vous
par votre présence légitime et la
brutalité du régime chinois
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge des sports madame baratiner à
nous
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
chaire sénateurs monsieur dessus vous le
savez au niveau bilatéral la france mène
un dialogue exigeant en matière des
droits de l'homme avec la chine car nous
sommes convaincus que c'est par celui ci
que nous parviendrons à faire connaître
nos positions
j'ai rencontré la présidente d'amnesty
international madame condrieu sur ces
sujets récemment pékin mais aussi la
coupe du monde de football au qatar
nous avons évoqué ensemble l'impératif
qui est le nôtre
responsabiliser plus le mouvement
sportif sur ces sujets comme sur de
nombreuses autres le mouvement sportif
international qui doit être en pleine
conscience des enjeux de société sur
lesquels ils ne peuvent aujourd'hui plus
faire l'impasse lorsqu'il s'agit
d'attribuer l'organisation de telles
compétitions des compétitions sportives
dans le monde nous avons évidemment ce
que vous évoquez le respect des droits
de l'homme mais aussi le combat contre
les discriminations et les violences
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
l'attention portée sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme et pour cent cadres et
aussi dans les enjeux qui vous sont
chers de développement durable et des
pour la planète et pour les populations
de ces pays qui organisent les
événements sportifs et nous croyons ce
gouvernement croit et l'état français
croient que la politique de la chaise
vide n'est pas une solution efficace
pour avancer et accompagner le mouvement
sportif sur ces questions
je vous rassure monsieur le sénateur ma
présence au soutien de notre délégation
à pékin n'affecte en aucune manière la
position de la france sur ces sujets les
droits de l'homme comme sur tous les
autres
si je vais à pékin c'est pour être en
soutien de nos athlètes vous avez évoqué
les sportifs de votre votre région
jeudi vont démarrer les compétitions de
ski de bosses perrine laffont va tenter
de défendre son titre olympique amy
cabrol benjamin cave et sasha théo caris
autant de sportifs qui s'entraînent
depuis quatre ans est l'objet de leur
vie nous leur devons le respect et moi
ma mission en tant que ministre des
sports c'est d'être à leurs côtés et je
compte la remplir avec responsabilité et
en toute conscience de ce que je
représente en tant que ministre des
sports et la parole que je porte au nom
de la france en étant très attention je
vous remercie monsieur dessus
oui en même temps à l'assemblée votre
majorité dénoncent un génocide vous
légitimez avec votre présence là bas
arrêté le slalom prenez des décisions à
assumer vos positions
la parole est à notre collègue à la
marque pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
m'associe à mon tour au nom de notre
groupe à l'hommage rendu à olivier
léonard il ya plus de deux ans nous
avions dans cet hémicycle de long débat
sur la suppression progressive de la
taxe d'habitation depuis cette mesure a
produit ses effets mais pour de nombreux
maires les choses sont beaucoup moins
simple et des bénéfices nettement moins
évident sur le terrain les maires et
cette question m'a d'ailleurs été
suggéré par le président de
l'association des maires de l'aveyron
les maires donc luttent encore pour
comprendre le système de compensation
mis en place par le gouvernement qui
s'avère d'une très grande complexité
pour les communes la perte de recettes
de taxe d'habitation a été compensée par
le transfert de la part départementale
de taxe foncière pour s'assurer
qu'aucune commune ne serait perdante un
coefficient correcteur a été mise en
place si cette part départementale
excéder les recettes de taxe
d'habitation les communes ont été
surcompensées c'est le cas de la
totalité des communes de mon département
à une exception près je vous le concède
monsieur le ministre sur le plan
comptable aucune commune aveyronnaise
n'est sortie perdante de l'opération
mais c'est sur le terrain que les choses
se compliquent en effet des
contribuables le voit sur leur avis de
taxe foncière une augmentation
importante de la part revenant à la
commune et nous savons tous que le
consentement à l'impôt est important en
démocratie il ya là un problème de
transparence et de lisibilité car les
contribuables notamment en zone rurale
pourrait croire que leur commune
augmenter son taux alors même que leur
argent alimente en fait un fonds de
compensation et profite donc à des
communes situées hors du département
monsieur le ministre comment comptez
vous améliorer la lisibilité de cette
fiscalité locale afin de ne pas mettre
nos mères dans une situation délicate
vis-à-vis de leurs administrés je crois
qu'il est urgent de renforcer la
pédagogie sur ce sujet
pour vous répondre
la parole l'état monsieur olivier
dussopt ministre délégué en charge des
comptes publics vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mark tout d'abord je voudrais
confirmer deux points vous avez évoqué
le premier c'est que cela fait
effectivement deux ans nous avons eu des
ballons souvent très argumenté sur la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
j'avais l'occasion devant vous de
souligner que cette suppression taxe
d'habitation rapporte en moyenne un peu
plus de 700 euros par ménage que c'était
une volonté du gouvernement de rendre du
pouvoir d'achat de supprimer un impôt
injuste entre les particuliers la
deuxième chose que je veux saluer dans
votre question si en fait que vous avez
dit avec beaucoup d'honnêteté que
l'intégralité des communes de votre
département et c'est vrai pour toutes
les communes de france n'avait pas perdu
d'argent dans cette opération qu'elle
avait été compensé même si vous
regrettez je vais y venir la complexité
que vous présentez des modes de
compensation nous avons amélioré la
capacité à compenser cette perte de
recettes puisque dans le cadre de la
dernière loi de finances vous vous en
souvenez certainement nous avons intégré
au projet de loi de finances un
amendement permettant d'intégrer les
rôles complémentaires et donc de
parfaire la compensation versée aux
collectivités et cela a été d'ailleurs
saluée par la plupart des associations
d'élus vous m'interrogez sur le nouveau
taux de taxe foncière qui s'applique et
que l'on découvre sur la feuille
d'imposition il est vrai qu'il a
augmenté puisqu'il s'agit du cumul de
l'imposition communal précédente et
département départementale ce taux a
augmenté mais c'est aussi accompagner la
suppression du taux départemental ce qui
signifie que le taux global reste le
même si il y à améliorer les outils de
communication je le ferai bien
volontiers pour rendre cela plus lisible
au delà votre question me permet de
souligner que les modalités de
compensation nous avons mises en places
garantissent une liberté de ton et une
autonomie fiscale aux collectivités que
sont les communes mais pour les autres
collectivités nous avons un compenser
cette perte de recettes par la tva la
reprise économique nous connaissons va
se traduire en 2022 par une augmentation
des compensations versées à ces
collectivités de 6% cela représente que
2 800 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour les régions plus de 800 par le
département puisqu'elle s'en faut les
intercommunalités et cela vient
souligner indépendamment de la reprise
que nous connaissons que ses recettes de
tva sont généralement plus dynamique que
les recettes qui était précédemment
obtenu de la fiscalité locale
il donne aussi de la visibilité à celle
ci
donnait la parole aux présidents
christian cambon pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
le seul président tout d'abord le groupe
des républicains auquel j'appartiens
s'associer à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu à notre regretté collègue léonard
qui appartient notre région ile de
france
monsieur le premier ministre
mahler et honte aux oppresseurs du
peuple malien voilà bien ce que l'on
entend maintenant régulièrement dans les
manifestations
hostiles à la france au mali alors que
nous sommes nous y sommes présents
depuis plus de huit ans que 58 de nos
soldats y ont laissé la vie et que des
centaines de blessés garderont une
marque pour leur vie entière
dans cette fuite en avant l' la junte
malienne a manifestement décidé de faire
porter à la france le bouc émissaire de
lui faire jouer le rôle de bouc
émissaire de toutes ses propres
difficultés
la liste des humiliations que le mali
nous fait connaître actuellement nous
fait subir est assez longue pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de véritable réponse de la
part de notre gouvernement
nos accords militaires ont été dénoncés
ils nous liait depuis des années
le ciel malien utile l'espace aérien du
mali nous est interdit sur une très
grande partie à la demande de des
milices wagner ces mêmes milices wagner
ses véritables soudards des temps
modernes s'installe définitivement dans
cette perspective pour nous en chasser
est prélevée sur ce malheureux pays un
tribut sur les ressources et les moyens
financiers dont malheureusement le mal
dit n'avait guère besoin
dernièrement date le danemark qui avait
contribué qui avait manifesté sa volonté
de contribuer à l'effort que nous
portons est à kouba a été éconduit et a
dû rentrer chez lui enfin humiliation
suprême
notre ambassadeur a été rappelé dans un
délai de 72 heures ce qui donne plutôt
l'impression d'une expulsion et ce qui
est une véritable humiliation pour nous
alors face à cette provocation qui sont
des provocations délibérées
la france ne peut pas restée impuissante
faute de d'en subir les conséquences à
la fois pour sa crédibilité en afrique
mais aussi en europe
viendra le temps de faire le bilan des
échecs des erreurs de tout ce qui a pu
être mal fait dans cette dans cette
affaire ma question aujourd'hui elle est
très simple qu'est ce que vous comptez
faire que ce que vous comptez faire
décidez vous de rester au mali contre la
volonté de ses dirigeants et au risque
de pénaliser nos soldats et de risquer
leur vie est-ce que vous souhaitez que
l'on s'installe au burkina faso qui sort
d'un coup d'état très affaibli est ce qu
il convient d'aller au niger mais le
niger
mais le niger nous demande de ne pas
accueillir takouba ou bien est
faudra-t-il aller au tchad qui est
distant de 2600 km c'est la véritable
problème alors monsieur le premier
ministre dit au sénat ce qu'il convient
car fait le par respect pour eux le
sacrifice qui a été consenti à nos
concitoyens et pour les 53 les 58 morts
que nous avons perdu
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
si monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président comme bon
je reprends donc la parole après avoir
répondu au président qu'à nerfs vous
avez parlé d' humiliation il ya
incontestablement une très grave crise
politique avec le mali
et c'est précisément et que vouliez-vous
qu'elle fit d'autres parce que la france
a très fermement par la seule d'ailleurs
mais la france dont je réponds devant
vous de l'action a très fermement
condamné tout ce que vous avez
précisément décrits et qui est à la
seule
imputation de la junte militaire
malienne qu'effectivement ce régime a
décidé entre autres de renvoyer notre
ambassadeur je rappelle encore ici que
le représentant de la cedeao a également
été renvoyé que le danemark a fait
l'objet des décisions que vous avez
monsieur le président rappelait mais
permettez-moi de le dire c'est pas une
humiliation que voulez vous confie qu'on
approuve le fait que le régime allié
renvoie notre ambassadeur montre la
fermeté dont nous avons fait preuve dans
la condamnation de ce qui s'y passe et
nous avons parfaitement bien fait
monsieur le président alors certes c'est
un élément nouveau c'est un élément
nouveau dans la stratégie globale
de notre présence dans cette région du
monde nous devrons faire évoluer notre
dispositif opérationnel pour lutter
contre le terrorisme sujet n'est pas le
mali vous ai parlé du niger d'autres
états contre le terrorisme dans cette
zone ainsi que je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure et j'insiste auprès du sénat
c'est pas simplement un problème franco
malien simple m du mali d'un lutte
contre terrorisme international l'europe
est au rendez vous je vous rappelle que
les ministres se sont réunis le 24
janvier et qu' ils vont prendre ministre
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
de l'union européenne des sanctions
contre cet état que la cedeao vous
savait parfaitement tout ça monsieur
peur s'est réuni et que nous
continuerons à travailler dans ce cadre
multilatéral à la fois à la réaction et
à l'évolution de notre dispositif le
parlement monsieur le président je
reviens vers le président taner le
parlement évidemment mérite d'être
parfaitement informée de cette situation
et donc je le dis il y aura il y aura le
travaux des commissions dont la vôtre et
oui le gouvernement organisera un débat
sur la base de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution sur ce sujet extrêmement
important
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole et à d'autres collègues
nathalie goulet pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
le président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues d'abord notre groupe
évidemment s'associe à l'hommage qui a
été vendu à notre collègue olivier
léonard
ma question s'adresse à madame tia pas
parce que monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur n'est pas là la diffusion
d'un documentaire sur les dérives de
l'islam radical à roubaix a déchaîné les
haines et les menaces contre la
journaliste ophélie meunier désormais
sous surveillance policière cela nous
rappelle l'assassinât samuel pâtit le
cas de la jeune milla sans parler des
journalistes de charlie hebdo qui sont
toujours sous surveillance policière
sept ans après les faits les
journalistes les enseignants devraient
être libres dans ce pays comme les
autres citoyens d'exprimer des opinions
sur l'islam sans crainte de représailles
sinon nous tombons dans la soumission la
réponse faite à l'assemblée nationale
par la ministre des sports sur la
question du respect de la laïcité du
port des signes religieux dans les
manifestations sportives n'a rien de
tellement rassurant madame la ministre
ma question est simple
que comptez vous faire enfin pour que la
peur change de camp
pour vous répondre la part belle à la
ministre délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté va me choque pas
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'abord je veux redire ici le
soutien du gouvernement vis-à-vis de
madame ophélie meunier qui est menacé
aujourd'hui pour avoir présenté sur une
chaîne de télévision un reportage dans
lequel elle montre ni plus ni moins la
réalité de l'action des islamistes en
france et dans laquelle elle présente
les réponses notamment des services de
l'état je veux lui dire à elle et à tous
les journalistes à quel point nous
mobilisons pour qu'il puisse être libre
c'est pourquoi le ministre de
l'intérieur a décidé de faire place et
madame ophélie meunier sous protection
policière c'est le cas aussi de
certaines personnes qui ont témoigné
dans ce documentaire sur la question de
l'action vous savez à quel point
l'action du gouvernement est résolu pour
mieux lutter contre l'islamisme nous
sommes d'ailleurs venu devant vous
présenter une loi que nous avons débattu
ensemble que vous avez envie chi que
vous avez voté la loi pour conforter les
principes républicains qui aujourd'hui
est mise en oeuvre nous sommes allés par
exemple avec ma collègue sara lee
présentée à la mise en oeuvre à beauvais
du contrat d'engagement républicain ce
contrat qui dit pas un euro d'argent
public pour les ennemis de la république
nous l'avons voté il est dans la loi il
permet désormais de mieux lutter contre
les associations qui sont les faux nez
de l'islamisme par ailleurs nous avons
renforcé les moyens pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
je veux saluer l'action des services qui
ont permis de déjouer 37 attentats
islamistes depuis début 2010 est nous
avons doublé le budget de la dgse nous
avons ouvert près de 2000 emplois
supplémentaires depuis 2010 est sur ces
sujets là nous avons expulsé plus de 700
étrangers radicaliser qui étaient
inscrits au fsb rt nous avons mené plus
de vingt quatre mille opérations au
contrôle sur des établissements
soupçonnés de radicalisation dans chaque
département se tiennent maintenant les
clear cellule locale de lutte contre
l'islamisme et la radicalisation qui
permet de mener ses actions le thème la
sénatrice moi je partage pleinement
votre constat et sachez que le
gouvernement est entièrement mobilisé
pour agir concrètement contre à la
menace islamiste qui pèse face à notre
pays je vous remercie
voilà me goulet au même ministre et moi
je ne trouve pas que votre bilan soit
aussi positif d'abord
vous traitez les effets vous ne traitez
pas les causes je voudrais quand même
vous rappeler que les associations
notamment celle de roubaix proche des
frères musulmans ont perçu des
subventions publiques je vous rappelle
également qu'une quinzaine de jours j'ai
déjà posé une question sur des
subventions européennes et notamment
cette scandaleuse campagne 8 jabot menée
par le conseil de l'europe et le
parlement européen avec des fonds
européens
aujourd'hui la france préside l'union
européenne
est-ce que vous allez interdire les
frères musulmans les faire mettre sur la
liste des organisations terroristes est
ce que vous allez passer au crible les
financements des associations est ce que
vous allez contrôler les rescrit fiscaux
parce que ça c'est aussi un problème de
ce toutes ces associations qui
perçoivent des subventions publiques et
des dons toutes ces dispositions ne sont
absolument pas efficace et moi je trouve
que ces dérives doivent être
sérieusement dénoncer encore une fois il
ya des démarches à faire au niveau
européen et je compte vraiment sur la
présidence française pour mettre un
terme à ces dérives notamment en matière
de financement et surtout madame la
ministre faisant interdire les frères
musulmans selon faisons les inscrire sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
jour merci merci
la parole qu'à l'autre collègue céline
brulin pour le groupe communiste
républicain
citoyen et écologique j'avais la parole
monsieur le président notre groupe
s'associe à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu à notre collègue léonard monsieur
le ministre après de nouvelles
révélations sur les ehpad privé vous
avez annoncé un renforcement des
contrôles et un travail sur la
certification des établissements
quels seront les objectifs de ces
contrôles seront ils menaient par les
ars qui je le rappelle fonctionne en
dialogue de gestion avec les ehpad
attendent des améliorations de
performances ou prônent l'efficience
dans la dépense publique quand nos aînés
ont besoin de soins d'accompagnement
d'humanité envisagez-vous de refuser
l'agrément à des établissements dont le
modèle économique est axée sur la
rentabilité au profit des pâtes public
ou associatif à but non lucratif en tout
cas entendez vous avancez comme le
réclament les salariés depuis des années
vers un taux d'encadrement d'un
personnel pour un résident au delà des
scandales révélés par victor castanet
dans les fossoyeurs n'osais pas de
connaissent un problème structurel de
sous-effectif au point que les agents
qui font pourtant de leur mieux au
quotidien évoque une maltraitance
institutionnelle
pour répondre la parole et oblige des
solidarités de la santé monsieur verrons
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice merci pour votre
question d'abord je vous redis à quel
point je suis bouleversé par
ce qui a été écrit ce qui est dit ce qui
traduit une réalité dans un certain
nombre d'établissements chargé
d'accompagner de soigner des personnes
âgées fragiles en perte d'autonomie ont
été confiés par leurs familles parce
qu'elle ne pouvait plus rester au
domicile parce que c'était trop dur
je suis bouleversée pour les soignants
et blouses blanches mais aussi les
directeurs d'établissement qui se
mobilise au quotidien j'ai fait ce
métier madame la sénatrice pendant trois
ans j'étais aide soignant n'est pas tu
es je connais l'engagement permanent
constant jour et nuit des équipes
au lit des personnes âgées parfois dans
les salles collectives pour animer leur
quotidien et le rendre moins
insupportable alors que la vie décline
progressivement
bouleversée pour les familles qui ont
fait ce choix
qui est un choix qui ne pouvait plus
être repoussée le plus souvent de confié
un proche un parent ou grand-parent à
des équipes à des bons professionnels
pour qu'ils puissent passer les derniers
moments de leur vie dans les meilleures
conditions possibles on ne part pas de
statut je ne parlais pas de statut
public ou privé madame la sénatrice fort
de mon expérience j'ai travaillé dans
des ehpad privé d'étain des ehpad
publics il y avait une constante il ya
une constante et je vous rejoins là
dessus et pas suffisamment de personnel
pour bien prendre en charge et bien
prendre soin des résidents nous étions
deux pour 90 lits les nuits que ce soit
dans le public ou dans le privé les
choses ne changent pas il faut pas
confondre ce qui est un problème
d'organisation des ehpad et nous y
travaillons et vous le savez que cette
majorité en criant le cinquième risque
en mettant deux milliards et demi de
plus par an en créant 10000 postes en
étant recrute en train d'en recruter 40
mille autres en mettant du numérique en
reconstruisant 3000 établissements
médico-sociaux et hospitaliers dans
notre pays à travers le ségur la baisse
simon a pris le taureau par les cornes
bien avant que ce sujet devienne un
sujet polémique ne confondons pas cela
et ce qui pourrait confier à de la
maltraitance institutionnelle si cela
devait être avéré dans un ou plusieurs
ehpad d'un ou plutôt un groupe c'est
tout l'objet des enquêtes que nous
menons et c'est le travail que j'ai
confiée et qu'elle mène avec beaucoup de
courage à brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué en charge de l'autonomie
un brûlant
merci monsieur le président je vous
rejoins sur un point mais je dirais sur
un seul monsieur le ministre il est
difficile de travailler dans les ehpad
aujourd'hui toutes catégories confondues
mais aujourd'hui nous apprenons que le
futur ex pdg d'orpea a engrangé six cent
mille euros en engrangeant des actions
je dirai au bon moment en y mettant
beaucoup de guillemets bien évidemment
voilà ce que le groupe vente sur son
site le secteur ehpad est réglementé par
la rs et l'état et permet une excellente
lisibilité dans les années à venir ce
placement s'est entièrement démocratiser
diversifier votre portefeuille en
investissant dans un actif immobilier
sécurisé avec un rendement attractif et
des conditions de gestion optimisée par
le gestionnaire aux pays la sécurité
sociale il est temps de construire un
service public de la dépendance plutôt
que d'embarquer les pdg de ces groupes
financiers gestionnaires d pad en voyage
présidentiel comme ça a été le cas très
récemment en chine
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue marie
evrard pour le gros du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président donc notre groupe s'associe à
l'hommage fait à notre collègue sénateur
léonard donc ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
nous ne pouvons pas le nier le
changement climatique va impacter de
plus en plus nos vies et notre avenir
les événements climatiques imprévu
s'avère de plus en plus violents et
régulier avec des pluies diluviennes
relatives aux épisodes cévenols des
sécheresses qui s'éternise et des
canicules qui s'intensifie et que dire
de l'épisode de gel du printemps dernier
il a ravagé 30% de nos villes notamment
dans l'yonne c'est pour anticiper et se
préparer et cet avenir que le président
de la république a demandé la tenue de
ce varennes agricole de l'eau et de
l'adaptation au changement climatique
monsieur le ministre
l'accès à l'eau est un enjeu vital de
toute société et vous le dit
régulièrement il n'ya pas d'agriculture
sans eau et pas de france forte sans
agriculture forte
il nous fallait sortir des postures dans
lesquelles nous on en lisez les conflits
d'usagé sortir des postures par la
concertation les changes trans partisan
et avec l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
c'est cette méthode que vous avez
employé avec dérangeait rabat lors des
travaux du varennes agricole de l'eau et
de l'adaptation au changement climatique
je crois que l'on compte 1400
participants à ces travaux au cours des
six derniers mois les conclusions ont
été rendues hier matin en présence du
premier ministre qui a tenu à venir
clôturer ses tableaux ses travaux un
acte politique fort et volontariste que
nous devons de saluer monsieur le
ministre à l'heure où le sénat examine
en ce moment un des volets de votre plan
d'action avec le pgi l assurance
climatique quel consensus se dégage de
ces propositions et quel est le
calendrier d'actions envisagées merci
pour vous répondre là par les phobies
liste de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur de normandie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
marie evrard vous évoquer ici la
question de l'eau de l'autre dans le
domaine agricole une question ô combien
crucial et je voudrais d'abord commencé
ma réponse en saluant l'action du sénat
quelles que soient les bords politiques
d'ailleurs sur cette question de l'eau
sur lequel vous êtes beaucoup impliqué
vous dire également que comme vous
madame la sénatrice je considère que
cette question de l'eau emporte la
question de notre souveraineté
agroalimentaire car il n'est pas
possible il ne sera jamais possible de
faire de l'agriculture sans eau alors
face à cela nous avons effectivement
organisé avec bérengère rabat sous
l'égide du premier ministre ce moment
politique qu'est le varennes de l'eau et
du changement climatique
un vrai moment politique car vous l'avez
dit un énorme engouement de beaucoup de
participants et puis des cycles de
solutions très concret sur trois
thématiques d'abord la protection de nos
cultures et nous aurons l'occasion dès
la semaine prochaine de discuter de ce
projet de loi sur l'assurance récolte
ensuite l'adaptation nos cultures mais
également la question de la gestion et
du stockage de l'eau trois sujets ô
combien important avec des annonces très
concrète faite hier par le premier
ministre 215 millions d'euros
d'investissements pour justement
l'adaptation de nos cultures et
l'investissement dans les mesures de
stockage mais également des revues de
textes réglementaires pour faciliter la
proche et également des soutiens aux
projets territoriaux car évidemment la
question de l'eau se joue au niveau des
territoires bref vous le voyez une
véritable détermination à avancer sur ce
sujet mais avec méthode dans la
concertation et permet permettez moi
monsieur le président de conclure mes
propos en citant un ancien sénateur
ancien égale également ministre de
l'agriculture edgard pisani edgar pisani
avait cette très belle phrase il disait
que le drame en politique et de sombrer
dans le détail et dans n'oubliez
l'essentiel est bien revenons à
l'essence elle et traitons la question
de l'eau dans le domaine agricole
merci monsieur le ministre
y compris pour cette référence c'est de
la parole
[Applaudissements]
à la présidente catherine de roche pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président et
permettait aussi qu'au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales je
rende hommage de notre collègue leone à
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre sentez concerne les propos
tenus la semaine passée par le directeur
de l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris martin hirsch qui s'interrogeait
sur la femme la gratuité pour les non
vaccinés qui sont admis en
hospitalisation ou en réanimation et
souhaité savoir quelle était la position
du gouvernement
la parole est commis des solidarités de
la santé monsieur verrons
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice catherine de roche
madame la présidente merci pour votre
question vous connaissez ma position et
c'est celle du gouvernement et vous
connaissez la position du gouvernement
et c'est la mienne plutôt dans ce sens
là d'ailleurs
nous avons eu l'occasion doigt mais pas
le premier ministre les mettre en
difficulté que près luminy ce n'est pas
le moment madame la sénatrice nous en
avons débattu déjà dans cet hémicycle et
comme médecins et comme citoyen et comme
ministre en charge de la santé et des
solidarités évidemment il n'est pas
question d'envisager la moindre seconde
le différencier la nature du
remboursement des soins des personnes
qui sont malades selon qu'elles soient
vaccinées ou non vacciner on ne fait pas
cela avec les gens qui sont atteints de
cancer selon qu'ils fument ou qui ne
fument pas fait parce avec les gens qui
ont greffé du foie selon qu'ils aient
continué à boire ou non après les
comptes malgré les conseils de leur
médecin et on soit il est traumatisé de
la route selon qu'ils apportaient la
ceinture ou non donc notre conviction
notre combat que vous menez à nos côtés
je vous en remercie madame la présidente
parce que votre apport est précieux
c'est le combat de la conviction pour
celles et ceux qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux on peut s'en féliciter c'est
tant mieux ce sont des gens qui sont
protégés il en reste encore à convaincre
et puis il associe des français à
convaincre deux buts recevoir leur
rappelle leur troisième dose quand ils
n'ont pas encore eu je rappelle que le
15 février les règles du pass vaccinale
vont évoluer et on ne veut certainement
pas que des millions de nos concitoyens
se retrouve en dernière minute en mesure
de en demeure de se faire vacciner parce
qu'il serait oublier l'échéance profiter
des secondes qui me restait pour sortir
un peu du cadre de la réponse dans la
réponse à la question m'a été posée est
évidente
madame la présidente
si monsieur le ministre votre réponse en
effet prendre une telle décision
ouvrirait une boîte de pandore vous avez
détail et où tous les cas possibles en
effet on ne peut pas créer un cra d'un
cadre éthique spéciale à la pandémie et
le président du comité consultatif
d'éthique jean françois delfraissy nous
l'a rappelé
néanmoins j'ai été surprise que le
directeur de l'ap-hp
de par sa position directeur rentrer
dans un débat ainsi politique et
laissant croire que la surcharge des
hôpitaux est le fait des non vaccinées
dans la commission d' enquête sur
l'hôpital que je rapporte avec mes
collègues nous auditionnons depuis des
semaines nous voyons bien que la
solution n'est pas uniquement liée à la
pandémie est lié ou non vacciner
donc je pense qu'en effet ce n'est pas
correct de sa part j'ai trouvé ça un peu
saugrenue si je puis dire
oui mais mais en plus les médecins en
effet se sont élevés même si on sont
épuisés pour certains du travail qui est
fait entre animations se sont élevées
contre de tels propos rappelant leur
serment d'hippocrate
néanmoins si j'avais aussi poser ma
question c'est j'ai entendu l'autre jour
le porte parole du gouvernement
expliquait qu' il y aurait il y avait
des devoirs indéniablement mais qu' on
allait vers une société avec plus de
devoirs je pense que non il y a des
droits il y a des devoirs mais une
dérive qui révèrent plus de devoirs et
moins de droits n'est pas celle que nous
souhaitons et c'est à méditer dans la
période actuelle
merci beaucoup d'hommes la présidence
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue monique
lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis la sortie du livre les
fossoyeurs chaque jour apporte son lot
de témoignages à peine croyable est
totalement insoutenable vous avez
annoncé des inspections de l'igas et de
l'igf contacts déjà en 2020 la presse
épinglait des ehpad appartenant à un
groupe financier bien connu sur le
marché du vieillissement entre ces deux
épisodes deux années se sont écoulées
dans ce laps de temps qu'elle contrôle
avez vous mandaté dans ce type de
structure quelle décision avez vous
prises faut-il que l'horreur ce soit à
ce point documenté pour enfin réagir par
ailleurs ce dossier met en lumière les
agissements de ces groupes financiers et
les moyens employés
rendements allant de 5 à 9%
rémunérations extravagantes de leurs
dirigeants fortunes colossales amassées
avec quelles méthodes moins de personnel
que dans les ehpad publics et là
monsieur le ministre je m'inscris en
faux sur les propos que vous avez tenus
tout à l'heure dans le public le ratio
agents résidant et de 70,6 pour 100
résidents et dans le dans le public et
dans le privé il n'est même pas de 55
rationnement des soins apportés aux
résidents ce qui induit captation d'une
partie de l'argent public versé par
l'assurance maladie et les départements
rétrocession versé par des fournisseurs
aux rémunérations d'apporteurs
d'affaires pour obtenir des agréments
primes versées aux gestionnaires en
fonction des résultats financiers de la
structure c'est à dire des économies
réalisées et tout cela pour rémunérer
des actionnaires du par ailleurs peuvent
déduire jusqu'à 300 mille euros de leur
impôt sur 9 ans niches fiscales
généreusement octroyé en 2009 monsieur
le ministre maintenant que tout est
connu de tous allons nous continuer à
verser de l'argent public à ce type
d'investisseurs alors on continue et à
leur donner des agréments aurez vous le
courage d'annoncer que dorénavant le
grand âge ne pourra plus être confiée au
secteur privé non lucratif ou un secteur
public
pour vous répondre en la parole et kobe
de solidarité de la santé monsieur
verrons
madame la sénatrice je redis que les
faits qui sont déclarés sont extrêmement
graves bouleversant je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure j'ai signé ce midi la saisine de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales qui va diligenter une enquête
massif global sur l'ensemble du groupe
qui est incriminée je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ne faille pas d'ailleurs étendre
le champ de l'inspection au delà ce
groupe nous verrons et c'est aussi une
enquête que nous menons avec l'ensemble
des agences dans les territoires aussi
avec les départements etc de la même
manière vous le savez il ya une enquête
de l'inspection générale des finances
cette fois ci tenant compte de ce qui a
été allégué comme comportement du
dirigeant du groupe orpea mais aussi de
mécanismes fiscaux ou financiers qui
seraient à l'oeuvre et que évidemment
nous voulons mettre en plein jour
surtout s'il devait être condamnable ne
serait-ce que moralement voir par la loi
donc compter sur notre engagement total
même la sénatrice on peut refaire le
débat éternellement sur ehpad publics et
privés sur hôpitaux publics hôpitaux
privés médecins salariés aux médecins
libéraux je vous dis juste que les
soignants quel que soit le secteur dans
lequel ils travaillent il travaille avec
la conviction chevillée au corps avec
leur vocation avec leur engagement au
service des malades et des personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie et que je
peux vous garantir que les soignants qui
travaillent dans le secteur privé sont
très fiers d'aller travailler matin par
contre ils veulent des moyens pour
pouvoir le faire dans de bonnes
conditions et qu'il partage en cela une
revendication juste et légitime elle que
le gouvernement cette majorité entend
depuis plusieurs années maintenant d'où
la mise en place de la cinquième branche
il le partage avec les salariés du
public qui eux aussi demande à voir des
moyens plus de personnel pour pouvoir
mieux soigner mieux prendre en charge ce
que nous non mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je le rappelle 10000 postes
gouvernance médicalisé dans les ehpad
recours à une infirmière de nuit de
réseau tout cela nous n'avons pas
attendu un livre pour le faire c'est se
qui se décline depuis des années
désormais maintenant madame la sénatrice
j'étais socialiste vous êtes socialiste
et je me souviens comme vous du rapport
de la cour des comptes de 2017 qui
stipulait que sous présidence socialiste
il y avait eu un très fort boom et
notamment dans les départements très
fort dirigée par les socialistes très
fort boom les ai pas de priver si vous
changez vos convictions peut-être qu'un
jour vous aurez l'occasion également de
changer la politique que vous aviez
jusqu'ici mené
ahdab lubat quelques secondes
quelques secondes les ministres votre
exemple est fort mal choisi puisque je
suis l'élu d'un département dont vous
avez bien connu le président henri
emmanuelli et où tous les ehpad son
public
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue bruno
roux juin pour le groupe les rues du
coeur
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé des comptes
publics en pleine préparation de leur
budget 2022 un grand nombre de
collectivités territoriales tire le
signal d'alarmé avec près de 35 %
d'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
les répercussions sur les finances
locales sont importantes on assiste à
une hausse brutale
sauf pour les contrats à prix fixes et à
la difficulté de passer un nouveau
marché à des prix raisonnables pour les
fins de contrat l'association des maires
de france et la fnccr estime que cette
augmentation s'échelonnent de 30% à 300%
neuf communes sur dix seraient impactés
l'ademe évalué à 4 milliards d'euros
leurs dépenses en énergie en 2017
le surcoût cette fois dépassent 1
milliard l'addition est salée la crise
coheed a nécessité beaucoup d'efforts
pour suppléer l'état les collectivités
vont être contraintes de renoncer à
certains investissements
il est vrai que certaines sont en partie
préservée grâce à des contrats
tarifs réglementés de vente mais la
plupart n'y sont plus éligibles monsieur
le ministre faisons en sorte que tout
puisse de nouveau accéder à ce tarif
réglementé j'ai entendu le gouvernement
s'inquiétait du sort des ménages et des
entreprises
confrontée à ces difficultés
n'oubliez pas que tous les échelons
locaux sont également fortement impactés
si la hausse de l'inflation va entraîner
une revalorisation des bases locatives
l'augmentation des recettes fiscales
sera loin de compenser celle du prix de
l'énergie monsieur le ministre quel
message aujourd'hui adressez vous aux
collectivités territoriales qui
s'inquiète une fois de plus de la
réduction de leur capacité financière
monsieur olivier dussopt après les
délégués recherche des comptes publics
pour vous répondre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur quelques
éléments pour apporter des réponses à
votre interrogation sur un sujet qui
concerne les collectivités qui concerne
aussi est à m'interroger communistes des
comptes publics commis des comptes
publics avec ma collègue en charge de la
transition écologique nous avons eu
cours de l'automne dernier à réviser un
certain nombre de contrats du fait des
difficultés rencontrées par nos propres
fournisseurs et nous avons aussi pour
l'état dû faire face à une augmentation
des tarifs qui représente un coût qui
n'est pas négligeable cela nous amène
avec le premier ministre à faire preuve
d'une grande attention au sujet du coût
de l'énergie pour l'ensemble des acteurs
privés comme publics il ya aujourd'hui
deux types d'éléments que je veux porter
à votre attention et qu'ils peuvent être
rassurant à ce stade en tout cas premier
élément tient au fait que nous avons
pris un certain nombre de dispositions
qui s'appliquent aux collectivités
locales des collectivités locales
bénéficient comme les particuliers de la
baisse de la tennis et feu elle en
bénéficie notamment lorsqu'elles sont
alimentés pour des activités qui n'ont
pas de nature commerciale qui ne sont
pas sujets tiller la tva et elles sont
traitées comme des entreprises par
contre pour les activités qui relèvent
d'un assujettissement la tva la deuxième
chose que je souhaite souligner tient en
fait que les décisions que nous avons
prises avec bruno le maire consistant à
relever le volume de production au titre
de la reine bénéficier aussi aux
collectivités et là où des hausses de 40
% auraient pu être constaté la hausse du
volume de la reine ramène c'est vrai ça
20% enfin vous l'avez dit les
collectivités de plus petite taille
celle quand une section de
fonctionnement avec un budget de moins
de 2 millions d'euros ou moins de dix 10
équivalent temps-plein bénéficient du
tarif réglementé et par le tarif
réglementé voit l'augmentation du prix
de l'électricité limitée à 4% ainsi que
le prix du gaz limitée au montant du
mois d'octobre vous vous inquiétez de la
capacité des collectivités à faire face
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure au sénateur
mark les compensations sous forme de tva
vont se traduire pour l'ensemble des
collectivités par une augmentation de 2
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2021 par
ailleurs la dynamique des recettes
fiscales est certaine il ya une
dynamique lié à une évolution des bases
elle tient au développement des
collectivités il ya une révision
forfaitaire des valeurs locatives à
hauteur de 3 4% cela représente de
manière cumulée entre quatre et cinq
fois le montant craint et non encore
constatée du prix de l'énergie pour les
collectivités cela reste rassurant à ce
stade donc le gens voient le
gouvernement de faire preuve de la plus
grande vigilance
merci
le sureau genre si vous le souhaitez
quelques secondes monsieur le ministre
protéger les finances des collectivités
locales n'oubliez jamais que soixante
dix pour cent de l'investissement est
réalisé en france l'investissement
public par elle et que le milliard ces 2
% d'investissements en moins et l'impact
sur l'emploi et l'économie générale
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue indique
jacques mais pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie est en fait c'est
le ministre chargé des comptes publics
qui le représente une fois encore les
tarifs des péages d'autoroutes
augmentent il y a de quoi exaspérer nos
concitoyens dont le pouvoir d'achat fond
comme neige au soleil entre cette
nouvelle hausse et les prix de l'énergie
qui flambent ils sont pressurés de
toutes parts la situation est d'autant
plus explosive qu'il est bien difficile
d'expliquer pourquoi les tarifs des
péages monte encore puisque les sociétés
concessionnaires sont hyper rentable
la seule justification à cette hausse
est proprement scandaleuse
les prix augmentent parce que cela était
prévu par les contrats de concession ce
qui conduit à une fois de plus à les
remettre en cause ce que le sénat fait à
l'initiative de notre collègue vincent
delahaye que j'associe à ma question
sous sa houlette
notre haute assemblée a mené une
commission d' enquête qui a rendu ses
conclusions en septembre 2020 sans
susciter la moindre réaction de la part
du gouvernement elle a pourtant fait des
propositions concrètes pour sortir du
statu quo qui n'est plus tenable sans
verser dans la fausse bonne solution de
la renationalisation
qui coûteraient plus aux contribuables
qu'elle ne lui rapporterait les plus
importantes de ces propositions consiste
à ne plus prolonger la durée des
concessions et organiser un sommet des
autoroutes pour enfin définir
l'équilibré économique des concessions
et identifier les marges
d'investissement dont bénéficieraient
les usagers sans nouvelles augmentations
tarifaires
monsieur le ministre
allez vous prendre en compte ces
propositions plus globalement comment
allez-vous reprendre en main les
concessions autoroutières
vous répondre la parole et kabiliste
délégué recherche des comptes publics
monsieur du soft vous
aussi monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vous évoquez l'augmentation
annoncée des tarifs d'un certain nombre
de concessions autoroutières ou devrais
je dire l'augmentation de certains
tarifs de presque toutes les concessions
autoroutières nous sommes et vous l'avez
dit lié par le droit des contrats les
concessions telles qu'elles ont été
signés s'appuie sur un décret de 1995 et
ce décret définit les modalités par
lesquelles les tarifs des péages
d'autoroute peuvent être vus par les
autorités les eaux les sociétés qui sont
titulaires de la concession cette
modalité prévoit que cette augmentation
de tarif est limitée à 70 % de
l'inflation ce qui explique
l'augmentation qui intervient ces jours
ci à hauteur de 2% je tient malgré tout
à saluer un certain nombre de sociétés
concessionnaires des autoroutes qui ont
fait le choix pas tout mais qui on le
fait le choix de geler les tarifs sur
les trajets qu on qualifie du quotidien
c'est à dire les trajets comprenant le
moins de kilomètres est ce que nous
devons remettre de manière brutale en
cause le modèle des concessions je ne
crois pas je pense que cela mérite un
débat beaucoup plus approfondie d'abord
parce que le modèle concessif a marqué
un certain nombre de progrès au cours
des dernières décennies avec une
augmentation du nombre de kilomètres
d'autoroutes aménagé avec aussi pour
l'état entre 2006 et 2010 8 50 milliards
d'euros de recettes fiscales et 20
milliards d'euros d'investissements sur
le patrimoine nous aurons bientôt
collectivement et dans quelques années a
réinterrogé ce modèle de concessions à
l'aune de tous les éléments puisque vous
l'avez dit toutes les concessions se
termine entre 2031 et 2036 il serait
folie budgétaire que de vouloir
nationaliser les concessions de manière
brutale puisque cela représenterait un
coût de 47 milliards d'euros et tout le
monde de ce s'accordera à dire que
l'état doit financer d'autres priorités
avant celle ci dans la période qui vient
nous allons y travailler nous allons
faire dans un cadre très particulier le
cadre fixé par la loi du 6 août 2015 qui
était portée par le ministre de
l'industrie de l'époque emmanuel macron
qui a précisément dit que nous ne
pouvions plus que l'état ne pouvait plus
échangées la prolongation de concession
contre la réalisation de travaux et que
la remise en cause des concessions leur
et interrogations devait être le modèle
de droit commun c'est dans ce cadre que
nous allons travailler sans reprendre
l'ensemble des éléments de réponse
apportés ma collègue bérengère à bas ce
que fait l'état pour aider les français
face à la hausse du coûts d'énergie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jacqueline eustache brinio pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
collègues dimanche 23 janvier m6
diffusait un reportage sur les dangers
de l'islam radical au cours duquel de
nombreux français ont dû découvrir avec
effroi la réalité de ce qui se passe sur
notre victoire depuis la journaliste
ophélie meunier le juriste amine el bahi
auxquelles nous apportons bien
évidemment tout notre soutien de tuer
être placée sous protection sous ne
suite à de nombreuses menaces dont ils
sont victimes en france 35 personnes
seraient sous protection pour des propos
jugés certains pour certains hostiles à
l'islam madame la ministre trouvez vous
normal qu'il va vivre cachés ou protéger
lorsqu on dénonce une idéologie
mortifère qui n'a pas sa place dans
notre pays ou faut-il se taire sur
certains sujets pour vivre tranquille
qu'avez-vous fait concrètement depuis
cinq ans pour faire taire ces pressions
qu'avez-vous fait concrètement pour
dénoncer lutter contre l'islamisme
contre l'entrisme des frères musulmans
qui continuent à mettre en place leur
projet inlassablement inexorablement sur
notre territoire
on vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non monsieur papa merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice d'abord je
voudrais si vous me le permettez
commencé par saluer votre engagement sur
ces sujets parce que vous avez été très
impliquée à nos côtés quand nous avons
ensemble voter la loi confortant les
principes de la république et je crois
que nous avons partagé à la fois ce
constat mais aussi l'objectif est
l'urgence de lutter contre la menace
islamiste dans notre pays et cette loi
qui a été enrichie et voter ici au sénat
avec vous avec les sénateurs elle a
permis justement de nous doter d'un
certain nombre d'outils plus pratique
plus utile plus concret et cela répond
madame la sénatrice à votre question sur
qu'avez vous fait eh bien nous avons
pris cette fois nous avons pris cette
fois qui n'existait pas auparavant
dans la droite ligne du discours des
mureaux du président la république
emmanuel macron qui a décidé enfin de
nommer la menace le séparatisme et de
dire la réalité de ce que nous vivions
en france cette loi nous a permis de
nous doter de ce contrat d'engagement
républicains notamment que j'évoquais a
précédemment mais également de renforcer
les menaces la protection face aux
menaces qui peuvent exister notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux nous étions il
ya à peine quelques semaines avec le
premier ministre et le garde des sceaux
chez pharos et au parquet lutte contre
la haine en ligne qui protège et qui met
en oeuvre les dispositifs de la loi
confortant les principes de la
république vous voyez le gouvernement
agit nous faisons fermer les
établissements qui représente une menace
nous le faisons grâce à l'action des
cuirs et nous faisons grâce à la loi qui
a été renforcée et je vous remercie
encore pour cela
madame la ministre excusez moi mais
encore des mots toujours des mots est
toujours votre ambiguïté le en novembre
2019 le sénat mettez en place une
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste et pour la
première fois le 24 janvier 2020 comme
par hasard juste après le président de
la république parlait enfin de
séparatisme le sénat a voulu vous tendre
la main plusieurs fois par des
amendements que certains d'entre vous
qualifie hypocritement d'amendements
textile l'interdiction de signes
ostentatoires lors d accompagnement
scolaire tout comme les compétitions
sportives encore récemment
l'interdiction du burkina vous avez
toujours renoncer vous avez toujours
refusé en préférant subir les pressions
de minorités agité par peur de les
combattre par l'arche par lâcheté et
para commandement que ge apparente à du
clientélisme
pendant ce temps là la base arrière des
frères des frères musulmans
lissage de château chinon et de
saint-denis participerait à la formation
des imams dans le cadre du conseil
national des imams alors madame la
ministre les français en ont assez des
paroles ils veulent des actes ils
veulent des preuves et vous ne nous les
données pas merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue laurence
rossignol madame la présidente
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
d'abord m'associer mais aussi aux
hommages qui ont été prononcés en faveur
de l'évier léonard qui était mon ami et
dont je voudrais rappeler qu'il était
aussi un maire qui aimait passionnément
sa ville de sainte geneviève des bois et
qu'il fut un irréductible militants de
la lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme
ma question s'adresse au ministère de
l'intérieur il ya une dizaine de jours
l'association osez le féminisme a
procédé à deux cents signalement de
milliers de vidéos pornographiques avec
danse et vidéo - la moitié d'entre elles
qui sont en infraction au code pénal
l'industrie pornographique et les sites
comme par exemple jacky michel répondent
aux pires fantasmes cher collègue resté
30 calme parce que ce que je vais vous
dire va certainement vous troublez vous
choquer
beurette des sites est prise dans une
cave grosse qui revient du biais
de l'aide viol collectif ado enceinte
tout cela est accessible sur le net pour
peu que vous rentriez les bons mots clés
les viols sont des vrais violent les
tortures sont de vrais torture toutes
ces vidéos constituent des infractions
pénales apologie de la haine apologie
des crimes de guerre incitation à la
haine raciale viol en réunion
proxénétisme homophobie mais tout
demeure accessible en fait seule la
lutte contre le terrorisme est
réellement traquer sur le net si une
vidéo montrait un violeur en train de
une femme en criant allah
akbar à mort les kouffar je n'ai pas de
doute dans l'après midi elle serait
retirée mais s'il viole une femme en
disant juste cette vidéo restera
indéfiniment sur le net alors madame la
ministre qu'elle suit ont été données
aux signalements qui ont été faits à
pharos combien de vidéo retirée et
combien de sites fermés
monsieur le premier ministre ce n'est
pas n'importe quoi je comprends vous de
comprendre vous connaissez pas bien le
dossier monsieur le premier ministre et
je ne vous en voudrez pas il ya un tel
tabou là dessus mais non pas de ce que
je dis et n'importe quoi ce que je dis
la triste réalité pour vous répondre la
parole est calviniste délégué en charge
de la citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'abord je veux m'inscrire en
faux par rapport à ce que vous
mentionnez sur le retrait sur le deux
poids deux mesures qui existeraient je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
bien évidemment sur le constat que vous
partagez c'est évidemment très choquant
et le gouvernement condamne évidemment
c'est pratique c'est un sujet grave et
vous savez que nous avons par exemple
présenter de manière coordonnée avec
différents ministres le 15 novembre un
premier grand plan national de lutte
contre la prostitution des mineurs pour
mieux protéger ces jeunes filles et ces
jeunes hommes qui sont exploités par des
filières dans ce cadre là nous avons par
ailleurs en ce sens si parfois il ya
aussi de la prostitution sur ces sites
nous avons aussi renforcé améliorer la
coordination des unités judiciaire et de
la police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale qui contribuent au quotidien à
lutter nous avons créé un réseau
d'enquêteurs spécialisés qui s'appelle
cyber jambes et je veux rendre hommage à
ces gendarmes parce qu'ils font un
travail extrêmement difficile toute la
journée ils prennent en pleine figure
ces images ces vidéos en 2021 il ya eu
300 enquêteurs formés à l'anc est
notamment sous pseudonyme ils vont faire
des actions de trac pour à les confondre
ce l'a310 enquêteurs spécialisés et 6100
correspondant par ailleurs nous avons
mis en place et diffuser la cellule
nationale de lutte contre les images de
pédopornographie qui administre la base
calliopée qui comparé analysé logiciels
des images d'origine pédopornographiques
pour mieux lutter notamment d'entre avec
interpol puisque ça se passe parfois de
manière internationale je veux dire que
nous avons reçues en 2021 vingt mille
signalements relatifs à des contenus
pédopornographiques adressé à pharos et
comme nous sommes allés voir pharos avec
le premier trait le garde des sceaux ils
nous ont très clairement présenté
l'activité à la fois de lutte contre le
terrorisme mais aussi bien sûr de lutte
contre la pédopornographie c'est aussi
pour cela que maintenant farrow s'est
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 pour prendre les
signalements également la nuit enfin je
veux rendre hommage aux agents de
l'office central de répression des
violences aux personnes l'ocr bp qui
travaille au ministère de l'intérieur
jour et nuit avec des agents qui nous
ont expliqué à quel point les enquêtes
qu'il menait était parfois
traumatisantes pour eux mêmes c'est eux
qui sont à l'origine des récents coups
de filet qui ont permis notamment
pendant le confinement d'arrêter des
centaines de paix de criminels grâce à
l'action délicate qui l'ont mené en
ligne et je veux les salue et je vous
remercie
madame la présidente
mais bien sûr madame la ministre que
c'est traumatisant de traquer ces vidéos
et c'est tellement traumatisant que ce
sont des citoyennes et des citoyens
qu'ils le font et quand dans un palais
nuit comment vous expliquer malgré tout
ce que vous venez de nous dire qu'il
faut que ce soient des citoyens qui
portent plaintes des citoyens qui
saisissent la justice des citoyens
qu'ils fassent les signalements pharos
pourquoi tout ce que vous nous décrivez
n'est pas suivie d'une cessation de ces
sites d'une fermeture de ses sites et
d'un retrait de six vidéos parce que
malgré tout toujours de nous dire tout
ce que j'ai racontée c'est toujours sur
le net
mais la parole est à notre collègue
stéphane chotard à elle pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans une déclaration récente un grand
chef d'entreprise lanceur d'alert casse
les idées reçues sur les voitures
électriques nous sommes en effet un
moment de transformation
enthousiasmant à certains égards
inquiétant à d'autres cela me conduit à
vous interroger au tour de 5
préoccupations environnementales
énergétiques social budgétaire et
industriels
d'abord en raison de la mauvaise
empreinte carbone liées à la fabrication
des batteries électriques sans parler de
leur recyclage véhicules électriques de
rouler 70 km pour commencer à être
positifs sur le plan environnemental
cela interroge mais ce n'est pas tout
pour faire rouler une voiture électrique
il faut de l'électricité
si nous continuons à refuser d'engager
une stratégie claire en faveur du
nucléaire allons-nous devoir produire de
l'électricité à base de centrales à
charbon comme cet hiver les sources
d'énergie non pilotable ne suffisent ne
suffisant pas à satisfaire nos besoins
de croissance alors même que vous
fragilisez odf il faut aussi organiser
l'avitaillement
le sujet du coût est également majeur la
production d'un véhicule électrique est
plus onéreuse que celle d'un véhicule
thermique environ 50% de plus entraînant
un prix minimum de l'ordre de 30 mille
euros sans parler du sujet du marché de
l'occasion la différence n'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait les classes
moyennes françaises mais aussi les
collectivités les entreprises ont-elles
vraiment les moyens de supporter cette
différence nos finances publiques déjà
bien mise à mal ont-elles encore les
moyens de compenser enfin il ya le sujet
de l'emploi et de la mutation profonde
et rapide de notre industrie automobile
pouvez-vous démentir la rumeur
insistante et la crainte répandue de
l'arrivée prochaine d'un gigantesque
plan social de l'industrie automobile
française
dans ce moment de l'inflation galopante
de report de l'entrée en vigueur de la
zdf du grand paris que compte faire le
gouvernement pour arrêter de mettre à
mal les classes moyennes mais aussi pour
défendre nos entreprises et nos emplois
et réellement accompagner une
trajectoire réaliste de notre transition
énergétique je vous remercie
pour la parole est aux ministres en
charge des comptes publics fellous up
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur sautarel vous m'interrogez sur
la situation de l'industrie automobile
sa transition vers des modèles plus
respectueux de l'environnement tout cas
qui sortent des énergies fossiles et la
manière dont nous pouvons accompagner
cette transition tant pour les
territoires les salariés du secteur que
pour les ménages d'abord je voudrais
vous affirmez affirmé devant vous que le
gouvernement depuis 2007 s'emploie avec
énergie à accompagner la filière
automobile si une cuillère en laquelle
nous croyons en laquelle nous croyons
fort et nous croyons que les quatre cent
mille salariés de cette filière mérite
de la considération comme les groupes
industriels qui font la fierté de
l'industrie française c'est la raison
pour laquelle dès 2017 nous avons mis en
oeuvre un certain nombre de plans visant
à accompagner la compétitivité a
accompagné la diversification a
accompagné les trajectoires de
décarbonation et en ciblant tout
particulièrement en terme de bénéfice de
nos z les pmi et les pme qui forment le
maillage de l'emploi dans nos
territoires dès le début de la crise et
avec la mise en oeuvre du plan de
relance nous avons consacré 8 milliards
d'euros un plan est spécifiquement
articulée autour de la filière
automobile cela nous a permis de
soutenir 400 projets d'investissement ça
nous a permis de soutenir parmi ses
projets d'investissements 70 60 projets
portés par des pme et dans le même temps
parce que nous savons qu'il y a une
trajectoire vers la décarbonation savons
qu'il y a une trajectoire vers des
véhicules électriques nous travaillons à
des plantes déploiement des bornes pour
faciliter les usages en ayant en tête
que c'est un des carburants d énergie
par dont les moins chères à usage bien
moins que les énergies carbone qui sont
aujourd'hui utilisent est ce que le tout
électrique une solution la réponse est
non c'est aussi la réponse de la raison
pour laquelle dans le cadre du plan de
relance comme dans le cadre de france
2030 nous misons beaucoup sur
l'hydrogène sur le développement d'une
filière hydrogène avec cette conviction
que l'hydrogène est une énergie d'abord
du futur une énergie utile une énergie
efficace sur laquelle nous devons nous
appuyer et c'est aussi pour ces raisons
que nous travaillons à tout ce qui
concerne la filière les batteries tout
ce qui concerne la filière du recyclage
le président la république a récemment
annoncé des implantations industrielles
au confluent fin mais je n'en n'aurai
pas le temps pas accompagner les ménages
je crois que là l'importance et le
nombre des systèmes dette des ménages
des dom et nage pour acheter ces
véhicules des montres l'attention du
gouvernement en la matière
quelques secondes
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
ses réponses mais je pense néanmoins que
le sujet aujourd'hui mérite
d'accompagner la trajectoire de
transition énergétique et surtout veille
à l' équilibre de notre balance
commerciale qui en a bien besoin pour
une industrie qui est majeur pour notre
pays et pour merci merci
donc ne pas rendre notre collègue lana
tetuanui pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole mme martinez
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues y aura ma
mesure les ministres d outre-mer absent
le 13 route 2020 le haut commissaire de
la république adressé pour la vie au
président du conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique communale de polynésie
un projet dans le dos non s'étendant et
adaptera la fonction publique communale
cette même disposition pour un
toilettage des textes et le 19 juillet
2021 les élus de l'assemblée de
polynésie été saisis à leur tour sous la
mention urgence signalée un avis sur le
nouveau projet version paris le
gouvernement inscrit alors pour le 8
février à l'ordre du jour du sénat un
projet de loi de ratification de ladite
ordonnance sous la mention procédure
accélérée dès lors des longues un
consensus inédit inédit entre élus et
organisations syndicales se dégage pour
porter les quelques revendications
légitimes et non les moindres qui
manquait et de surcroît devait être
validé en concertation avec vos services
techniques et la commission des lois du
sénat mais d'un revers de la main vous
avez décidé de le retirer en fin de
semaine dernière à l'ordre du jour de
notre honorable assemblée sans aucune
explication monsieur le ministre
pourquoi
pour vous répondre la parole et covilis
délégué chargé des relations avec le
parlement monsieur feno donner la parole
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous interrogez en effet le
gouvernement sur le retrait de l'ordre
du jour de votre assemblée du projet
doit ratifier l'ordonnancé du 8 décembre
dernier étant dans et adaptant la
fonction publique des communes de
polynésie française certaines certaines
dispositions statutaires relatives à la
fonction publique territoriale
l'objectif de cette ordonnance je le
rappelle est d'attirer davantage de
personnes dans la fonction publique
communale au service de ces
collectivités et de nos concitoyens plus
qu'ailleurs nous savons tous ici combien
ces agents sont importants et d'une
grande valeur
n'est donc pas question de remettre en
cause l'embauché de l'ambition portée
par le gouvernement et que vous avez pu
décrire en la matière le retrait de
l'ordre du jour de ce projet de texte de
l'ordre du jour du sénat s'explique pour
des raisons au fond simple contrairement
à ce qui était initialement envisagé
n'est pas paru possible d'achever le
processus de ratification dont on entier
de cette ordonnance avant la suspension
des travaux du parlement en séance
publique dans trois semaines le choix
des leurs et effet de mobiliser ce temps
supplémentaire pour davantage concertée
associés travailler sur l' ordonnance en
question en particulier sur ses décrets
d'application ces concertations ont
d'ailleurs commencé une réunion a déjà
eu lieu autour de sébastien lecornu avec
vous madame la sénatrice deux sénateurs
rofritsch la députée maina sage et le
maire de tulle marin laquelle a permis
d'identifier certains sujets sur
lesquels un consensus doit encore être
dégagées une autre réunion travail est
prévue comme vous le savez est comme le
ministre s'y est engagé dans un courrier
adressé au président fritsch ce projet
de loi reste soumis au parlement c'est
une exigence constitutionnelle et
spécifique de le faire sous 18 mois qui
découle de l'article 74 rien de notre
constitution je le rappelle cet examen
d'ailleurs commencer en commission des
lois aujourd'hui et il se poursuivra
prochainement séance publique de la
manière la plus apaisé la plus
constructive possible c'est un
engagement que je prends au nom du
gouvernement et qui tiendra c'est une
marque de respect aussi à l'endroit de
nos concitoyens de polynice merci
monsieur le ministre je prends acte de
votre réponse mais convenez que sur la
forme laforge
saisine de l'assemblée de polynésie sous
la mention urgent se signaler
inscriptions en procédure accélérée ici
au sénat jeudi dernier vous le retirer
de l'ordre du jour mais la cerise sur le
gâteau ou plutôt sur l'arc club en ce
jour de chandler vous adressez nous
adresser votre réponse à 12h25 ce jour
au président flash ceci est
irrespectueux des élus communaux du
fénoir qui ont le rêve entités
respectives et qui ont travaillé sur un
texte depuis plus de deux ans ceci en
tout cas à mes yeux et pensez
irrespectueux du parlement telle faille
merci
nous avons terminé avec l'édition
voulait vraiment merci monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres les prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 9
février à 15 heures je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à
16h35 pour le débat d'actualité
énergie et pouvoir d'achat qu'à l'impact
de la politique du gouvernement la
séance est suspendue
la séance est reprise en application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution et de la loi organique la
loi ordinaire du 23 juillet 2010 prises
pour son application la commission de la
culture a émis lors de sa réunion de ce
jour un avis favorable par 28 voix pour
aucune voix contre à la reconduction de
monsieur antoine petit à la présidence
du centre national de la recherche
scientifique
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
d'actualité sur le thème énergie et
pouvoir d'achat qu'à l'impact de la
politique du gouvernement sur la
proposition du groupe de travail sur la
modernisation des méthodes de travail du
sénat la conférence des présidents a
décidé qu'un débat d'actualité se
tiendrait lors de chaque semaine le
contrôle après la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement nous
inaugurons donc aujourd'hui ce nouvel
outil de contrôle je vous rappelle que
dans ce débat le gouvernement à l'afld
aura la faculté la faculté pas
l'obligation s'ils le jugent nécessaire
de prendre la parole immédiatement après
chaque orateur pour une durée de deux
minutes l'orateur disposera alors à son
tour du droit de répartie pour une
minute le temps de réponse du
gouvernement à l'issue du débat est
limitée à 5 minutes madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez donc
si vous le souhaitez répondre une fois
après chaque orateur une fois que
solution à retrouver une place dans
l'hémicycle
dans le débat la parole est à monsieur
jean françois husson pour le groupe
l'est républicain pour sept minutes
qu'est ce que c'est
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour les
français comme pour nos entreprises cela
a fait en fait de longs mois que leur
pouvoir d'achat est touché par l'envolée
des prix de l'énergie au delà de la
flambée conjoncturelle tous les experts
s'entendent pour dire que les prix de
l'énergie ne seront plus ceux qui l'ont
été dès qu'ils seront structurellement
plus élevée c'est peu de dire que les
bouts de sparadrap ou l'échec électoraux
non ciblés proposé pour ne pas dire
distribué depuis plusieurs mois par le
gouvernement ne seront pas à la hauteur
de cet enjeu
avançant sans boussole ni anticipation
au gré des hausses les plus récentes des
prix du gaz de l'électricité ou encore
des carburants le gouvernement a déployé
une série de mesures sans véritable
cohérence entre elles en tout cas
complètement dépourvue de vision
d'ensemble de stratégie pour chacune
d'entre elles il a tâtonné jusqu'au
dernier moment pour finir par concevoir
des dispositifs aux insuffisances
multiples tentant de répondre au
mécontentement grandissant de nos
concitoyens dans une vision de court
terme mais avec des inquiète des
conséquences inquiétantes pour nos
finances publiques
autant dire coût total de l'opération 20
milliards d'euros d'abord pour le 600
millions d'euros le gouvernement a
majoré de 100 euros le chèque énergie
bénéficiant à près de 6 millions de
foyers les plus modestes décision prise
en urgence mais qui s'est vite avérée
insuffisante en ce qui concerne les prix
du gaz dont la flambée explique une
bonne part de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui le gouvernement
dans la crainte peut être d'un retour du
mouvement des gilets jaunes et à
quelques mois d'échéances électorales
importantes s'en est finalement remis à
la bonne vieille méthode du blocage des
prix et de l'économie administrée il a
opté pour la procrastination avec un
blocage d'ailleurs très temporaire dont
la facture soyez en sûr ce sera in fine
est présentée acquitté par les
consommateurs
en revanche les entreprises demeurent
les grandes oubliées puisque rien ou
presque n'est prévu pour elle afin de
tenir compte de la hausse des prix du
gaz les tergiversations du gouvernement
ces mesures successibles sans cohérence
d'ensemble et son absence de vie lyon à
plus long terme sont tout autant
manifeste s'agissant de la hausse des
prix d'électricité
alors que le premier ministre s'était
engagé dès septembre à limiter à 4%
l'augmentation à venir des tarifs
réglementés d'électricité le
gouvernement attendu les débats en
séance à l'assemblée pour déposer sans
étude d'impact évidemment un amendement
au projet de finances pour 2022
prévoyants rien de moins qu'une
meilleure génération de la taxe
intérieure sur la consommation finale
d'électricité
cette minoration dont le coût est estimé
à l'origine à 4 milliards d'euros à une
première fois été réévalué à 6 milliards
aujourd'hui on sait que la suppression
quasi totale de l'atc feu s'élève à 8
milliards d'euros et qu'elle ne
permettra même pas de faire la moitié du
chemin qui mène à l'engagement pris par
le premier ministre
et si le gouvernement ne fait pas
d'efforts pour contenir les dépenses
c'est bien le contribuable aujourd'hui
avec une hausse de la fiscalité ou bien
de demain pour réduire la dette qui
devra payer et bien face à cette mesure
fiscale insuffisante le gouvernement a
déposé allons-y un autre amendement en
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi de
finances prévoyant la possibilité de
bloquer les tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité
pour en faire payer cette fois la
facture aux consommateurs en 2023 à cela
s'ajoute désormais le relèvement de 20
térawattheures de la reine mesure pour
laquelle le gouvernement se défausse
cette fois sur une entreprise edf pour
excuser encore du peu 8 milliards
d'euros je vous le dis j'ai l'impression
d'assister à une interminable partie de
mikado avec ces dispositifs qui
s'enchevêtrent et ébranlent la confiance
des français est par ailleurs le
gouvernement est incapable d'estimer les
conséquences concrètes de cette hausse
des prix l'énergie pour nos entreprises
cette forme d'improvisation qui tend
vers l'amateurisme n'est plus tenable
mais je pense que l'exemple le plus
criant de cette improvisation du
gouvernement et de sa faculté à
concocter en catastrophe des situations
bancal et néanmoins très coûteuse pour
nos finances publiques reste sa réaction
face
l'envolée des prix des carburants tout
d'abord avec l'indemnité inflation dont
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de détailler ici
les nombreux inconvénients
soucieux d'afficher aux yeux des
français une réaction il faut
d'anticipation le gouvernement a annoncé
dans l'urgence une mesure qui n'aurait
plus vocation à couvrir la seule
augmentation des prix des carburants
mais plutôt l'inflation en général
de ce tour de passe passe a résulté un
dispositif d'abord électoraliste et
largement inefficace visant à saupoudrer
sans beaucoup de discernement 4
milliards d'euros d'argent public
aujourd'hui al'inverse le gouvernement
propose un relèvement du barème
kilométrique
c'est à dire une mesure très concentré
cette fois et qui ne règle pas par
exemple les problèmes rencontrés par
tous ces français vivant en zone rurale
en zone périurbaine il n'y a pas d'offre
de transport organisé ou collectif
de façon générale les experts de la
commission de la régulation de l'énergie
mais même la direction générale de
l'énergie et du climat
tous sont d'accord pour considérer
qu'après cet acte mais les prix de
l'énergie resteront plus élevé
structurellement qu'avant la crise or
cette hausse des prix à laquelle on
assiste alimente évidemment globalement
l'inflation laquelle pèse à son tour
fortement sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français et je le rappelle renforce les
difficultés pour les plus modestes
qu'ils soient des travailleurs pauvres
des foyers à petites retraites des
étudiants s madame monsieur le ministre
l'objectif de votre gouvernement sachez
le ce n'est pas le nôtre
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
madame monsieur le ministre non non très
bien la parole est maintenant aux
présidents guillaume gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre 12 millions c'est le nombre de
françaises et français qui passent
l'hiver sans pouvoir chauffer leur
logement correctement 12 millions de
françaises et français qui subissent une
précarité énergétique est bien plus
nombreux qui doivent consacrer
exceptionnellement une part encore plus
élevée de leur revenu dans les énergies
électricité et gaz carburant pour
l'automobile l'énergie n'est pas un bien
de consommation comme un autre c'est un
bien première nécessité nécessaire pour
s'éclairer cuisine et se chauffer se
rendre au travail se déplacer parce que
c'est un bien première nécessité la
puissance publique a un devoir de
régulation de contrôle et de
planification un devoir de les rendre
accessibles à chacune et à chacun
nous en faisons l'écho depuis des mois
le coût d'énergie pèsent de plus en plus
l'augmentation simultanée des prix
l'énergie appelle des réponses à la
hauteur entre électricité en hausse à
cause d'un mode de calcul européen
désuet se fondant en partie sur le coup
des centrales à charbon ou au gaz et les
prix des carburants qui poursuivent leur
montée atteignent de nouveaux records
plus élevée qu'à la période de
mobilisation des gilet jaune certes le
gouvernement a pris des mesures
sont-elles suffisantes et d'adapter non
le chèque énergie revalorisé de 100
euros nous voulons le porter à 400 euros
pour les bénéficiaires actuels et
l'élargir pour 16 millions de foyers
supplémentaires à 100 euros le
relèvement de 10 % du barème
kilométrique de l'impôt sur le revenu il
ne changera absolument rien pour la
moitié des français qui ne paie de toute
façon pas cet impôt
le gouvernement mène une politique du
pouvoir d'achat hypocrite ce qui est
donné d'une main et repris de l'autre
vous augmenter ponctuellement le chèque
énergie mais vous appauvrissez
durablement les demandeurs d'emploi avec
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage le
seul pouvoir d'achat que le gouvernement
a fait croître pendant ce quinquennat et
celui des plus riches la situation de la
jeunesse et à cet égard alarmante 1,5
million de jeunes sont touchés par la
pauvreté évidemment cela a des
conséquences sur leur accès aux produits
énergétiques
hélas aucune politique viable de sortie
de là pauvreté n'est mise en place ne
sont pas deux ou trois aides ponctuelles
et bien maigre et qui permettront aux
jeunes de s'émanciper et de devenir
autonome c'est pour cela que les
écologistes défendent un revenu citoyen
automatique des 18 ans portée à 920
euros nous le devons à notre jeunesse
déjà en place sur la métropole lyonnaise
mais surtout au delà des aides
ponctuelles et disparates du
gouvernement aucune politique de
transformation profonde de la
consommation énergétique n'est menée là
encore l'écologie est une solution tout
autant pour le climat que pour le
pouvoir d'achat une politique écologiste
de l'énergie est une politique qui
permet à toutes et à tous de vivre
dignement dans son logement et de se
déplacer tout en assurant de la
souveraineté énergétique de la france le
meilleur moyen de soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des françaises et des français
est de réduire leur comment sommation
d'énergie cela passe d'abord par une
politique ambitieuse de rénovation
thermique globale des habitations ce
sont 10 milliards d'euros par an a
consacré à l'isolation des bâtiments et
pour que les populations les plus
précaires puissent accéder à la
rénovation énergétique de leur logement
il faut la mise en place d' un reste à
charge 0 parce que l'électricité est un
bien commun edf doit être nationalisées
pour reconstruire un vrai service public
de l'énergie l'état ne peut opérer
injuste accès à l'énergie et une
transition écologique sans avoir la main
sur cet outil industriel puissant et
stratégiques cela passe également par le
soutien de filière française qui
assureront notre autonomie énergétique
je pense évidemment à la filière
silicium photovoltaïque qui menace de
disparaître mais également à la filière
hydroélectrique
se déplacer est aussi un droit mais cela
se révèle également être contraint une
politique systémique des mobilités se
doit d'offrir des athées latif favorable
au pouvoir d'achat le rail demande des
investissements conséquents au moins 4
milliards d'euros par an pour moderniser
le réseau ferroviaire et développer les
trains du quotidien
dans les zones rurales les toits
d'accompagner les initiatives locales
qui se met en place et qui permet des
alternatives à l'automobile une
politique de tarification des transports
est indispensable il n'est pas
acceptable qu'un déplacement en
transports en commun soient toujours
plus coûteux qu'un d'espacement en
voiture individuelle ul
conduire une politique énergétique
bénéfique pour le climat est favorable
au pouvoir d'achat des français et des
françaises est donc possible les
écologistes portent des propositions en
ce sens alliant justice sociale et
souveraineté énergétique
le gouvernement lui a baissé les armes
sur le front des inégalités sociales et
perpétue la dépendance énergétique
envers les puissances étrangères merci
merci monsieur le président
côté gouvernement non bon vous me direz
vous levez la main quand vous avez
besoin voilà je vais pas chaque fois
revenir vers vous vous avez parfaitement
raison monsieur le ministre allez la
parole est maintenant monsieur fabien
gay pour le groupe crc e pour cinq
minutes
sur le président madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
débattons ici de l'impact de la
politique du gouvernement en matière
d'énergie et de pouvoir d'achat la
réponse mais chers collègues nous semble
assez évidente le bilan est globalement
négatif
monsieur et madame les ministres votre
gouvernement avec les libéraux qui vous
ont précédés et responsable de la
situation dégradée de l'accès à
l'énergie nous payons la note de la
dérégulation de la privatisation et de
la libération libéralisation du secteur
de l'énergie mais vous refusez de faire
le bilan de cette libéralisation est
préféré en faire opposé les conséquences
sur les citoyens avec mépris même
puisqu'à une retraitée qui touche 8
euros par jour une ministre conseille
avec la plus grande indifférence de
changer de système de chauffage votre
crédo c'est faire peser la charge de la
facture d'électricité sur les usagers
tout juste bons à payer mais aussi des
peaux cdf et surtout sauvegarder les
revenus et les dividendes des acteurs
alternatifs pourtant la situation n'est
pas inéluctable la grande différence
entre nous c'est que vous placez à
l'échelle individuelle ce qui relève en
réalité de choix politiques dans une
logique concomitante vous confier ce qui
révèle du service public au secteur
privé au nom de votre dieu le marché et
de son apôtre la concurrence au sein
d'une union européenne conçue par et
pour le marché les résultats de la
libéralisation du secteur de l'énergie
est pourtant évidente un manque
d'investissement une perte de
compétences conduisant à des défauts
d'entretien des risques pour les
salariés la population mais aussi un
manque de prévoyance le gouvernement
abandonne le projet est co combustion de
reconversion de la centrale à charbon de
cordes mais en octobre dernier puis
réalise qu'il faudra encore compter sur
la centrale pour passer l'hiver et va
signer dans quelques jours un décret
pour deux mille heures supplémentaires
et la centrale devra fonctionner encore
des années alors madame et messieurs les
ministres entendons-nous la transition
avec l'épauler dont les essais ont été
concluants mais aussi une inaction dans
la rénovation thermique des logements
est essentiel pour nos concitoyens et
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
vous nous annonciez en 2017 la moitié
des passoires thermiques supprimé en
2022 seulement aujourd'hui
70 milles rénovation globale soit
effectuée par an quand
370000 sont nécessaires pour respecter
la stratégie nationale bas carbone et
enfin une hausse constante des tarifs de
l'énergie pour le gaz c'est près de 57 %
d'augmentation
rien que sur l'année 2021 soit 400 euros
en moyenne sur la facture annuelle pour
l'électricité c'est une hausse continue
de plus de 52% depuis plus de dix ans et
tout comme pour le gaz le prix de
l'électricité continue de flamber et
cela nous amène à votre dernière
trouvaille il faut le reconnaître au
libéralisme une certaine créativité pour
arriver à ses fins et préserver à tout
prix le marché pour endiguer cette
augmentation des tarifs de l'électricité
de manière provisoire tout en préservant
les fournisseurs alternatifs
on demande à l'état donc aux usagers et
à edf de se saigner en relevant le
plafond de la reine parlons-en de la
reine ce système qui devait permettre
aux fournisseurs alternatifs les
entreprises privées d'acheter à bas coût
de l'électricité produite par edf au
lieu de s'approvisionner sur le marché
de gros plus cher l'objectif qu'ils
puissent investir dans le développement
de leurs propres moyens de production ce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait évidemment
pourquoi dépenser quand la manne tombe
si aisément donc cette fois-ci vous
exigez d'edf qu'elles vendent davantage
d'électricité dans le cadre de la reine
mais edf a déjà vendu son électricité
par anticipation est devant et devra
donc au final racheter sur le marché de
gros sa propre électricité au prix du
marché c'est à dire plus de 200 euros le
mégawattheure pour la revendre à ses
concurrents au prix de 46 euros le coût
pour edf 8 milliards d'euros on frôle le
gmi edf à + 80% public qu'ils
appartiennent donc à nos concitoyens
nous sommes donc doublement perdants en
tant que citoyen mais aussi en tant
qu'usagers parallèlement ce racket
organisé pour 12 millions de françaises
et de français l'énergie est aujourd'hui
un luxe mais l'énergie n'est pas un luxe
ni un avantage à conquérir l'énergie est
un bien de première nécessité qui
conditionnent nos vies l'accès à
l'énergie pour toutes et tous doit être
reconnu comme droit fondamental réelle
alors besson immédiatement la tva à 5,5
sur le gaz électricité et surtout
sortons l'énergie des griffes du marché
renationalisation ensuite edf et angie
qui disposant des monopoles et de moyens
pourront se mettre au service non
seulement des usagers de nos entreprises
et d'oeuvrer pour la planète avec la
nécessaire transition écologique je vous
renverrai bien aller
la parole est maintenant monsieur hervé
maurey pour le groupe union centriste
pour 4 minutes et si chacun pouvait s'en
tenir à son temps de parole ce serait
merveilleux
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues notre
pays est affectée par une inflation
qu'il n'est pas connue depuis des années
et la hausse du prix de l'énergie
représentent à elles seules la moitié de
cette inflation le prix du litre de
gazole et de l'essence atteignent un
niveau historique supérieur à celui qui
a conduit au mouvement des gilet jaune
en janvier 2018 nos tarifs du gaz ont
augmenté de 40% en 2021 et celui de
l'électricité malgré les mesures prises
à augmenter encore hier matin de 4%
face à ces hausses le gouvernement n'est
pas rester immobile mais malheureusement
les mesures prises sont largement
insuffisantes souvent inadaptés quand
elles ne sont pas purement et simplement
néfastes elles sont insuffisantes et
inadaptées par leur caractère général
est possible et le chèque inflation d'un
montant de 100 euros attribuée
uniformément quelles que soient les
situations en témoigne le gouvernement
une fois de plus semble ignorer que les
habitants des territoires ruraux sont
particulièrement impactés par ces
hausses des prix
un logement en zone rurale consomme 33 %
d'énergie en plus qu'un logement en
centre ville le surcoût moyen des
dépenses de carburants des ménages en
milieu rural est quant à lui de 40%
supérieur à la moyenne nationale
pourquoi ne pas avoir institué un
dispositif qui intègre cette réalité au
delà de cette question pourquoi alors
que plus de la moitié du prix du litre
d'essence à la pompe revient aujourd'hui
à l'état par le biais de la fiscalité le
gouvernement n'at-il pas souhaité
utiliser ce levier pour alléger la
charge qui pèse sur nos concitoyens
comment ne pas être choqué que les
recettes de l'état augmentent grâce à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et
j'indique que la fiscalité énergétique
représente 900 euros par ménage par an
et on 165 euros pour les ménages en
milieu rural cette situation est
d'autant plus insupportable que malgré
les demandes réitérées de notre
assemblée depuis un certain nombre
d'années ces ressources dégagées ne sont
pas affectés à la transition écologique
ni aux économies d'énergie je souhaite
également attirer votre attention sur
une question qui ne semble pas jusqu'à
présent préoccuper le gouvernement et
qui est importante les conséquences de
la hausse du prix de l'énergie pour les
collectivités locales
les collectivités locales et notamment
les communes voient leur facture
énergétique augmenter fortement elles
seront très certainement obliger un
moment donné de répercuter ces dépenses
supplémentaires en augmentant la
fiscalité locale ou bien en abondant
dans des projets d'intérêt local
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
éviter ce qui constituerait une double
peine l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie et l'augmentation des impôts
consécutive à l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie pour les collectivités locales
autre question qu'en est il du
rattrapage du blocage des prix sur les
prix de l'électricité qui a été évoqué
par la commission de régulation
d'énergie à l'horizon 2023
enfin je voudrais pour terminer dès
dénoncé entoure les décisions néfastes
et responsables qui ont été prises
concernant odf
l'augmentation du volume d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire vendu à prix réduits
par odf coûtera 8 milliards d'euros à
cette entreprise huit milliards c'est
l'équivalent du prix estimé d'un nouveau
réacteur au père de ce choix est juste
insupportable alors qu edf est endetté à
hauteur de 40 milliards d'euros et qu'il
doit faire face un mur d'investissement
de 80 à 100 milliards dans les années
qui viennent
ces décisions viennent malheureusement
parachever un quinquennat de politique
erratique sur le nucléaire qui a
fragilisé l'un des plus beaux fleurons
de notre industrie de toute évidence
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues les choix du
gouvernement ne sont pertinents ni pour
les ménages ni pour edf est donc grand
temps de revoir ses décisions pour
répondre réellement aux attentes et aux
besoins de nos concitoyens et aux enjeux
énergétiques de notre pays je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
impeccable impeccable tellement
impeccable que sur le coup le ministre
souhaite intervenir vous avez la parole
pour deux minutes monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président en quelques
mots pour réagir à la fois cette
intervention et aux précédentes dire
d'abord comme lorsqu'il est dit ou
annoncé que le gouvernement n'a pas une
recours à la fiscalité pour amortir la
hausse du coût de l'énergie pour les
ménages ses formes c'est faux puisque
l'une des principales mesures que nous
avons prises pour limiter la hausse du
coût de l'électricité vise à abaisser la
télé et feu de 21 points 5 à 0 5% ce qui
se meut représente un manque à gagner de
8 milliards pour l'état et face à une
augmentation des cours encore plus
importante nous avons effectivement
demandé à edf de produire plus au titre
de la reine avec un coût de 8 milliards
d'euros j'entends les interventions de
ceux qui s'inquiètent des conséquences
pour edf de ses huit milliards d'euros
c'est d'abord une décision que nous
avons prise en pesant l'ensemble des
avantages et des inconvénients mais je
voudrais dire aussi que je n'ai pas
entendu de contre-proposition permettant
d'en d'éviter aux ménages de faire face
à une augmentation de leur facture
d'électricité de 40 % au mois de février
ce qui aurait été le cas si nous n'avons
pas pris les décisions que nous avons
prises tant en matière thijs et feu
qu'en matière d'augmentation des volumes
de la reine enfin pour ce qui concerne
la question des collectivités que
sénateur maurey a évoqué un instant
environ trente mille communes
bénéficient du tarif réglementé puisque
celui ci s'applique à toutes les
collectivités ayant une section de
fonctionnement inférieur à 2 millions
d'euros ou de moins de 10 e tp dans leur
personnel pour les autres que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'indiquer tout à l'heure que
le bénéfice de la baisse de la tsf eux
leur était acquise que le bénéfice des
conséquences de l'augmentation du volume
de la reine leur était acquise j'ai
aussi souligné que en 2022 et c'est
heureux la fiscalité va augmenter
mécaniquement de 3 4% du fait de la
révision des valeurs locatives en
application de la formule arrêtée fin
2017 et à l'occasion du pdf pour 2018 et
de dire aussi que la part de tva dont
bénéficient les collectivités va
augmenter plus de 800 millions d'euros
pour les régions de plus de 800 millions
d'euros pour les départements depuis de
400 millions d'euros pour les
intercommunalités le sénateur mark qui
m'interrogeait souligné ce n'était pas
le sénateur mark pardonnez moi le
sénateur qui m'interrogeait qui était du
groupe et l'air souligné que des
différentes associations estimé le
surcoût à un milliard d'euros mais
quelques chiffres que j'ai énoncé
montrer ses rations que les
collectivités doivent pouvoir y faire
face ça ne nous empêche pas d'y rester
extrêmement attentifs
monsieur le sénateur maurey vous avez
une minute pour répondre au ministre
remercié le président très très
rapidement j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit
le ministre mais mais sur edf il
n'apporte aucun élément concret et en
commission des finances nous l'avons
entendu avec le miz bruno le maire dira
nous serons aux côtés d'edf mais ça veut
dire quoi y'a rien de concret dans ce
qui est dit par rapport à l'effort
demandé par le gouvernement à edf et à
ce que signifie nous serons aux côtés
d'edf pour l'avenir encore une fois
c'est un fleuron important de notre
industrie et aujourd'hui on le met en
difficulté quant à sa réponse sur
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie pour
les collectivités locales je suis pas le
seul à m'en inquiéter à toutes les
associations d'élus et notamment les
maires ruraux ont évoqué le le fait que
ça aurait des conséquences qui serait
extrêmement difficile à supporter donc
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
vous n'avez pas pleinement rassuré très
bien la parole maintenant madame
guylaine pantel pour le groupe r d est
ce pour cinq minutes
vous voulez
allez-y monsieur fabien gay je n'ose
vous demandez sur la base de quel
article mais bon ma générosité naturelle
en la matière l arctique qui vous sied
le mieux au président il ya d'abord je
ne ferai pas de politique juste je le
dis on est en fait un nouveau débat on
essaye des choses j'estime que monsieur
ils sont monsieur compta et moi même
soit vous répondez à chacun à chaque
intervention est donc du coup on a une
réplique soit vous répondez à personne
mais vous ça me semble assez incohérent
politiquement de choisir à qui on
intervient et de fait que nous on ne
puisse pas répondre que ni monsieur et
sony messieurs gontard ni moi-même
puissions répondre voyez je n'ai pas
intervenu sur le sujet edf mais
j'interviens dans le cadre du débat et
c'est pour ça que je me suis permis vous
avez vous avez raison vous avez raison
cher collègue
peut-être mais c'est pas moi d'en
décider il faudra revoir ça sur ce
système peut-être que lorsque le
ministre ne répondra que par exemple à
un sur quatre peut-être qu'on pourrait
donner une minute à chacun des autres
que ce que celui qui est le dernier est
quoi le b pour le moment c'est pas la
règle donc je transmettrai monsieur guay
très bien madame pantel je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre van hamme
la ministre mes chers collègues les prix
les prix de l'énergie s'emballe dans le
monde après deux âmes de pandémie la
reprise de l'économie et donc de la
demande en gaz combiné à la faiblesse
des stocks et aux crises géopolitiques
crée des tensions sur les marchés de
gros de l'énergie entraînant une forte
inflation au détriment du pouvoir
d'achat des français
selon la note de conjoncture publiée par
l'insee en décembre les prix d'énergie
ont augmenté de 18,6 pour cent dans
l'ensemble
41% pour le gas 21% pour les chances et
4 pour ça pour l'électricité alors que
la précarité énergétique touche
5,6 millions de ménages en temps normal
cette envolée risque malheureusement
d'en faire basculer beaucoup d'autres
nous pillons à l'instar de nos voisins
européens le prix de notre dépendance
aux énergies fossiles nous payons en ski
concert de prix de l'électricité
l'application du principe du coût
marginal que la phrase souhaiterait
semble-t-il révisé dans le cadre d'une
éventuelle réforme du marché européen de
l'énergie
il faut le reconnaître le gouvernement a
réussi pour l'instant à contenir
l'inflation en dessous de la moyenne
européenne et à préserver une partie du
pouvoir d'achat des français grâce à
plusieurs mesures le chèque énergie
supplémentaire de 100 euros l'indemnité
de 100 euros pour un million environ de
pardon 38 millions de personnes le
bouclier tarifaire avec le gel des
tarifs réglementés de gaz et la
limitation de la hausse des tarifs
réglementés de vente de l'électricité
la baisse de la taxe sur l'électricité
la taxe intérieure sur la consommation
finale déficits et à ce niveau minimum
est un fait récemment la revalorisation
de 10 % du barème de l'indemnité
kilométrique l'addition total plus de 15
milliards d'euros pour atteindre
l'étincelle d'une crise sociale
jusqu où pourra-t-on tenir ainsi alors
qu'il ne s'agit que d'un pansement a
fait de l'adhérence face à une évolution
structurelle de surcroît ces mesures
rate une partie de leur cible puisque
les aides versées ont été tous dressent
en tenir compte des critères
d'éloignement ce qui pénalise de fait
des territoires hyperburo ainsi quid des
mesures de soutien des collectivités
locales territoriales qui souffrent tout
autant de ces hausses de prix notre
groupe a régulièrement l'occasion de
s'exprimer les particularités
géographiques et climatiques de ces
territoires exige d'être considérés à
leur juste mesure à l'heure de
l'achèvement de votre mandat nous
pouvons déplorer à ce sujet la faiblesse
de votre engagement en ce sens et ce
malgré nos nombreuses interpellations
mais il est encore temps de reconnaître
que le poids de ces postes de dépenses
pèse plus lourdement pour les français
en zone rurale j'en conviens une
réduction des taxes énergétique ou de la
tva et complexes à appliquer notre pays
est très dépendant de ces taxes
en outre elle ne permettrait pas de
viser spécifiquement les ménages
modestes ou issues de certains
territoires la transition énergétique ne
pourra malheureusement se faire qu'au
moyen d'un effort considérable et n'aura
pas pour effet d' infléchir à la baisse
la facture de nos concitoyens les prix
de l'énergie vont inévitablement
continuer leur ascension car l'énergie à
un prix
les investissements massifs dans
décarbonation le développement des
réseaux intelligents ou encore le
stockage auront un coût que ce soit pour
le consommateur ou de contribuables nous
sommes véritablement sur le fil du
rasoir en même temps il est urgent de
redoubler d'efforts en matière
d'économie d'énergie sachant que l'une
des principales causes la précarité
énergétique réside dans la mauvaise
isolation des logements
accès l'auront donc leur rénovation
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
si l'état doit tout faire pour préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des français et les
finances des collectivités locales
quelles réponses durables souhaitez vous
impulsez et comment comptez vous les
coordonnées avec nos partenaires état
membre de l'union européenne
je vous remercie
merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
claude tissot pour le groupe socialiste
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
depuis de nombreux mois dans un profond
désarroi les françaises et les français
sont confrontés à une hausse continue
des prix des produits du quotidien et à
une explosion de leur facture
énergétique selon l'insee dans la note
de conjoncture du mois de décembre 2021
les prix à la consommation du gaz des
carburants électricité ont
respectivement augmenté de 41% 21 % et 3
% entre décembre 2001 et octobre 2021
dans cette même étude la hausse des prix
depuis le début d'année 2021 a conduit
un surcroît de dépenses mensuelles
d'énergie d'un peu plus de 40 euros en
moyenne par ménage dont 20 euros pour
les carburants toutefois ces moyens le
cache de fortes disparités entre les
foyers selon lui de résidence a été dit
en deux ans la facture énergétique a
grimpé en moyenne de 43 euros dans les
communes rurales contre 30 euros dans
l'agglomération parisienne de même la
facture énergétique pèse plus lourdement
dans le budget total des ménages à
faible revenu cette dépenses contraintes
liées aux énergies ne fait donc que
renforcer les inégalités sociales et
territoriales de plus dans un contexte
où notre économie se relance
progressivement se former des prix des
énergies conduit à de très lourdes
conséquences sur la compétitivité de nos
entreprises la hausse des prix des
énergies vient s'ajouter à
l'augmentation des coûts des matières
premières qui se répercute
indéniablement sur prix d'achat pour les
consommateurs
face à ce constat madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre votre gouvernement
a fait le choix de prendre ses décisions
des décisions court termiste sans
s'attaquer aux réelles difficultés et
l'enjeu du marché de l'énergie le
bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité
l'augmentation du chèque énergie et la
création de l'indemnité d'inflation sont
des premières mesures pertinentes pour
soulager le budget des ménages toutefois
sans contester leur bien-fondé nous
pouvons nous interroger sur le ciblage
et le niveau de chacune de ces aides
dans une récente étude la dame fixe
recommande l'ademe recommandé de fixer
le montant du chèque énergie à 710 euros
pour être réellement utile auprès des
foyers qui souffrent de la précarité
énergétique l'envoi d'un chèque énergie
200 euros durant le mois de décembre a
certainement été un soulagement pour les
ménages concernés mais cela ne mais ce
n'est pas assez pour les foyers qui ont
vu leurs dépenses d'énergie augmenté de
40 euros par mois en 2021 vous me
répondrez très certainement que
l'indemnité inflation et l'augmentation
du barème de l'indemnité kilométrique
récemment annoncée par le 1er mai istres
viennent compléter ce dispositif
malheureusement elle aussi souffre
d'hasselt ciblage un certain
d'indemnités inflation créer des
situations d'inégalité entre salariés
d'une même entreprise et parfois au sein
d'un même foyer le réhaussement de 10% à
nîmes kilométrique est également une
demi mesure ne concerne que les français
imposables qui peuvent déclarer leurs
frais professionnels et en vous
concentrant sur les gros rouleurs vous
semblez malheureusement oublié les 17
millions de français qui sont contraints
de prendre tous les jours leur voiture
pour aller travailler tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès à des
transports en commun et sur ses 17
millions la moitié gagnent moins de 1700
euros net par mois face à ces prix face
aux prix record des carburants
atteint ces dernières semaines votre
gouvernement doit impérativement agir
auprès de ces français qui ont ce qu'ils
sont les premiers corps des face à la
hausse des prix des énergies depuis
plusieurs mois notre groupe ainsi que
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
nous en nous avons proposé plusieurs
mesures immédiates la création d'un
bouquet tarifaire énergétique permettant
l'accès à un volume minimal de gaz de
fioul ou d'électricité à un tarif très
bas le doublement du chèque énergie
versée automatiquement afin de mettre
fin au non recours malheureusement
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
cette crise met en lumière les impensés
les impréparations de la politique
énergétique du gouvernement cette
situation était prévisible dès le début
de la pandémie due qu'au but de lakovic
19 nous alertions avec mes collègues de
la commission des affaires économiques
sur du sénat sur l'effet inflationniste
en sortie de crise des prix pouvant
flamber si l'offre d'énergie ne
parvenait pas à accompagner la demande
cette impréparation qui est également
celle des gouvernements précédents je
vous rassure conduit à dépenser au moins
15 milliards d'euros dans les mesures
d'urgence plutôt que dans des projets de
long terme sans critiquer le montant
consacré nous nous étonnons davantage au
sein de notre groupe que vous ne diriez
pas des leçons et des enseignements de
cette crise la libéralisation à
l'extrême du marché d'énergie qui se
retrouve tiraillé entre injonctions
européennes et influence géopolitique
est la cause de cette crise profonde le
relèvement du plafond de la reine des 10
décidé en ce début d'année est un nouvel
exemple de votre orientations
ultralibérales c'était très bien dit
tout à l'heure cette mesure bénéficiera
uniquement aux fournisseurs au détriment
de l'opérateur historique edf qui a
pourtant besoin de fonds pour investir
durablement vous refusez votre rôle
d'être actionnaire et vous préféré
sacrifier une entreprise publique qui
est indispensable à la planification
énergétique pour les décennies à venir
pourtant dans un rapport de novembre
2021 sur les choix de production
électrique la cour des comptes a rappelé
la nécessité d'anticiper et de prévoir
pour renouveler notre mix énergétique
ainsi madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre pour qu'une telle crise ne se
reproduise plus et l'impact plus aussi
durement nos concitoyens nous vous
soumettons trois principaux conseils de
long terme et d'anticipation revenons et
politique et générale énergétique
volontariste de l'état et du
gouvernement avec une puissance publique
assumé qui investit massivement dans ces
entreprises publiques réformant le
marché européen de l'énergie votre
gouvernement vos profiter de la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne pour un fils d imposer une
nouvelle direction et enfin planifions à
très long terme après avoir conduit une
large concertation citoyenne et
parlementaires pour assurer un bouquet
énergétique en étant là nestea la
nécessaire transition écologique la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
français et la souveraineté énergétique
de notre pays je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur didier rambaud pour
le groupe air des pays pour six minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'inflation et là c'est vrai elle touche
particulièrement le secteur de l'énergie
est malheureusement à bien observer des
dernières nouvelles l'inflation est en
train de s'installer dans le quotidien
des français et des françaises selon la
dernière estimation provisoire de
l'insee les prix de l'énergie ont bondi
de plus de 19 7 % sur une période d'un
an gaz électricité carburant rien n'est
épargné alors si la situation est à
prendre au sérieux est elle pour autant
catastrophique
est-ce que tout va mal comme certains le
clament à longueur de journée depuis
quelques semaines non je ne crois pas la
situation actuelle est difficile pour un
certain nombre de français mais je ne
crois pas que cette description soit
juste parce que la situation économique
va se prendre dans sa globalité peut-on
ici évoqué un taux de croissance de 7%
du jamais vu depuis 1969 avec une telle
croissance la france devrait signer une
des meilleures connu meilleure
performance de la zone euro deux points
au dessus de la croissance moyen estimé
à 5% cela se traduit avec un taux de
chômage historiquement faible proche du
plein emploi
saluant au passage la politique du quoi
qu'il en coûte reconnu par des
observateurs économiques qui a permis de
sauvegarder nos entreprises et nos
emplois pour autant qui dit croissance
dit l'inflation par la demande surtout
dans le contexte international et
sanitaires que nous connaissons après
une année 2009 1 de paralysie économique
en raison du coût vide le rebond de la
consommation des ménages et la
reconstitution des stocks des
entreprises ont fait exploser la demande
cela entraîne une hausse du cours de
nombreuses matières premières le
contexte international est certes pour
beaucoup dans l'explosion des prix
d'énergie mais n'oublions pas qu'un
retour de l'inflation est la conséquence
d'un retour à la croissance aussi pour
chaque situation le gouvernement s'est
penché sur le problème en question pour
apporter une solution pour que face à
chaque secteur énergétique touchées par
l'inflation le gouvernement a travaillé
pour agir et créer des dispositifs
ciblée et adaptée des solutions
concrètes tant son inflation que ce le
porte-monnaie de nos concitoyens le gaz
le 30 septembre dernier le premier
ministre a annoncé le gel des tarifs
réglementés du gaz autrement dit il a
été décidé de bloquer les prix jusqu'en
avril 2022 je parle bien entendu de
boucliers tarifaire bouclier qui a pour
but de protéger l'ensemble des ménages
de la flambée historique que nous
connaissons en ce moment sans ce
bouclier tarifaire l'inflation aurait
été insupportable
les prix du gaz augmente heureux
aujourd'hui de 66 % financièrement la
mesure permet donc d'éviter une hausse
de la facture de gaz d'environ 900 euros
ensuite sur l'électricité qui vous le
savez est un secteur en réalité
intimement lié à celui du gaz là aussi
du bouclier tarifaire porte ses fruits
puisque les prix d'électricité augmente
aujourd'hui 2 4% certes mais sans ce
bouclier tarifaire il aurait augmenté de
44% mes chers collègues rendez vous
compte nous ne nous limitons autant que
faire se peut les dégâts observés un
instant la situation chez nos voisins
européens
en espagne la facture d'électricité
passe de 1000 à 1500 euros en italie la
facture passe de 1000 à 2000 290 euros
en france le gel des prix permet là
encore d'éviter en moyenne une hausse de
300 euros des factures d'électricité
alors je me pose une question à combien
s'élèverait aujourd'hui les factures de
gaz et d'électricité des français sans
le bouclier tarifaire la mesure était
donc nécessaire et adaptée pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat et des fins de mois
et mieux encore le gouvernement ne s'est
pas contenté de ce bouclier il a ensuite
été question de créer des dispositifs
ciblés pour accompagner les ménages les
plus modestes dans la situation délicate
que nous vivons je pense d'une part ou
chèque énergie exceptionnelle un chèque
de 100 euros versés à six millions de
ménages en décembre dernier je pense
d'autre part à l'inflation 200 euros
versée aux françaises et aux français
qui gagnent moins de 2000 euros net par
mois une indemnité qui concerne 38
millions de français l'objectif est
clair limiter l'impact de la force de
l'inflation sur le porte monnaie le
résultat me semble également clair les
mesures sont salués par un grand nombre
de français enfin je reviens sur un
sujet explosif celui du prix des
carburants
incontestablement la hausse est
impressionnante car depuis le mois de ce
depuis le mois de septembre les prix du
litre de sans plomb 95 de sans-plomb 98
ou du gazole frôlé en ce moment les deux
euros si ce n'est pas déjà fait dans
certains territoires face à cela le
gouvernement a décidé de prendre une
mesure supplémentaire large et
protectrice au bénéfice de celles et
ceux qui quotidiennement utilisent leur
voiture pour travailler et sans pouvoir
bénéficier d'un réseau de transport en
commun telle est la raison d'être de la
revalorisation du barème kilométrique de
10% une mesure volontairement ciblé qui
permettra une économie moyenne de 150
euros par bénéficiaire mais il faut
regarder de plus près quand même la
situation de celles et ceux qui ne
paient pas l'impôt sur le revenu mes
chers collègues se sont autant de
mesures adaptées qui impacte déjà le que
le quotidien de nos concitoyens là où la
baisse des taxes proposées par certaines
oppositions aurait sans doute été plus
longue à mettre en place inefficace donc
aux yeux de l'opinion publique dé
raisonnable économiquement et
particulièrement tous sauf sage environ
environnementalement enfin ce que je
veux souligner c'est plus le
gouvernement n'a pas attendu la la scion
ni la crise sanitaire pour se préoccuper
du pouvoir d'achat des français la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
baisse des impôts sur les sociétés comme
pour les ménages la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles la mise en place des
dispositifs passeport pass culture la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la revalorisation de la
prime d'activité et des salaires des
soignants dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé depuis 2010 est le gouvernement a
fait ce qu'aucun gouvernement n'a été
capable de faire sur la même période en
matière de pouvoir d'achat autant
d'exemples de mesures concrètes qui
impacte la vie des français et lorsqu'on
ajoute le rebond de 7 % de la croissance
qui n'a rien d'automatique alors oui je
crois que nous pouvons regarder l'avenir
avec vigilance certes mais surtout avec
optimisme merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame vanina
paolig agen pour le groupe les
indépendants pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2020 le
monde s'est arrêté le trafic aérien a
chuté de 66% le prix du pétrole s'étant
réduit qu'il est devenu négatif le baril
de brent je vous le rappelle s'est
échangé à cette période ou 1,38 dollar
la lutte contre la pandémie a gelé
l'activité humaine
comment croire que moins de deux ans
plus tard nous serions confrontés à une
flambée des prix de l'énergie il s'agit
en vérité du revers d'une même médaille
une médaille très positive parce que des
vaccins efficaces ont été mis au point
et que le virus a muté à priori moins
dangereusement ces derniers temps nous
avons pu vivre à nouveau à peu près
normalement nous avons pu reprendre le
chemin du travail la reprise économique
entraînant une forte demande a renchéri
le prix de nombreuses matières premières
et notamment ceux de l'énergie
tout au long de cette crise sanitaire
qui se poursuit le gouvernement et le
parlement ont travaillé à protéger au
mieux la santé nos concitoyens nous
avons également veiller à préserver le
tissu économique de notre pays pour
amortir le choc de la pandémie dans nos
territoires
ces mesures de soutien indispensable
pour bon nombre d'acteurs présente
toutefois de sérieux biais elles
favorisent l'inflation et augmente la
dette de notre état deux épées de
damoclès qui menace l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens le chemin de crête est
étroit car l'énergie est l'un des postes
de dépenses a été rappelé les plus
importants de nos concitoyens nous avons
tous en mémoire je pense les
conséquences teinté de jaune fluo de la
hausse de la fiscalité sur les
hydrocarbures en 2018
parce qu'ils en ont besoin pour se
chauffer pour se déplacer pour
travailler nos concitoyens sont à la
merci des variations du prix de
l'énergie ne rien faire c'est prendre le
risque de ralentir la reprise et de
laisser nombre de nos concitoyens en
difficulté
compenser les hausses c'est quand même
tirer davantage sur un heiva ce type
déjà bien entendu de nos finances
publiques
depuis descendre jusqu'en février les
moins aisés reçoit un chèque inflation
de 100 euros il ya quelques jours le
gouvernement a annoncé une
revalorisation du barème de l'indemnité
kilométrique de 10% au bénéfice de
quelques deux millions et demi de foyers
français ces mesures visent à contrer
les effets d'une inflation que nous
espérons tous provisoires et s'adresse à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
turgot dont la statue nous surplombe
nous regarde depuis quelques temps je
pense avec un peu plus de sévérité la
santé de nos finances publiques le
préoccupe
l'état ne peut pas tout il ne faut donc
pas tout attendre de lui turgot disait
qu'un des plus grands obstacles à
l'économie des finances publiques et la
multitude des demandes dont louise 16
était content une continuellement à saïd
et que la trop grande facilité de ses
prédécesseurs à les accueillir a
malheureusement autorisé s'il nous faut
agir face à l'urgence nous devons
également regarder avec lucidité ce que
le futur nous réserve la fin du recours
aux énergies fossiles et le dérèglement
climatique vont probablement encore
renchérir les prix de l'énergie cette
perspective de nous inciter à travailler
et investir davantage dans la recherche
et le développement de solutions
alternatives
le champ des possibles est vaste nous
devons oeuvrer à produire plus
efficacement une énergie plus durable
nous devons étudier attentivement les
moyens de renforcer l'efficacité
énergétique de nos bâtiments notamment
via la rénovation thermique mais aussi
grâce à l'automation l'autoconsommation
collective au stockage et nous devons
faire de même avec nos véhicules la
transition écologique est une nécessité
au regard du dérèglement climatique
il est aussi essentiel que notre pays
cultivent et renforça souveraineté en ce
domaine un pessimiste voit la difficulté
dans chaque opportunité un optimiste
voit l'opportunité dans chaque
difficulté
nous disait soeur winston churchill nous
pouvons faire le choix de voir dans le
défi climatique d'immenses opportunités
de développement pour notre économie le
gouvernement a annoncé des
investissements considérables dans le
cadre du plan 2030
certains concernent des filières
d'avenir comme l'hydrogène vers la
décarbonation d'autres industries ou
encore la production du premier avion
bas carbone je vais dans l'aube
continuer à soutenir des projets en ce
sens le groupe les indépendants est
attaché à la bonne gestion des finances
publiques si les mesures conjoncturelles
sont incontournables il faut veiller à
ne pas les multiplier nous pensons en
effet que les fonds publics sont bien
mieux employés lorsqu'ils sont investis
dans le secteur novateur susceptibles de
contribuer à la souveraineté de notre
pays et au développement de son économie
si la france conçoit des technologies
durables de demain nos finances
publiques et le pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes s'en ressentiront
favorablement je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenat monsieur daniel gremillet pour
le groupe l'est républicain pour sept
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous savons tous ici la france est
confrontée à une crise sans précédent
des prix des énergies entre le printemps
2020 et hier les prix de marché ont été
multiplié par 2,5 pour le pétrole 3 pour
le gaz existent pour expliciter certes
il n'y a pas que la france c'est aussi
un contexte mondial et européen
cette hausse s'est répercutée sur les
prix à la pompe qui s'élève à 1,7 euro
pour un litre pour l'essence et le
gasoil de 1,1 euro par litre pour le
fioul s'est aussi répercuté sur les
tarifs réglementés de vente du stress %
pour le gaz en octobre dernier 4 % pour
électricité ce mois de février or cette
flambée était prévisible dès juin 2020
la commission des affaires économiques
dans son plan de relance avait alerté
sur un effet inflationniste en sortie de
crise nous avions même proposé normale
et russian du chèque énergie dans le
cadre de nos travaux budgétaires on en
vend dernier nous avions également
dénoncé un bouclier tarifaire tardif est
incomplet regrettant le manque d' écoute
et d'évaluation nous avions même suggéré
de relever les aides aux ménages aux
entreprises et collectivités et
d'accélérer l'application des
fournisseurs de recours et des
correspondants solidarité précarité car
cette flambée
mais sous tension l'ensemble des
secteurs énergétiques elle érode sur le
plan de pouvoir d'achat des ménages car
l'énergie représente 10% de leur budget
à terme une hausse de la précarité
énergétique est à craindre nous avons
déjà aujourd'hui 3,5 millions de ménages
qui sont touchés cette flambée obstrue
la reprise durable de notre économie car
l'énergie représente 7 % de notre
produit intérieur brut les entreprises
energo intensives sont touchés mais
aussi nos pme et tpe au delà des prix
des énergies ceux de leurs co produit
ormond aussi d'ammoniaque pour les
agriculteurs par exemple un du minium
pour les industriels et que dire des
métaux rares indispensables un
transition énergétique
cette flambée pèse sur les contrats de
fourniture des collectivités selon la
fédération nationale des collectivités
concédantes et j les hausses observées
sur plusieurs millions milliers de
points de livraison s'établissent entre
20 et 300 pour cent cette flambée
désorganise le secteur de l'énergie
c'est vrai au premier chef pour le
groupe edf qui évalue à 8 milliard
d'euros le coût d'un relèvement du
plafond de l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique et de
l'action sur les tarifs réglementés de
vente d'électricité
l'annnonce de sera l'allemand a
constitué un choc pour son pdg elle a
entraîné une dégradation de sa notation
et l'organisation d'une trêve de plus
certains fournisseurs adhésif ont ctrc
ont cessé leurs activités à l'instar de
leclerc énergie laissant sur le banc du
chemin mille quatre cent quarante mille
abonnés dans ce contexte la politique
énergétique à court terme du
gouvernement me semble erratique en
premier lieu le boulier le bouclier
tarifaire est mal calibré il l'est dans
son montant car l'attribution de 100
euros via le chèque énergie ou
l'indemnité inflation à l'automne a été
largement rattrapé par la hausse des
prix depuis heures il l'est aussi dans
son champ car les tarifs réglementés de
vente sur lesquelles se focalisent les
blocages ou des compensations ne
concerne que cette mary 2 5% de la
consommation de gaz et 28 % de son
électricité
en deuxième lieu de boucliers tarifaires
et mal évaluées lors du budget le
gouvernement avait estimé à 6 milliards
d'euros la baisse de la taxe de
consommation finale d'électricité on en
est à 8 milliard d'euros aujourd'hui
jusqu'où ira-t-on en dernier lieu le
bouclier tarifaire est mal anticipé
aucune mesure n'est prévue au delà 2022
or la flambée des prix des énergies
pourrait bien durer par ailleurs
l'action soit établie réglementés
pourraient se répercuter in fine et sur
les ménages et les entreprises lorsque
l'on sait que la mesure proposée pour le
tout cas ce n'est qu'un dispositif de
lissage courant jusqu'en janvier 2023 et
que les tarifs réglementés de vente de
gaz disparaîtront dès juillet 2023 de
graves difficultés sont à prévoir
de plus aucune conséquence financière
nette tirée pour le groupe edf on relève
le plafond de la reine deux cents à 121
1 120 térawattheures mais son prix
stagnent raconte sylvia 8,5 euros le
mégawattheure contre le 42e actu le
monde c'est dérisoire alors que le prix
de marché et de l'exciter s'envole à
plus de 200 euros au delà la politique
énergétique à long terme du gouvernement
ne semblent
indigente si les mesures d'urgence sont
indispensables et leur modèle de
financement et rod nos capacités
d'investissement
les 8 milliards d'euros perdus par le
groupe edf c'est autant de mois pour ses
projets or le grand carénage suppose
cinquante mille milliards d'euros au
total et la transition énergétique 10
milliards d'euros annuels
comment dans ces conditions financer la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs 3e
perd 46 milliard d'euros
pire la politique d ornement évalue
études et lui le pardon des vraies
décisions à prendre
car il faut le dire la vérité tout
d'abord un fermeture des réacteurs
existants fragilise notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement rt ainsi relever
sont dans son bilan prévisionnel une
situation de vigilance pour les trois
prochaines vers plus encore l'atteinte
de ces objectifs décarbonation du paquet
d'ajustement 55 n'est possible qu'en
intégrant l'énergie nucléaire la
taxonomie verte enfin niveau milices
n'est plus tenable s'agissant de la
relance de la filière nucléaire perte
est ainsi indiqué dans ce rapport au
futur verger tic de mes 50 qu'il y a
urgence se mobiliser au total la crise
des prix de l'énergie algie comme un
révélateur des insuffisances de la
politique du gouvernement pour ma part
je suis convaincu que le soutien au
pouvoir d'achat des ménages passe par un
soutien la production d'énergie
nucléaire pour limiter notre dépendance
aux importations d'hydrocarbures et
garantir un prix d'électricité faible
est identique à tous les français
surtout territoire en définitive un vrai
bouclier tarifaire ne devrait pas
consister en une fuite en avant des
finances publiques mais une relance de
vie sains nucléaire colonne vertébrale
de notre souveraineté énergétique de la
france merci
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
pierre moga pour le groupe union
centriste pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la crise actuelle a démontré tout
d'abord notre forte dépendance aux
énergies fossiles qui grève le pouvoir
d'achat des français et les ambitions
économiques de nos entreprises rappelons
en effet que si le nucléaire représente
70% de l'électricité produite en france
ils représentent moins de 20% de
l'énergie finale utilisé par les
français la prépondérance du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité ne doit
pas occulter la dépendance de la france
mais plus généralement de l'europe aux
énergies fossiles importées pour ses
besoins en énergie
la crise actuelle a rappelé le besoin de
réformer le marché européen de l'énergie
afin de protéger le consommateur des
variations d'un coût marginal qui fixe
le prix unique du marché du
mégawattheure je salue ainsi la position
française consistant à défendre le prix
du marché plus fidèle au cou domestique
moyenne de production et aux efforts de
décarbonation des mix car sans une telle
réforme et alors que le prix des
énergies fossiles sera inévitablement
amenés à augmenter la france ne
bénéficient pas de ces choix or nos
choix collectifs ont conduit à faire de
notre pays le champion du monde de dpi
décarbonés avec une électricité
produisant 10 fois moins de gaz à effet
de serre que nos voisins allemands grâce
à nos centrales et à nos barrages il est
temps d'accélérer l'électrification de
nos usages et la décarbonation de
l'économie en découplant le prix de
l'électricité du prix des énergies
fossiles
cela m'amène à défendre la logique a dit
yves rappelé par rte c'est à dire la
complémentarité non seulement possible
mais nécessaire entre les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes et une
énergie nucléaire pilotable la seconde
permettant à réalité d'accompagner
l'essor des premières en effet le
nucléaire n'est pas un problème mais une
partie de la solution à la transition
énergétique et permettra d'assurer aux
français une stabilité du prix de
l'électricité
si les coûts bruts des centrales
nucléaires sont effectivement élevé la
flexibilité que permet cette énergie
l'amortissement des réseaux bref le coup
système complet fait dire aux
gestionnaires du réseau que construire
de nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires et
pertinents du point de vue économique et
permettra d'éviter l'exclusion des
factures énergétiques
en parallèle d'une hausse assurer des
énergies fossiles le tout en renforçant
notre indépendance énergétique
à ce titre j'ai déposé avec mon collègue
jean françois longeot une proposition de
résolution tendant à accompagner l'essor
du nouveau nucléaire en france en ce que
premièrement les mini réacteur
permettent d'envisager de nouveaux
usages du nucléaire contribuant à la
décarbonation de notre économie
production de chaleur
d'hydrogène d'électricité pour les
industriels et ses
seconds vendre la quatrième génération
des réacteurs pour laquelle notre pays
doit redéfinir ses ambitions permettra
de répondre aux deux principales
critiques adressées au nucléaire via une
sécurité accrue et un multi recyclage
des déchets nucléaires aussi un effort
de recherche et de développement est
nécessaire
dès lors monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre cannes est il des propositions
françaises de réforme du marché européen
de l'énergie
quelles sont les ambitions françaises
pour utiliser le nucléaire comme levier
d'une diminution des tarifs d'énergie et
comme amortisseur de la crise que nous
vivons je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
thierry cozic pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour 4
minutes
ce prix monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui nous nous
retrouvons à débattre de l'énergie car
disons le franchement nous traversons
une crise une crise que personne n'avait
vu venir une crise provoquée par une
conjonction d'événements et de facteur
imprévu qui se sont additionnés pour
provoquer une explosion des prix du gaz
qu'il gagne de proche en proche tous les
marchés de l'énergie et révèle la
faillite de l'europe dans ce domaine
cette même europe qui bâtit sur la seule
concurrence a choisi d'exposer
l'ensemble de l'économie et des ménages
à la volatilité des marchés il faut être
clair la crise que nous connaissons
n'est ni lié à une hausse de la
consommation ni à une augmentation des
coûts de production mais c'était la
libéralisation du secteur que l'on doit
la situation pour laquelle nous sommes
de fait le système actuel ne permet même
pas de financer les investissements
nécessaires car ils n'offrent aucune
visibilité
un changement de cap doit être
rapidement mener autrement il risque
d'être impossible de mener une
transition écologique acceptée par
l'ensemble des populations
l'origine de cette dépendance
énergétique est multiple si la faiblesse
de la politique européenne de l'énergie
en est une la crise économique de 2008 a
aussi découragé certains états membres à
investir dans des infrastructures
énergétiques ou dans la rénovation leurs
infrastructures vieillissantes dans ce
contexte morose de nombreux pays hors
union ont aussi profité de l'absence
d'autoroutes de l'énergie entre les 28
pour signer des partenariats
d'approvisionnement avec certains
d'entre eux
confronté à l'hystérie des marchés
l'europe avance en ordre dispersé chaque
gouvernement tente de limiter la casse
pour sa population depuis le milieu de
l'été une poignée de pays européens
notamment l'espagne ou l'italie mais
aussi la france ont déjà adopté des
mesures telles que l'allègement de la
fiscalité indirecte un chèque énergie
pour les ménages les plus pauvres le gel
provisoire des hausses la sur taxation
des profits des électriciens et 2
gaziers pour tenter d'aider les
consommateurs à faire face à l'envolée
des prix
l'ensemble de ces aides représenterait
quelque 18 milliards d'euros rien que
pour la france
ces mêmes aides on lui est octroyée en
tendant le bras à bruxelles la
présidence tournante de l'europe n'est
pas étrangère se passe passe budgétaire
pas pu le rappeler en un article du
canard enchaîné ce même jour mais cela
est tout bonnement insuffisants et les
consommateurs peinent à avoir des
traductions concrètes dans leur pouvoir
d'achat de plus les mesures prix se font
au détriment du contribuable en cela la
situation française est quelque peu
ubuesque et éclairant des dérives de la
libéralisation à outrance du marché
d'énergie
vous avez interrogé à ce sujet le
ministre de l'économie de la semaine
dernière lors des questions au
gouvernement
j'avais demandé comment nous pouvions
nous trouver dans une situation où edf
produisent et une électricité qu elle ne
pouvait vendre elle-même au prix du
marché mais qu'elle devait céder à ses
concurrents qui eux pratiquer des prix
exorbitants j'attends encore la réponse
je ne doute pas aujourd'hui vous serez à
même de me l'apporté
car des questions financières et
monétaires se pose de plus en plus
précisément cette crise énergétique
place la banque centrale européenne dans
une position difficile contre cette
flambée contre cette inflation importée
elle ne peut rien faire mes pompes mais
combien de temps pourra t elle maintenir
sa politique monétaire et les taux et
les taux faibles
de fait ne nous leurrons pas la crise
risque de durer bien plus longtemps que
ce que vous escomptez les eaux sur le
marché du gaz se sont propagées au
marché de l'électricité du charbon du
pétrole mais maintenant elles ont
engagées elles ont gagné les marchés des
flotteurs des contrats
d'approvisionnement d'électricité pour
2022 voire 2023 ceux des gossip au prix
de 150 euros le mégawatt contre 39 euros
en moyenne en 2019 c'est un signe que
les intervenants de marché n'anticipe
pas de baisse rapide
inéluctablement ces prix se
répercuteront un moment ou un autre dans
les factures des ménages et vos mesures
de bricolage conjoncturelle ne
changeront pas la donne au risque de
provoquer un malaise social encore plus
grand
merci chers collègues
je vais maintenant donner la parole
d'abord monsieur olivier dussopt
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics puis à madame bérenger rabat
merci monsieur le président nous ne
partagerons le temps avec ma collègue
dargis rabat deux éléments de réponse le
premier pour dire qu'en écho à beaucoup
des interventions entendues aujourd'hui
le gouvernement français demande
revendique une modernisation une réforme
du marché européen de l'énergie
notamment pour dissocier le marché des
particuliers du marché de gros
considérant que les consommateurs
français n'ont pas à subir une
augmentation aussi forte des prix de
l'énergie quand dans le même temps nous
avons une capacité à produire de
l'énergie un coût plus faible en tout
cas moi un plus plus maîtrisée notamment
du fait des investissements passés dans
le parc nucléaire et de la vence d'une
certaine manière que nous avons prises
dans la matière pour ce qui concerne le
pouvoir d'achat de manière aussi brève
que possible je me souhaite distinguer
trois phases la première concerne ce que
nous avons fait depuis le début du
quinquennat avec une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat des français dans la
revalorisation de la prime d'activité de
certains minima sociaux par la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires ou encore la diminution
d'un certain nombre de cotisations
autant de mesures qui sans être
exhaustif permettent une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat des français égale 1,8 à
1,9 pour cent par an en moyenne sur les
cinq dernières années c'est deux fois
plus rapide que les dix années
précédentes puisque de 2007 à 2012 nous
étions sur une augmentation d'un point 4
de 2012 à 2017 sur une augmentation de
0.4 ensuite nous avons répondu à la
crise par la mobilisation de l'activité
partielle et 2020 un permis de protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des français puisque
celui-ci a augmenté en moyenne de 0 4%
alors que nous connaissions une
récession de 8% c'est la démonstration
que les amortisseurs sociaux et
l'activité partielle en particulier ont
permis d'amortir les conséquences de la
crise sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français et enfin depuis nous répondons
à la crise de l'énergie par des outils
qui ont été évoqués le chèque énergie
hauteur de 100 euros d'abonnement pour
les cinq millions huit cent mille
ménages bénéficiaires habituels
habituellement l'indemnité inflation
dont je signale que 20 millions de
bénéficiaires ont déjà perçu cette
indemnité sur les 38 millions qu ils
apercevront d'ici fin février ou encore
les différentes dispositions en matière
de plafonnement de l'augmentation ou de
plafonnement des tarifs le jeu sur la
fiscalité ou le volume de la reine
autant de mesures qui représentent un
engagement de 15 milliards d'euros cela
a été dit et répété 15 milliards d'euros
en face desquels l'augmentation de 2 à 3
milliards d'euros des recettes fiscales
propres de l'état ne font évidemment pas
la maille si vous me permettez cette
expression c'est plus de 12 milliards
d'euros de coût net pour l'état c'est la
démonstration là aussi que nous mettons
des moyens conséquents sans compter les
efforts demandés à edf pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des français
merci madame ah bah je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs effectivement et
comme je viens de le dire mon collègue
olivier du soft face à cette hausse des
prix du gaz et de l'électricité des
mesures extrêmement protectrice ont été
mises en place et nous ne remettons pas
ici en cause le fait de devoir dans le
même temps repenser notre mix
énergétique pour atteindre des objectifs
de décarbonation et la montée en
puissance des besoins en terme
d'électricité il nous faut revoir
également le modèle économique le modèle
financier le modèle industriel français
dans le même temps garantir évidemment
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement et
donc la souveraineté et énergétiques
pardon européenne avec donc pour ce qui
est de l'électricité on l'a dit une
limitation de la hausse des prix à 4 %
nous nous y sommes tenus les tarifs
auraient pu augmenter il faut le redire
de 30 à 40% nous avions besoin de ces
réponses d'urgence même si elles sont
moins structurelles et plus ponctuels
elles ont dû nous nous amener à
déclencher ses aides et le parlement à
accompagner cette démarche avec la
décision de baisser la fiscalité sur
l'électricité avec la tei cf vous le
savez et puis dans un second temps pour
protéger également les entreprises qui
n'ont pas accès aux tarifs réglementés
la demande à edf d'augmenter de 20
térawattheures le volume d'électricité
nucléaire après réguler cette
électricité moins chère elle sera
rétrocédé il faut également le réfléchir
comme un retour aux consommateurs aux
ménages aux entreprises aux
collectivités via des tarifs de vente
tant que edf que de ses concurrents qui
tiendront compte de ces électrons moins
cher avec donc la participation dans
cette lutte contre la hausse des prix
que nous demandons f au terme du service
public et de l'intérêt général et nous
savons que cette mission de service
public doit se mettre effectivement au
service des français aujourd'hui dans
cette crise exceptionnelle crise
exceptionnelle et d'ailleurs
imprévisible comme on a pu parfois le
l'entendre ou le sous-entendre cet après
midi aucun analyste aucune prévision ne
permettait d'imaginer cette cette crise
des prix de l'énergie que nous
connaissons avec donc un lien à
renforcer évidemment est une urgence à
trouver des solutions en termes de
régulation à la sphère européenne pour
ces marchés de l'énergie une régulation
qui doit être pensé avant la transition
énergétique comme vraiment à un modèle à
reconstruire avec un lien prix payé
coûte coût de la production et comme
coup de la décarbonation du mix qui
doivent être redessinés cette crise des
prix de l'énergie d'ailleurs plus
précisément cette crise des énergies
fossiles elle se vit au niveau européen
le conseil informel des ministres de
l'énergie que nous avons tenu à amiens
la semaine passée nous a permis de
constater qu'une majorité aujourd'hui se
dégageait pour faire évoluer au niveau
européen cette cette réglementation et
nous porteront donc sur le marché de de
détail de l'électricité
toute l'attention est tous nos travaux a
fortiori dans le cadre de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
nous leur disons 15 milliards 15
milliards dead pour le pouvoir d'achat
pour les ménages quelques failles dans
le dispositif qui ont été repérées on
l'a vu cet après midi lors des questions
au gouvernement pour les grosses
propriétés pour des logements qui
peuvent être
chauffer des réseaux de chaleur et qui
s'approvisionnent évidemment au gaz nous
aurons des réponses plus ciblés dans les
quelques jours qui viennent pour
préciser vraiment ce dispositif et
répondre à tous les besoins plus de
trente mille communes sur les 35 mille
communes françaises qui bénéficient déjà
de ce bouclier tarifaire nous avons
quand même un dispositif qui a été très
large et une réactivité que vous avez su
trouver également
dans les dispositions législatives que
nous avons dû prendre dans les semaines
passent et qui nous permet vraiment de
dire que les français ne sont pas
laissés seuls face à cette crise des
prix de l'énergie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre la ministre mes chers collègues
je peins je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 18h15 pour l'examen
de la proposition de loi tendant à
redonner un caractère universel aux
allocations familiales
la séance
est suspendue
la séance est reprise monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle que la conférence des
présidents avaient prévu que nous
suspendions entre 20h30 et 22h que du
bonheur en accord avec le gouvernement
et avec le groupe de l'union centriste
nous pourrions prolonger notre séance
au-delà de 20h30 sa manière claire pour
examiner les deux points de l'ordre du
jour de l'espace réservé au groupe union
centriste sans avoir à suspendre n'y a
pas d'opposition je n'en vois point
comme dirait le président larcher
il en est ainsi décidé l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi tendant à redonner un caractère
universel aux allocations familiales
présentée par monsieur olivier neau et
plusieurs de ses collègues demande du
groupe union centriste dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur olivier nos auteurs de la
proposition de loi et rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales vous
avez la parole cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de
commission qui doit arriver mais sa
collègue la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui vise à supprimer
la modulation des allocations familiales
en fonction des revenus du foyer les
allocations familiales occupent une
place à part parmi les prestations de la
branche famille en 2020 elle
représentait 12,7 milliards soit 41 % de
dépenses de prestations légales de la
branche elle était versée à plus de 5
millions de familles ce qui en fait la
première des prestations familiales
prestation historique et majeur les
allocations familiales ont une portée
symbolique conçu pendant
l'entre-deux-guerres les allocations
familiales furent après la libération au
coeur de la politique nataliste mise en
oeuvre en france qui alors n'était qu'un
pays statique et clairsemé pour
reprendre les mots du général de gaulle
la loi du 22 août 1946 et andy leurs
bénéfices aux personnes dans
l'incapacité de travailler aux femmes
elles vont seuls plus de deux enfants
elle pose ainsi les fondements
de leur universalité
définitivement consacré à partir de 1978
lorsque toutes conditions d'activité
professionnelle pour l'ouverture des
droits aux prestations familiales fut
supprimée en ayant été versé à de
nombreux foyers depuis 77 ans les
allocations familiales sont régis par
des conditions d'attribution bien connue
des français elles sont aussi dues à
partir du 2ème enfant jusqu'à l'âge de
20 ans à l'exception des départements et
régions d'outre-mer dans lesquelles les
allocations familiales sont ouvertes dès
le premier enfant leur montant à taux
plein varie selon le nombre d'enfants à
charge 132 euros pour deux enfants 301
euros pour trois enfants et 470 euros
pour 4 la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2015 à
l'initiative d'un amendement
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale a
introduit à compter du 1er juillet 2015
une modulation des allocations
familiales selon les revenus de la
famille cette modulation concerne les
allocations familiales la majoration
versés pour les enfants de plus de 14
ans et enfin l'allocation forfaitaire
accordé lorsqu'un enfant à charge
atteint l'âge limite de 20 ans en
conséquence le montant des allocations
familiales a été réduit pour 10% de
leurs bénéficiaires soit un demi million
de familles
le versement est ainsi divisé par deux
pour les familles dont les ressources
dépassent un premier flacon de 5800
euros pour deux enfants et par 4 pour
celles dont les revenus excèdent 7800
euros pour deux enfants l'objectif
poursuivi est assumée par cette réforme
était de parvenir à des économies
budgétaires sur ce point la mesure a
tenu ses promesses puisque en 2016 760
millions d'euros ont été économisés au
détriment des familles d'autres mesures
d'économies se sont d'ailleurs ajouté
comme la réduction du plafond du
quotient familial ou plus récemment la
survalorisation des prestations
familiales en 2019 et 2020 la modulation
des allocations familiales a produit des
effets secondaires qui ne sont pas
difficiles à observer elle a affaibli la
lisibilité de la prestation en
introduisant de la complexité dans sa
gestion et de l'incertitude pour les
ménages concernés les ressources prises
en compte étant jusqu'à présent celle de
l'année n moins deux des événements
imprévus peuvent effectuer les revenus
des ménages sans que le montant des
allocations de réagissent afin de
soutenir le budget des familles pour
l'éducation des enfants cependant les
conséquences néfastes de la réforme
dépasse la seule question du paramétrage
d'une prestation familiale et justifient
que cette proposition de loi soit
débattue aujourd'hui cette modulation à
tout d'abord écorner le principe
d'universalité des allocations
familiales si celle ci demeure versée à
toutes les familles dès le deuxième
enfant à charge l'universalité qu'elle
met en oeuvre n'est plus que la façade
étant donné les montants modique
versèrent certaines familles il s'agit
par exemple d'une somme de 33 euros pour
deux enfants à charge lorsque les
ressources du foyer se situe dans la
troisième tranche du barème or la
modulation des allocations familiales en
portant atteinte au principe
d'universalité comporte le risque de
saper l'acceptabilité de la politique
familiale pour les foyers concernés par
la modulation ces derniers contribuent
au financement d'une politique toujours
qualifiés d'universels mais dont ils
sont paradoxalement exclut en outre
cette modulation d'une prestation
universelle en fonction du revenu
interpelle si cet universalisme
progressif venait à s'étendre c'est
notre modèle de sécurité sociale qui
pourraient être mis en cause à cet égard
il est assez révélateur que cette
réforme est affecté les allocations
familiales et non jusqu'à présent les
prestations d'assurance maladie la
politique familiale n'a pas constitué
une priorité à l'évidence pour les
derniers gouvernements plus encore cette
gouv cette modulation introduite en 2015
a dévoyé le sens des allocations
familiales qui ont été conçus pour
porter l'ambition de redistribution
horizontale de la politique familiale
quelles que soient les ressources du
foyer la prestation compenser une partie
une partie du coût de l'éducation des
enfants témoignant ainsi de la
solidarité de la collectivité pour les
familles c'est pourquoi le montant des
allocations ne variés que selon le
nombre d'enfants au contraire
l'introduction d'une logique de
redistribution verticale à brouiller les
objectifs à signée à cette prestation il
ne s'agit pas là de nier les nouveaux
enjeux de la politique familiale qui
doivent être relevés depuis les années
70 la nécessité d'aider particulièrement
les familles les plus vulnérables
explique la création prestations sous
conditions de ressources aux modulé
selon les revenus du ménage complément
familial allocation de rentrée scolaire
prime à la naissance ou l'adoption
allocation de base de la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant nombreuses
sont les prestations qui cible les
familles aux revenus les plus modestes
ou les publics spécifiques
cependant en perdant de vue le
l'objectif de redistribution horizontale
la réforme de 2015 a consacré la
transformation de la politique familiale
en seule politique de soutien aux
familles les plus précaires sans pour
autant être une mesure de justice
sociale la modulation des allocations
familiales n'en porte en soi aucun aucun
bénéfice pour les familles aux revenus
modestes pour toutes ces raisons
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
adoptée par la commission vous propose
de supprimer la modulation des
allocations familiales selon les
ressources de la famille l'article de
gages cette mesure dont le coût est
estimé à 830 millions d'euros par an
cette dépense supplémentaire serait
soutenable pour la branche famille dont
les comptes devraient afficher un
excédent de 1,7 milliard d'euros en 2022
surtout cette proposition de loi
s'inscrit dans le contexte préoccupant
de la natalité que connaît notre pays
qui s'avère un investissement pour le
renouvellement des générations
depuis 2012 la france présente le taux
de fécondité le plus élevé de l'europe
pourtant il nous est difficile de
targuer de cette place dans la dynamique
de la fécondité est désormais
défavorable le taux de fécondité
conjoncturelle qui oscillait autour de
deux enfants sur la période 2005 2015 à
diminuer constamment pour atteindre
1,92 enfants par femme en 2020 ce déclin
combinée à la diminution du nombre de
femmes en âge de procréer a provoqué une
chute de 80 mille naissances annuelles
entre 2015 et 2020 si l'année 2021
marque une stabilisation du taux de
fécondité à 1,83 en raison d'un
phénomène de rattrapage page après la
crise sanitaire les chances d'une
remontée durable du taux de fécondité
sont minces l'exception démographique
française en europe est à terme menacés
certes lui aucune étude n'a pu mettre en
évidence un lien entre la modulation des
allocations familiales et la chute de la
fécondité observée depuis quelques
années l'impact d'une mesure isolée de
la politique familiale et en tout état
de cause difficile à mesurer et les
seules considérations financières ne fut
suffisent pas déterminé le choix des
familles dans leur projet de parentalité
toutefois comment ne pas penser que
cette modulation a envoyé un mauvais
signal aux familles quant à une
réorientation de la politique familiale
et un affaiblissement de la solidarité
ont leur faveur cette mesure d'économie
budgétaire a demandé un effort aux
familles avec au moins deux enfants qui
n'étaient pas exiger des ménages sans
enfant aux revenus identiques
pour que leur projet de parentalité se
concrétise les familles ont besoin de
les voir soutenu par une politique
familiale cohérente et pérenne cette
proposition de loi vise précisément à
mettre fin aux distinctions voire aux
stigmatisations introduite par un barème
de ressources à redonner du sens aux
allocations familiales et à réaffirmer
l'engagement de la société aux côtés des
familles la sécurisation de
l'environnement familial exige bien
entendu d'autres mesures et de nombreux
chantiers qui restent à engager qu'il
s'agisse de développer davantage l'offre
d'accueil de la petite enfance ou de
favoriser une meilleure conciliation de
la vie professionnelle et familiale avec
des congés parentaux plus pertinents la
fin de la modulation des allocations
familiales selon les revenus du foyer ne
constitue à l'évidence mais elle
constitue une première étape à renouveau
plus profond de la politique familiale
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est maintenant monsieur adrien
tac et secrétaires d'état chargés de
l'enfance et des familles vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
place
je suis le président dans la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le
rapporteur cher e olivier nau mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes réunis pour examiner la
proposition de loi tendant à redonner un
caractère universel aux allocations
familiales dans l'objectif selon votre
exposé des motifs monsieur le rapporteur
de je vous cite relancer la natalité
dans notre pays et redonner du sens à
notre politique familiale
la période est sans doute propice au
débat sur ce type de sujet faux le crâne
parfois peut-être aux propositions
facile et démagogique pourquoi pas
peut-être caricatural ce n'est pas du
tout sens monsieur le rapporteur de
votre proposition de loi dont je dois
dire cependant que je n'en partagent ni
la démarche ni l'esprit mais elle nous
donne l'occasion je vous en remercie de
débattre de ces sujets importants je
considère essentiel de le faire sur des
bases précises car nous sommes tous des
uns et les autres à lapproche
d'échéances importantes
propositions vont se polariser les
totems seront peut-être brandi en
programme
traduisant parfois une difficulté à voir
au delà de penser toutes prêtes faute il
soumettre les allocations à des plafonds
de revenus au risque de porter atteinte
au principe d'universalité le plafond du
quotient familial doit-il être relevé le
calcul départ doit-il être modifiées
autant de questions bien sûr importante
car l'impact des aides monétaires sur le
quotidien des familles françaises n'est
pas neutre et pourtant il faut que les
choses soient claires la modulation dont
vous avez rappelé monsieur le rapporteur
qu'elle n'était pas le fait de ce
gouvernement mais remonté à 2015 la
modulation que votre proposition de loi
remet en question ici non seulement
préserve en réalité le principe
d'universalité des allocations
familiales
mais elle permet aussi et surtout de
répondre à un objectif de justice
sociale
je rappelle en effet que la modulation
ne touche qu'une faible partie des
bénéficiaires des allocations familiales
seuls 10 % des allocataires étaient
concernés en 2019 et j'insiste sur ce
terme de modulation puisque en réalité
toutes familles peuvent toujours
bénéficier
d'allocations familiales quel que soit
son niveau de revenu et ce dès le
deuxième enfant
cette modulation elle répond par
ailleurs un objectif de justice sociale
il s'agit bien de concentrer l'effort de
solidarité nationale vers ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin et donc de réduire
les inégalités ce à deux niveaux de
façon verticale et horizontale
traditionnellement et les travaux de
l'insee le montre la modulation a en
effet permis en 2021 une réduction de
9,4 pour cent des inégalités verticale
de niveau de vie c'est-à-dire entre les
familles aisées et les familles modestes
et de 20% pour les familles
monoparentales entre familles
monoparentales et les familles
nombreuses dans une redistribution que
l'on qualifie cette fois-ci vous le
savez d'horizontal
souligne par ailleurs et c'est mon
second point que contrairement aux
affirmations l'exposé des motifs même si
vous les avez relativiser dans votre
propos monsieur le rapporteur
l'impact des allocations familiales sur
la natalité n'est pas démontrée en
france comme dans la quasi totalité des
pays de l' ocde d'ailleurs ces dernières
années il n'y a donc pas de corrélation
évidente vous l'avait dit entre leur
modulation et la baisse de la natalité
qu'on a pu constater dans la plupart des
pays de l'osce et des oeufs ces
dernières années vous avez rappelé que
la france reste en tête du taux de
fécondité dans les pays de l' ocde avec
1,83 en progression d'ailleurs cette
année par rapport aux années précédentes
enfants par femme et donc quand je lis
un candidat je n'ai pas celui que vous
soutenez monsieur le rapporteur qui dit
toute la politique familiale française a
prouvé qu'en mettant de l'argent on a
une expansion de la natalité
c'est bien mal connaître en réalité les
ressorts contemporain de ce qu'est la
politique familiale d'une part et par
ailleurs plus grave tout cas pour lui
peut-être c'est mal connaître ce que
sont les aspirations et les besoins des
familles françaises aujourd'hui
la belle de la faune qui en dit est
observée depuis 2000 15 touches en
réalité tous les groupes de niveau de
vie
un fait qui va bien sûr à l'encontre de
cette idée d'une diminution diminution
de la natalité pour les plus aisés en
raison de la modulation des allocations
familiales institué en 2015 les études
disponibles montrent en réalité plutôt
que la diminution de la natalité
résulte de différents facteurs
des facteurs démographiques avec un fake
et la diminuation notable du nombre de
femmes en âge de procréer dans notre
pays et du recul de l'âge moyen de la
maternité
des facteurs d'ordre sociétal avec chez
les parents j'y reviendrai une
aspiration grandissante à mieux
concilier vie professionnelle et vie
familiale pour ne plus avoir à choisir
entre l'une et l'autre ou l'autre et
enfin des facteurs économiques oui c'est
vrai lié aux incertitudes qui pèsent sur
la conjoncture et plus récemment à
l'impact de la crise sanitaire sur la
confiance globale des ménages et de nos
concitoyens
mais c'est bien l'ensemble de ces
leviers en réalité qu'il faut actionner
et s'il s'est agi depuis 2010 est de le
faire c'est ce que le gouvernement fait
depuis 2017 et de rompre avec trente
années de débats qui se sont un peu
réduits et enfermé si vous me permettez
à la seule question des aides monétaires
des débats qui je pense nous empêchait
de prendre pleinement conscience des
nouvelles aspirations des parents
justement et des nouvelles difficultés
aussi des parents actuels car ce qui
compte c'est d'assurer un environnement
global le plus favorable possible à
l'accueil du jeune enfant en réalité ce
qui compte c'est de prendre en compte
les spécificités des parcours de
proposer des solutions précises adapté
pour mettre parents et futurs parents
dans les meilleures conditions
d'accueillir leurs enfants
c'est notre vision de la politique
familiale c'est ma vision de la
politique familiale une politique
familiale qui repose sur deux piliers
visé à bâtir d'une part une société
globalement plus accueillante pour les
enfants et leurs familles et d'autre
part de faire la politique familiale un
outil assumé de lutte contre les
inégalités de destin qui touche encore
trop d'enfants dans notre pays
donc oui ce premier pilier c'est
dépasser la question de l'universalité
par les seules prestations pour bâtir
une véritable universalité des services
pour toutes les familles
cela implique simplement de reconnaître
qu être parent c'est pas forcément chose
aisée
et d'agir pour les accompagner dans ce
rôle c'est indispensable et cela veut
dire agir dès les premiers temps de la
parentalité d'autant plus que l'on sait
que la moitié des parents français
aujourd'hui nous disent qu'il est dur
d'être parents que les femmes nous
disent qu'elles se sentent seuls pendant
leur maternité pendant la grossesse
après la grossesse et que près de 20 %
d'entre elles probablement plus sont
touchés par la dépression post partum
c'est tout le sens vous l'avez compris
de toute la politique des 1000 premiers
jours de l'enfant cette période
fondatrice où doris cyrulnik nous dit
que tout commence tout ne se joue pas là
mais tout commence
de l'attachement entre parents et
enfants à l'apprentissage des premiers
gestes des premiers mots et sur laquelle
je le croise est aucun gouvernement
n'avait jamais autant investi que sur
cette période là c'est le choix de la
prévention également
dès le quatrième mois de grossesse et
pour tout sept tranches de la vie avec
une ambition forte qui consiste à
prévenir les risques psychosociaux des
l'instant le projet parental se forment
privilégier une approche systémique qui
tient compte de l'environnement dans
lequel évolue l'enfant parce que l'on
sait que les 1000 premiers jours sont
essentiels et désormais toutes les
femmes et leurs conjoints bénéficie dans
notre pays d'un parcours 1000 premiers
jours qui s'articule autour de
l'entretien prénatal précoce ou
quatrième mois remboursés par la
sécurité sociale
d'un meilleur accompagnement maternité
et en sortie de maternité
avec la création de 200 postes d'eu
staff psycho médico sociaux dans les
maternités priorité avec une meilleure
articulation entre la ville et l'hôpital
pour éviter ces fameuses ruptures de
parcours dont nous disent dont les
femmes ne disent souffrir
enfin d'un entretien post natale la
cinquième semaine après l'accouchement
d'un deuxième entretien à la 12e semaine
si besoin pour lutter justement contre
cette dépression post partum entretient
désormais obligatoire c'est-à-dire
remboursés par la sécurité sociale vous
l'avez voter dans la dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
convient aussi au delà de cette
universalité des parcours de reconnaître
les spécificités des familles voir les
détresses singulière l'arrivée d'un
enfant ainsi doit être accompagnée pour
toutes les familles quelle que soit leur
forme ou leur fortune n'entraîne pas
exactement les mêmes charges ou les
mêmes problématiques pour les uns et
pour les autres et donc nous avons
développé aussi des parcours spécifiques
dans le cas d'un enfant l'arrivée d'un
enfant prématuré par exemple l'arrivée
d'un enfant en situation de handicap
l'arrivée d'un enfant adopté autre
configuration c'est ce que nous faisons
également en accordant une attention
particulière aux familles monoparentales
vous le savez depuis le début de ce
quinquennat avec notamment la majoration
par exemple de 30 % du plafond de
l'allocation garde d'enfants pour ces
familles ou encore le déploiement du
service public de versement des impayés
de pension alimentaire
construire cette universalité des
services aux familles c'est aussi
répondre aux attentes et aux
préoccupations généralisée des parents
en matière de conciliation entre vie
personnelle et professionnelle
est de permettre aux parents de
concilier toutes ces vies que nous
cumulons vite parents de travailleurs de
professeurs pour tous les conjoints qui
souhaitait depuis bien longtemps pouvoir
s'investir davantage dans ses premiers
jours heureux nous avons doublé la durée
du congé paternité d'accueil du jeune
enfant en le faisant passer de 14 à 28
jours et en le rendant pour partie
obligatoire une transformation sociétale
majeure
il faudra souvent sûrement aller plus
loin encore et mener une réflexion
globale sur l'ensemble des congés
familiaux notamment le congé parental
mais pas uniquement et vous le savez
j'avais missionné christel heydemann et
julien damon pour réfléchir sur une
meilleure articulation entre vie
personnelle et professionnelle
cette politique de service universel
enfin elle concerne évidemment l'enjeu
des modes d'accueil du jeune enfant et
là aussi nous menons une action résolue
depuis le début de la mandature pierre
après pierre nous sommes en train de
bâtir un véritable service public de la
petite enfance dans notre pays
d'une part en ayant inscrit dans la loi
la charte nationale de la qualité du
jeune enfant en ayant ensuite créé un
comité de filière de la petite enfance
pour mettre autour de la table
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
petite enfance pour travailler autour
des questions de formation de carrière
de passerelles de rémunération
nous avons alloué des moyens
supplémentaires pour créer des places
pour encourager la formation des
professionnels ce sont 45 millions
d'euros qui ont été mobilisés pour la
formation des professionnels de la
petite enfance dans le cadre de la
stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre la pauvreté
et puis cette dynamique à l'oeuvre il
nous faut encore intensifier pour
avancer comme annoncé par le président
de la rép public il ya peu de temps dans
la voie de ce droit garantit un accueil
du jeune enfant à un prix raisonnable
est similaire que l'on soit accueilli en
individuel ou en collectif
pour chaque parent dans nos territoires
et saha posera en temps voulu la
question des compétences dont nous
aurons l'occasion je pense je l'espère
de rabat de débattre ici
cette universalité des services cet
accompagnement à la parentalité se
développe sur d'autres sujets à d'autres
époques d'autres périodes de la vie je
pense notamment à la question de la
parentalité numérique dont les parents
nous disent mais c'est une de leurs
préoccupations majeures la question du
rapport de leurs enfants à l'écran et
aux usages numériques et potentialités
qu'offre le numérique pour les enfants
mais aussi à certains risques et menaces
qui peuvent peser sur eux lundi prochain
sera la journée de la cei sur internet
dès ce qu'une journée internationale
excusez moi pour l'anglicisme qui sera
l'occasion pour le gouvernement de faire
de nouvelles annonces en la matière ce
qui me permet aussi de rappeler la
création d'ores et déjà du site je
protège mon enfant point gouv.fr qui
regroupe un certain nombre de ressources
et des aides pour les parents pour les
accompagner dans la question de la
relation de leurs enfants aux écrans et
au numérique enfin second pilier de
notre politique familiale et j'en
terminerai par là monsieur le président
mais c'est le rapporteur parfaitement
complémentaire du premier que je viens
d'exposer ses d'affirmer la politique
familiale dans son rôle d'investissement
social et d'outils de lutte contre les
inégalités de destin qui affecte encore
trop nombreux de nos enfants dans ce
pays oui la politique familiale est un
levier d'émancipation majeur elle permet
de lutter contre ces inégalités de
destin d'autant plus qu'elle s'y attaque
au moment où elles se forment et non pas
en attendant qu'elle se soit accrue près
de trois millions d'enfants dans notre
pays vous le savez continue de vivre
sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est
inacceptable et cela a constitué notre
première urgence quelques mois après son
élection le président la république
présenté la stratégie de prévention et
de lutte contre la pauvreté
en mettant l'encens et les familles au
coeur avec pour un objectif aussi clair
kian et inédit agir le plus tôt possible
pour briser ce cercle de la transmission
de la pauvreté de génération en
génération vous le savez il faut six
générations dans notre pays pour qu'une
famille que des enfants sortent de la
pauvreté les engagements pris alors
devant les français ont été tenus pour
aider plus fort les communes plus
pauvres à créer de nouvelles places de
crèche pour offrir à chaque enfant qui
arrive à l'école le ventre vide un petit
déjeuner gratuit
pour lui proposer un déjeuner équilibré
à la cantine pour un euro pour dédoubler
les classes de cp afin que
l'apprentissage de la lecture fondements
de l'éducation de la connaissance et des
chances se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions
et dames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs les principes historiques de
la sécurité sociale au premier rang
desquels l'universalité doivent se
confronter aussi à la vie de nos
compatriotes
tout simplement c'est d'ailleurs toute
la force de notre protection sociale que
de ne pas être figé la famille a toute
sa place dans les ambitions de ce
quinquennat qui s'achève les éléments de
bilan que j'ai dressé ne faut pas rougir
bien au contraire nous sommes fermes sur
les principes nous avons su regarder la
famille dans tout ce qu'elle avait de
divers et de complexes l'universalité
c'était des toutes les familles mais ce
n'est pas forcément les aider tout de la
même façon
c'est au contraire écouter prendre en
compte leurs attentes leurs besoins
leurs incertitudes nous le faisons
depuis 2010 est il nous faut encore
aller plus loin pour tous les parents et
pour tous les enfants de notre pays je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à madame raymonde poncet mange pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues l'ordonance du 4 octobre 1945
créant la sécurité sociale repose sur un
principe fondamental chacun cotise selon
ses moyens et reçoit selon ses besoins
ce principe se déclinait pour chacun des
risques et le lien entre cotisations
variable et prestations universelles
fondait le contrat social de solidarité
il y a dix tendu voire ont pu déjà par
la fiscalisation vient la csg en 1991
qui a trop transférer les cotisations
sociales liées à la protection sociale
vers l'impôt il en est ainsi pour la
branche famille dont la pièce maîtresse
des allocations familiales servait des
prestations universelles sans conditions
de ressources à toutes les familles
ayant au moins deux enfants de moins de
20 ans à charge pour compenser la perte
de niveau de vie et ce par rapport aux
familles sans enfant donc selon un
mécanisme de compensation et de
solidarité horizontale
nous rejoignons nos collègues auteurs de
ce texte pour défendre ce principe
fondamental heures d'universalité sont
partagés toutefois le lien établi entre
modulation des allocations familiales et
inscriptions de la natalité une
corrélation ici n'est vraiment pas une
causalité ne pensons pas que la
modulation pour les familles aisées cas
pour l'insee il s'agit bien des décide
supérieur et puis décourager ces
familles d'avoir des enfants d'autant
que les aides fiscales restent très
favorables à ces familles ainsi les 10%
ces 10% des plus hauts revenus
consentent 31% des gains nets liés aux
pressions familiales et conjugales
là où les 30% les plus modestes ne
bénéficie que de 6 5% dégâts l'erreur de
la modulation en supposant que la
justice sociale on n'était jamais une
motivation sincère et bien d'assigner ou
prestations familiales un objectif de
redistribution verticale à la place d'un
impôt dont c'est vraiment l'objet
principal à savoir lire pp ainsi plutôt
que d'attaquer le risque famille en son
principe
universalité de ses prestations il
aurait été plus pertinent de questionner
un angle mort de la politique familiale
au regard de la justice sociale soit le
quotient familial à l'effet fortement
anti héros distributif en effet le
conseil des prélèvements obligatoires le
rôle devait déjà dans un rapport publié
en 1900 en 2011 par nos l'économie
d'impôts dus au quotient familial croît
plus vite que proportionnellement aux
revenus la raison budgétaire restaurer
les équilibres de la broche en rabotant
le droit de prestations selon les
revenus a donc primé contre le principe
fondateur et il n'est pas contestable
que la porte de la modulation selon les
revenus et non les besoins est ainsi
ouverte pour d'autres risques
fragilisant l'attachement au modèle
social nous restons donc attaché au
principe de redistribution horizontale
entre ménages selon leur composition
afin d'amortir la baisse de niveau de
vie induite par la naissance et
l'éducation d'enfants le budget moyen
pour un enfant de sa naissance à ces
trois ans s'élèverait à 490 euros par
mois celui ci est supérieur pour le
premier enfant c'est pourquoi il est
temps d'élargir la prestation au premier
enfant moment où les risques de
décrochage financier par rapport aux
ménages sans enfant sont les plus grands
et qui va peuvent pour les ménages les
ménages modestes effectivement retarder
un projet d'enfant la décision de
modulation n'a de plus pas été soutenu
en 2015 par un accompagnement renforcé
pour les ménages modestes c'est donc une
pure mesure d'économie il aurait fallu
le dire et nous sommes donc favorables à
revenir sur cette modulation mais en
consolidant la politique familiale en
conclusion pour répondre à l'objectif de
la politique familiale de soutenir les
parents dans l'accueil et l'éducation
des enfants le groupe écologiste
préconise la location par enfant d'un
montant fixe d'allocations familiales et
ce dès le premier enfant mesures
soutenues par 60% de nos concitoyens
selon le dernier baromètre de la drees
l'article 1 de la proposition de loi
n'aurait de sens hirscher collègues que
dans une réforme plus ambitieuse d'un
politique familiale faisant droit cette
fois ci à l'injustice sociale aussi le
groupe écologie s'abstient je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
laurence cohen pour le groupe crc e pour
4 minutes je vous rappelle qu' un
deuxième débat après donc soyez vraiment
vigilant sur le temps
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi de l'union centriste
porté par notre collègue olivier nau
vise le rétablissement de l'universalité
des allocations familiales supprimés en
2015 sous le quinquennat de françois
hollande est remplacée par une
modulation pour les familles les plus
aisées au nom du redressement des
comptes publics alors que l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'un président de la république
et d'une majorité parlementaire de
gauche en 2012 était porteuse d'espoir
et de progrès sociaux la remise en cause
l'universalité des prestations
familiales en 2014 a été l'un des
symboles du refus de rupture du
gouvernement de l'époque avec les
restrictions budgétaires des politiques
sociales certes la modulation des
allocations familiales n'a pas supprimé
l'universalité de l'accès aux
prestations familiales mais elle a
entraîné la disparition de
l'universalité du montant des
prestations versées aux familles comme
nous l'avions dénoncé en 2014 la
modulation remet en cause l'universalité
de la protection sociale héritée du
conseil national de la résistance et
pierre angulaire de notre système de
politique familiale contrairement la
fiscalité qui remplit un rôle de
redistribution verticale les prestations
familiales jouent un rôle de
redistribution horizontale en faveur des
familles qui ont des enfants à charge
sans considération du milieu social dans
lequel grandi un enfant ni des
conditions de ressources cette
participation de chacune et chacun notre
système de protection sociale est
fondamental pour son existence or en
modulant les prestations familiales on
prend le risque les plus aisés refuse de
continuer de participer au financement
de la sécurité sociale et préfère le
système assurantiel ainsi la modulation
porte une atteinte à la cohésion sociale
en renforçant le sentiment
d'illégitimité des prélèvements en outre
il existe un lien entre la baisse de la
natalité et la politique familiale menée
selon le rapport du haut commissariat au
plan du 15 mai 21 consacré à la
démographie
l'augmentation de la population
française se poursuit mais à un rythme
moins important qu entre 2008 et 2013 le
rapport répond que les réseaux mécanique
de cet avis abaissement de la natalité
sont le vieillissement de la population
et l'entrée plus tardive sur le marché
du travail des nouvelles générations
ainsi la fécondité est également un
indicateur de la conciliation vie
familiale et vie professionnelle
à ce titre la politique familiale ne se
résume pas au financement des
prestations familiales mais à bien
d'autres facteurs dont par exemple les
congés accordés aux parents ou encore
les moyens dépensés pour l'accueil de la
petite enfance or en la matière nous
savons les retards qui existent pour ce
qui nous concerne nous défendons depuis
longtemps un sur un service public de la
petite enfance enfin même si je sais que
nous sommes très contraint par le
périmètre de nos ppl je regrette que
cette proposition de loi ne rétablissent
pas les cotisations patronales à la
branche familiale en effet depuis la
création du crédit impôt compétitivité
emploi cicr en 2013 les employeurs
étaient exonérées de cotisations de la
branche famille est depuis 2010 9 les
cotisations de la branche famille des
employeurs ont été supprimés remplacés
par l'affectation d'une part des
produits de la tva c'est profondément
injuste
raison pour laquelle nous continuons de
plaider en faveur du rétablissement des
cotisations sociales tout en ayant
parfaitement conscience de l'opportunité
politique de la part du groupe union
centriste de s'adresser aux familles les
plus aisées à quelques mois des
élections présidentielle et législatives
et sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes voteront en faveur du
rétablissement de l'universalité des
allocations familiales en parfaite
cohérence avec notre opposition 2014 à
la modulation des prestations familiales
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame annick jacques mais
pour le groupe union centriste
pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
olivier mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vise à apporter une première
solution pour contribuer à réduire voire
inverser la baisse de natalité que
connaît notre pays ces dernières années
son dispositif supprimera la modulation
des allocations familiales
selon le revenu de la famille qui a été
introduit il y a 6 ans alors que la
question démographique était absente des
débats chez la plupart de nos voisins
européens la france s'est distinguée
dans les années 1930 en mettant en place
une polo une politique volontariste pour
les familles plus précisément dès 1945
autour d'un principe celui de la
solidarité envers les familles qui ont
des enfants à charge un véritable succès
puisque l'on s'aperçoit que la france a
eu l'un des taux de natalité les plus
importants du continent
pierre angulaire de la politique
familiale en france les allocations
familiales possède un caractère
universel c'est à dire qu'elles sont
versés à toutes les familles dès la
naissance de leur deuxième enfant elle
entend inciter les parents en avoir
plusieurs pour pouvoir renouveler les
générations
notons au demeurant qu'il s'agit d'un
élément majeur pour soutenir notre
système de retraite par répartition
les allocations familiales permettent de
faire partiellement face aux coûts
engendrés par ces naissances elles ont
été pensées d'un même montant
quel que soit le revenu des familles et
était majoré lorsque nez c'est un enfant
supplémentaire
le principe d'une modulation mis en
place où le cac et d'un hollande
constitue une remise en cause du
principe égalitaire qui régissait les
allocations familiales
avec un montant identique pour tous les
foyers elle avait pourtant une
signification symbolique importante les
charges de famille devait avoir le même
sens politique et social pour l'ensemble
de la population
la remise en cause de leur caractère
égalitaire et universel fait en effet
peser un risque majeur de délitement de
la cohésion sociale entre les familles
la famille centriste a toujours été
attaché à ce principe d'universalité et
nous regrettons qu'il était et est remis
en question il y a quelques années
philosophiquement cette allocation se
justifie en raison des éléments précités
et non pour compenser une quelconque
disparité de moyens financiers entre les
familles pour cela il existe d'autres
compensations
en modulant cette allocation le principe
d'universalité
s'il n'a pas été supprimée a toutefois
vu sa portée limitée c'est à l'occasion
de l'examen de la loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale de 2015 et avec l'aval
du gouvernement cherchant certainement à
faire des économies que les députés ont
adopté des amendements socialistes qui
prévoyait qu'à partir de juillet 2015
des allocations familiales de base
serait divisé par deux à partir de 6000
euros de revenus mensuels pour un foyer
avec deux enfants et par 4 à partir de
8000 euros de revenus cette modulation
avait déjà entraîné à l'époque des
débats entre les différentes familles
politiques en séance publique au sénat
notamment
la majorité sénatoriale avait en effet
déposé des amendements pour supprimer
cette disposition
pensant que ce principe temps des
textures des familles plutôt qu'à se
recentrer sur l'enfant elle a pourtant
été rétablie à l'assemblée nationale
dans un contexte de natalité en baisse
il était important de remettre le sujet
sur la table et je remercie notre
collègue olivier henno d'avoir déposé
cette proposition de loi je note qu'un
seul amendement est d'ailleurs porté à
notre discussion je salue le travail de
notre collègue qui en sa qualité de
rapporteur de la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale est parfaitement en
mesure d'anticiper la soutenabilité de
cette mesure pour cette branche de la
sécurité sociale
cependant dire que la natalité
dépendrait d'une allocation famille elle
reviendrait à dire que la volonté
d'avoir plusieurs enfants se résume
uniquement à une contrepartie financière
ce n'est évidemment pas le cas et ce
serait de toute façon difficile à
mesurer nous ne pouvons pas ignorer que
le contexte du moment joue un rôle temps
lorsqu'il s'agit d'avoir un premier
enfant que lorsqu'il s'agit d'envisager
un deuxième voire plus il ne faut pas
oublier que ces dernières années n'ont
pas été faciles à tous points de vue
attentat crise sanitaire inquiétudes de
l'avenir
nous avons ainsi peut remarquer une
baisse de la natalité en france et en
europe une étude menée par the lands est
d'ailleurs montré que 40 % des jeunes
interrogés
il s'agissait de dix mille jeunes de 16
à 25 ans remettait en question leur
désir d'enfant avec la crainte du
réchauffement climatique ces chiffres
interpellent même si à cette tranche
d'âge ce n'est pas la préoccupation
première
pour autant le parallélisme entre cette
dernière qui baissent au moment où les
allocations familiales sont modulés dans
notre pays est indéniable en effet on
constate depuis 2015 une chute de la
natalité
nous sommes passés de 8 118 mille
naissances en 2014 à 7 153 milles
d'essence en 2019 il y a donc vraiment
matière à s'intéresser à la question est
ce lien avec le tournant de notre
politique familiale ne peut être
occultée
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
vise à supprimer la modulation du
montant des allocations familiales en
fonction du revenu du foyer
cela réaffirmera le soutien de l'état à
l'égard des familles et il s'agirait
d'un premier pas pour renforcer la
politique familiale socle de notre
société
mais il faut conclure j'ai trop la ligue
olivier on en entendra texte vous avez
déjà dépassé de 20 secondes je suis
désolé votre autorité n'a terminé chers
collègues ni faut calibrer vos enfants
invention merci de les calibrer c'est la
règle pour tout le monde et à pâte
rêveur la parole est maintenant à la
présidente nathalie delattre pour le
groupe r d est ce pour 4 minutes et 4
bis juste ça fait 4 x 60 secondes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pourquoi
soutenons nous la natalité en france
pourquoi la famille a toujours été dans
notre pays au coeur de notre action
publique parce que notre politique
familiale vise renouvellement des
générations parce qu'elle entend
maintenir le niveau de vie des familles
malgré les coûts engendrés par la
naissance et l'éducation des enfants
elle participe de fait est la lutte
contre la précarité la pauvreté sur
notre territoire parce que notre modèle
vise à favoriser la meilleure
articulation possible entre vie
familiale et vie professionnelle
un pilier essentiel pour garantir une
égalité réelle entre les femmes et les
hommes dans notre pays depuis
l'ordonnancé du 4 octobre 1945
différentes aides ont été mises en place
pour poursuivre ses objectifs mais ces
dernières années de nombreuses réformes
isolés ont été menées sans véritable
réflexion sur ce que signifie faire
famille au 21ème siècle ou même sans
réelle cohérence globale nos mesures de
soutien ont par conséquent perdu en
lisibilité et leur mode de versement
fallu retrouver plus complexe que jamais
la modulation du versement des
allocations familiales dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui a par exemple été
adopté par un amendement au plfss
sans étude d'impact ni concertation avec
les acteurs concernés une double peine
pour nos classes moyennes qui avait déjà
subi l'abaissement du plafond du
quotient familial en 2013 et en 2014
or les allocations familiales ont
historiquement été mise en place pour
soutenir tous les citoyens français
désireux d'avoir un enfant
indépendamment de leurs ressources face
aux pays anglo saxons nous nous étions
en or gris de ce modèle d'équité fondée
sur une solidarité horizontale les
ménages sans enfant reversant aux
familles avec enfants et notre
démographie dynamique semblait y
répondre plus que favorablement nous
restons le pays le plus fécond d'europe
mais depuis 2014 2015 un indice
conjoncturel de fécondité n'a fait que
baisser passant même en dessous du seuil
de renouvellement des générations en
2018 la naissance d'un enfant engendre
nécessairement des coûts qui rendent le
niveau de vie des ménages avec enfants
plus faibles que ceux sans enfant
d'après un rapport de la direction
générale du trésor de 2015 l'écart entre
les familles sans enfant et celle avec
trois enfants et plus s'élèverait à 26%
le principe d'universalité des
allocations familiales n'est pas qu'une
mesure symbolique nous ne pouvons
exclure systématiquement une tranche de
la population nos systèmes de
redistribution sociale si nous
souhaitons que cette solidarité perdure
notre dispositif dette comprend un volet
important de redistribution verticale
pour soutenir les foyers les plus
vulnérables je pense notamment aux
allocations de rentrée scolaire au prime
de naissance ou d'adoption et au
complément familial et depuis 2015
d'autres réformes importantes ont su
soutenir tout aussi efficacement le
niveau de vie des ménages les plus
pauvres comme la revalorisation du rsa
dans le cadre du plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté et la création de la prime
d'activité il est important de rappeler
que la réforme de 2015 n'a pas bénéficié
aux ménages les plus fragiles il
s'agissait uniquement de réduire le
déficit de la branche famille or le
versement des allocations familiales ne
peut et ne doit pas être une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire mon groupe
parlementaire conditionnera son vote à
l'adoption de l'amendement de notre
collègue colette mélot visant à
supprimer l'exonération sur le revenu
dont bénéficient les allocations
familiales pour ma part je voterai en
faveur de la proposition de loi
présentée par notre collègue monsieur
olivier henno dont je salue le travail
visant à redonner un caractère universel
aux allocations familiales je profite de
cette occasion monsieur le ministre pour
vous interpeller sur la nécessité de
redonner un cap stratégique à notre
politique familiale face à la diminution
du nombre d'enfants par ménage à
l'augmentation du nombre de familles
monoparentales et à la multiplication
des schémas familiaux il est
indispensable de lancer un family act à
la française un appel déjà lancé par une
mission d'information parlementaire
jusqu'à ce jour les c'est
malheureusement sans réponse je vous
remercie madame la présidente
la parole est maintenant madame corinne
féret pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour six
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour débattre d'un texte
remettant en cause un principe fort
auquel le groupe socialistes écologistes
et républicains est particulièrement
attaché la justice sociale oui car c'est
lors du quinquennat de françois hollande
et plus précisément lors du vote du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2015 que la
modulation du montant des allocations
familiales et de ces deux composantes en
fonction des ressources du ménage ou de
la personne qui a la charge des enfants
a été instituée certes cette mesure
s'est traduite par une meilleure
maîtrise des finances publiques à un
moment où les comptes de la branche
famille était déficitaire mais surtout
elle a permis tout en respectant le
principe d'universalité d'aider
davantage les familles modestes
nombreuses comme monoparentales oui
cette modulation qui poursuivait avant
tout un objectif de justice sociale a
permis de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre pour revaloriser l'allocation
de rentrée scolaire l'allocation de
soutien familial ou encore le complément
familial
nous avions l'ambition non seulement de
réduire la pauvreté mais également de la
prévenir et de limiter la reproduction
d'une génération à l'autre ce qui
justifiait un soutien accru aux familles
modestes et à leurs enfants nous
considérions et c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui qu'une politique en
direction des familles ne doit pas avoir
pour unique finalité d'améliorer un taux
en l'espèce de la fécondité par femme
elle doit en effet déployer toute une
série de mesures prises par l'état les
collectivités territoriales et les
organismes de sécurité sociale pour
aider les familles à élever leurs
enfants à faire face aux charges
financières qu entraînent leur naissance
et leur éducation ces mesures peuvent
prendre la forme de prestations
financières versées aux parents ou des
aides publiques en direction des
infrastructures qui facilite la garde
des enfants ou l'exercice des fonctions
parentales par exemple tout ne se passe
donc pas par les prestations familiales
et c'est bien pour cela que nous
plaisons nous plaidons pour la mise en
place d'un véritable service public de
la petite enfance c'est bien pour cela
aussi qu'il est erroné d'affirmer que la
modulation des allocations familiales
aurait constitué une remise en cause
d'un des principes fondamentaux de notre
solidarité nationale il n'y a pas de
plus grande solidarité que d'aider les
plus vulnérables
il est tout aussi excessif d'affirmer
que la réforme introduite en 2015 sur
verre responsable d'une baisse de la
natalité
l'insee vient d'indiquer que la france
reste en tête des pays européens en
termes de taux de natalité alors on peut
tordre les chiffres dans tous les sens
les faits sont là évoquer les
conséquences du rallongement des études
et de l'entrée tardive sur le marché du
travail permettrait sans nul doute
d'expliquer bien des taux de fonte de
fécondité par tranche d'âge beaucoup
plus que la modulation des allocations
familiales pour encourager la natalité
dans notre pays je note qu'il est de bon
ton ces derniers temps de faire des
propositions démagogiques voire
populistes comme celle qui consiste à
vouloir verser dix mille euros pour
chaque nouvelle naissance dans une
famille je cite de la france rurale
revenons plutôt à des mesures qui ont
fait leurs preuves pour encourager les
femmes à avoir des enfants comme
l'augmentation des solutions d'accueil
et de garde les politiques volontaristes
en matière de logement ou celles
oeuvrant à la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
permettre aux femmes d'avoir des enfants
et de travail et de conserver un emploi
stable voilà qui devrait davantage
occupés certains candidats à la
présidentielle enfin nous trouvons
dommage que cette proposition de loi ne
s'appuie sur aucune donnée précise si
free compte tenu des enjeux notamment
budgétaires une étude d'impact aurait
permis de lever bien des doutes et à
titre personnel et j'avoue ne pas avoir
non plus compris que le texte de
monsieur le rapporteur sous-entendent
que la modulation des allocations
familiales contre et conduirait à
s'interroger sur la possibilité de
moduler et d'autres prestations
jusqu'ici universel à l'instar des
prestations d'assurance maladie et
remettant ainsi en cause notre modèle
social il n'a évidemment jamais été
question lors de la réforme de 2015 il
ne semble pas que ce soit à l'ordre du
jour c'est donc hors sujet je le dis car
alain précision il ne faudrait pas que
s'ajoutent des contrevérités vous l'avez
compris le groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains votera donc
contre cette fois proposition de loin
d'autant plus que la france traverse une
période difficile en lien avec un
contexte sanitaire instable qui est venu
encore fragiliser nos compatriotes les
plus vulnérables à l'image notamment des
enfants mineurs de familles
monoparentales dont 40% d'entre eux vit
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
dominique théophile pour le groupe air
des pays pour quatre minutes vous avez
la parole chers collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la proposition de loi de
notre collègue olivier henno tendant à
renforcer l'universalité des allocations
familiales repose sur la thèse selon
laquelle leur modulation introduite en
2015 a précipité la baisse des
naissances dans notre pays la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 voilà en effet posé le principe
d'une modulation des allocations
familiales
les majorations pour age et de
l'allocation forfaitaire en fonction des
ressources du ménage cette réforme
souhaitée par le gouvernement d'alain
juppé par celui de lionel jospin est
appliquée par celui de manuel valls a
été menée dans un souci assumé de
maîtrise des dépenses publiques et alors
que les côtes de la branche famille de
la sécurité sociale était déficitaire
concrètement cette réforme se portaient
sur les familles les plus aisées c'est à
dire celles qui perçoivent des revenus
supérieure à 6000 euros par mois un
effort de solidarité en divisant par
deux ou par 4 le montant des allocations
familiales qui leur sont versés en 2016
environ 450 mille familles étaient
concernés par cette modulation c'est
moins de 10% du nombre total
d'allocataires
j'aimerais dans le peu de temps qui
m'est qu'on accordait revenir sur
certains des arguments qui ont été
avancés par notre rapporteur
le premier d'entre eux qu'au fond à mon
sens causalité et corrélations il est
vrai en effet que la france enregistre
depuis quelques années une baisse de
natalité en 2014 elle comptait 8 118
mille bébés en 2019 on a dénombré sept
cent cinquante trois mille en baisse de
8%
peut-on affirmer pour autant que la
réforme des allocations familiales en
est l'une des causes principales à vrai
dire nul ne le sait ce que l'on sait en
revanche c'est que l'ensemble des pays
de l'osce et des reconnaissent une
baisse de leur natalité la france qui
avait très longtemps figure d'exception
n'échappe plus à la reine elle demeure
pourtant avec 1,8 enfants par femme à la
première place des pays européens contre
1,56 en moyenne le second argument
consiste à dire que la modulation des
allocations familiales est une remise en
cause des principes d'universalité et de
solidarité mes chers collègues
entendons-nous bien il ne s'agit pas de
remettre
au nom en cause le caractère universel
des allocations familiales mais bien de
principe de répartition dans
l'attribution outre le fait que
l'ensemble des prestations liées à la
politique familiale fonctionne selon ce
principe c'est justement parce que cette
mesure d'économie repose uniquement sur
les plus les foyers les plus aisés
qu'elle a un sens en 2019 les familles
monoparentales représentait près de
quart des familles avec enfants elles
sont vous le savez plus souvent en
situation de précarité que les autres
dans la majorité des cas les parents
seuls est une femme car pour cent des
enfants mineurs qui sont dans ces
familles vivent par ailleurs en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté monétaire pour moi
accepter dans ce contexte que les 830
millions d'euros qui coûterait ce retour
en arrière bénéficient uniquement aux
familles les plus aisées comment
expliquer demain à nos concitoyens
qu'une famille dont les parents gagnent
le smic percevoir la même chose une
famille de cadres alors même que
celle-ci
chargement de notre politique familiale
et bénéficient déjà ce constat que nous
sommes nombreux à partager dans ce pays
ne signife ap signifie pas pour autant
que la situation actuelle est
satisfaisant beaucoup pourraient être
faits pour rendre les allocations
familiales plus juste il s'agit d'en
modifier le seuil les seuils ou de
renforcer le soutien aux familles
monoparentales mais cela fera peut être
l'objet d'un prochain débat vous l'aurez
compris mes chers collègues nos
priorités it en différentes notre groupe
votera résolument contre cette
proposition de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame colette mélot pour le
groupe les indépendants pour 4 minutes
le sud monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission monsieur leur apporte mes
chers collègues voilà deux siècles
malthus nous disait en substance qu'il
fallait restreindre la croissance
démographique d'une nation pour ne pas
mettre en péril son avenir nous savons
aujourd'hui qu'une population nombreuse
est l'une des conditions de la puissance
la période révolutionnaire et
napoléonienne nous a démontré très tôt
que le nombre fait bien souvent la force
la démographie dynamique de la france a
longtemps nourri sa puissance sans
d'ailleurs que des allocations ne soit
alors distribuées mais celle ci s'est
émoussée plusieurs initiatives privées
avaient mis en place des allocations
destinées aux parents au sortir de la
première guerre mondiale c'est le
gouvernement d' andré tardieu qui a créé
le premier une politique familiale
volontariste par la loi du 11 mars 1932
l'objectif poursuivi par le versement
d'allocations familiales et de
contribuer au renouvellement des
générations par une politique de soutien
à la natalité est de maintenir le niveau
de vie des familles cela explique
qu'elles aient longtemps et est
décorrélé des ressources des parents le
gouvernement de manuel valls a réussi là
où celui de lionel jospin avait échoué
il est parvenu à faire adopter la
modulation du montant des allocations
familiales en fonction des revenus des
parents la politique nataliste c'est
alors teinté de justice sociale notre
collègue olivier et nous rapporterait
auteurs du texte nous invite à revenir
sur cette corrélation pour que le
montant des allocations familiales ne
soit plus lié aux ressources des
bénéficiaires
si nous sommes tous attachés à la
politique familiale menée par la france
depuis plusieurs décennies beaucoup en
revanche sont partagés sur le sujet de
cette décorrélation nombreuses
monoparentales ou recomposées les
familles françaises ont beaucoup évolué
durant ces 70 dernières années les
ménages ont vu leur taille moyenne se
réduire de près d'une personne un
changement dû à plusieurs facteurs
l'augmentation des séparations et le
développement de la monoparentalité la
baisse du nombre moyen d'enfants par
famille mais également le gym semant de
la population et l'augmentation du
nombre de personnes vivant seules dans
le sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
il est important de tenir compte de
l'augmentation du nombre de familles
monoparentales avec le risque de
précarité associés à ce phénomène alors
les deux positions peuvent en effet se
justifier la politique familiale ne
poursuit pas a priori un objet un
objectif de justice sociale elle ne vise
pas à corriger une différence de revenus
mais bien on a encouragés à avoir des
enfants les allocations devrait donc
être fonction des enfants mais pas des
ressources de notre côté il peut
apparaître tout à fait légitime ne pas
revenir sur la modulation des
allocations en fonction des revenus la
valeur incitative de leur montant se
justifie difficilement quand il s'agit
de parents à revenu élevé à titre
personnel j'ai déposé deux amendements
sur ce texte le premier a pour objet
d'intégrer ces allocations dans
l'assiette de l'impôt sur le revenu il
me semble cohérent que ces allocations
soient traités comme des revenus mon
second amendement était considérée
contraire à l'article 40 de la
constitution par la commission il visait
à permettre le versement des allocations
familiales dès le premier enfant le
seuil de deux enfants encourage en effet
les familles à atteindre si ce n'est à
dépasser le seuil fatidique du
renouvellement de la population à savoir
2,1 enfants par femme il me semble
néanmoins que cette incitation n'impose
pas qu'aucun
qu'aucune allocation familiale soit
versée pour le premier enfant je note
d'ailleurs que les fonctionnaires ont
droit au supplément familial de
traitement dès leur premier enfant je
constate également que les allocations
familiales sont versées dès le premier
enfant dans l'intégralité des autres
pays de l'union européenne ainsi qu'au
royaume uni à l'heure où la population
européenne vieillit il nous faut
continuer d'inciter nos concitoyens à
avoir des enfants si nous ne voulons pas
voir notre population décroître et notre
puissance à lesquels nous devons surtout
donner aux français des raisons de
croire que demain sera mieux
qu'aujourd'hui et les membres du groupe
les indépendants voteront selon leurs
convictions très bien
la parole est maintenant madame
christine lagarde pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour cinq minutes
lopes
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur auteurs vous avez déjà dit
beaucoup dans votre propos liminaires et
notamment le constat qui est partagé à
savoir une chute drastique de la
natalité et pourtant le désir d'enfant
est toujours là toujours au constant
puisque en 2020 comme en 2010 les
français aspirent à avoir 2,39 enfants
par famille récemment le haut
commissariat au plan l'a dit clairement
la politique familiale soutien à la
natalité
tout en relevant que l'orientation
générale des décisions prises ces
dernières années en matière de politique
familiale n'a pas été celle d'un soutien
à la natalité une étude de l'ined
publiée en novembre 2000 21 dit
clairement que les politiques familiales
et les conditions économiques
conjoncturelles joue un rôle majeur sur
les niveaux de fécondité depuis 2013 la
politique familiale a été détricoté le
mouvement initié sous le quinquennat
françois hollande n'a pas été revu avec
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle majorité même
si le président de la république en
avril 2019 a donné à la famille le
statut de permanence de la société et a
indiqué vouloir rétablir la force d'une
politique familiale ce détricotage s'est
opérée sous la force de deux mouvements
de transfert tout d'abord deux
prestations universelles on est passé à
des prestations ciblées et
majoritairement des livres et sous
conditions de ressources en 2013 puis en
2014 le quotient familial a été abaissé
en 2014 les allocations familiales ont
été modulée le seuils d'attribution de
la page ont été modifiés ces mesures
sont des mesures de restrictions
financières et non pas des mesures de
redistribution
il n'y a pas eu d'argent pour les
familles les plus modestes il y a eu
juste moins pour les familles modestes
ou aisés c'est un effet sensible pour
les familles touchées l'unaf a chiffré
les pertes liées à la modulation pour
les familles de trois enfants à 34
milles euros pour le premier plafond est
à 51 mille euros pour le second plafond
avec la modulation un effort est demandé
aux familles aisées ayant des enfants et
non célibataires aisé aux couples
n'ayant pas ou n'ayant plus d'enfants à
charge c'est une simple raisons
budgétaires
la branche famille est excédentaire elle
sert à financer des déficits
et ailleurs d'ailleurs en novembre
dernier lors de l'examen du plfss
le sénat a supprimé le transfert d'un
milliard d'euros de la branche famille
vers la branche maladie pour dénoncer
les manques de mesures prises par ce
gouvernement durant cinq ans en faveur
de la famille une vraie politique
familiale ce serait de revaloriser les
prestations alors juste niveau elle le
second transfert et celui est une
modification se dépense qui relevaient
de la politique familiale sont
essentiellement devenus des dépenses qui
relève plutôt de la politique sociale
par exemple la hausse de 138 euros par
mois du complément de garde pour les
familles monoparentales déshérités la
création de plage soutenu uniquement
dans les quartiers défavorisés les repas
à 1 euro à la cantine cette confusion
apparaît clairement d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre dans le discours que vous
avez prononcé devant la conférence de la
famille en octobre dernier alors je
soutiens c'était la première depuis 15
ans donc c'est bien des familles mais
vous venez aussi de le réaffirmer en
disant que vous ne partagiez ni la
démarche ni l'esprit de cette
proposition de loi pour autant nous nous
pensons que cette proposition de loi
permet d'ouvrir un débat sur la
définition d'une vraie politique
familiale au delà de la seule question
de la redistribuer en novembre 2010 est
olivier ferrand qui était leur
rapporteur du budget de la sécurité
sociale faisait le constat de
l'existence d'une vingtaine de
prestations familiales dans lesquelles
personne ne s'y retrouve c'est ça qu'il
faut être capable d'analyser dans un
ensemble il ne s'agit pas de dire
l'universalité ou non alors le constat
était posée mais depuis rien n'a été
fait pour simplifier une politique
familiale efficace repose sur une
diversité diversité d'outils
compensation des charges aides
spécifiques qui permettent des réponses
adaptées à chaque famille quel que soit
sa composition ou son lieu de vie et qui
ne s'arrête pas aux 20 ans de l'enfant
la joie mais aussi les contraintes et
les responsabilités liées à l'accueil
d'un enfant ne dépendent pas du niveau
des revenus et chacun connaît l'adage
petits enfants petits soucis grands
enfants grand souci quelques solutions
pour favoriser l'égalité hommes femmes
par l'aide apportée aux familles comment
supprimer ces effets de seuil injuste et
incohérent si pénalisant pour le travail
des femmes au delà de la petite enfance
qu'elle pratique de conciliation peuvent
être promus tout au long de la vie pour
favoriser l'exercice des solidarités
familiales
comment permettre à toutes les femmes id
offrir un logement décent et des
possibilités d'études à leurs enfants
beaucoup de sujets sont ouverts que dire
à la prochaine coche de la cnaf quelle
forme prendra le futur service public de
la petite enfance que vous appelez de
vos voeux le déclin démographique de la
france obère l'avenir on l'a dit
l'équilibré du régime de retraite ne
dépend pas uniquement de l'augmentation
de la durée des cotisations
elle dépend aussi du nombre de cotisants
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à monsieur dominique de legge
pour le groupe l'est républicain pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
sur le président sur ministre madame la
présidente de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur mes premiers mots seront pour
remercier notre collègue olivier nau
d'avoir pris l'initiative de cette
proposition doit
l'abandon régulier progressive de
l'universalité des allocations
familiales
débuté depuis plusieurs années mais
érigée en principe en 2015 son
quinquennat de françois hollande est
poursuivie sous l'actuelle me semble une
triple erreur bien sûr parce qu'il
s'agit d'un détournement des principes
fondamentaux de la sécurité sociale qui
voulait que à revenu égal les familles
en ayant charge d'enfants voit une
partie compenser les coûts liés à leur
éducation
initiée avant guerre par certains
patrons il s'agissait de verser je le
rappelle sur le fondement d'une
rémunération égale pour un travail
identique ce qu'il était convenu
d'appeler un sirh salaires dont
l'ouverture était exclusivement fondée
sur la présence ou non d'enfants et bien
évidemment pas sur le revenu mais je ne
souhaite pas tant rappeler ce principe
fondateur que réfléchir avec vous
quelques instants sur l'erreur qui
consiste à vouloir confondre politique
familiale et politique d'assistance aux
revenus les plus modestes aux risques
d'affilée les familles à des cas sociaux
l'erreur première consiste à ne pas voir
dans l'aide aux familles ou à vouloir
voir dans l'aide aux familles qu'une
seule branche de la sécurité sociale en
oubliant tu la politique familiale ne
constitue pas une dépense de
fonctionnement récurrentes comme la
maladie ou la vieillesse la famille ne
relève pas d'une logique assurantielle
car elle ne constitue pas un risque à
couvrir bien au contraire elle relève
d'un investissement et en cela elle
participe de la pérennité de la société
de notre dynamisme démographique et
économique de notre rayonnement culturel
la vitalité démographique conditionne
bien sûr la solidarité entre les
générations et l'explosive dossier des
retraites en est un exemple je ne puis
que déplorer que les excédents régulier
la branche famille en partie due à la
réduction des bénéficiaires soient
systématiquement détournées de leur
objet pour financer d'autres branches
je souhaite rappeler que la modulation
imposé aux familles en 2004 n'a réduit
les inégalités qu'à la marge et à
pénaliser les familles les plus
nombreuses du fait d'un dispositif de
lissage très limité ainsi un faible
supplément de rousseau front due à une
forte diminution des allocations l'effet
de seuil s'avérant très élevés
particulièrement pour les familles
nombreuses
la seconde erreur a trait aux effets de
seuil de revenu qui a pour conséquence
de décourager certaines femmes de
reprendre une activité et je pense plus
particulièrement dans les familles les
plus modestes ou l'effet de seuil pour
effet de se dire que tout bien compté il
vaut mieux rester à la maison que
reprendre un travail enfin au risque de
m'attirer les foudres d'une partie de
l'assemblée je ne vois pas pourquoi nous
devrions servir des prestations à des
familles qui n'assument pas leurs
responsabilités éducatives les
allocations samilia meoli je m'y
attendais je m'en réjouis les
allocations familiales si vous voulez
bien comme écouter 30 secondes ne doit
pas être considéré comme un droit sans
contrepartie à la solidarité de la
nation doit respon les pondre la
responsabilité des familles
effectivement chers collègues si vous
faites une confusion entre une politique
d'assistance aux revenus les plus
modestes et les prestations familiales
il faut verser les prestations
familiales à tout le monde
si vous considérez que effectivement il
ya une contrepartie
la question mérite d'être posée sur le
ministre vous avez tenté en tous les cas
vous n'avez pas convaincu de nous
expliquer que pendant cinq ans vous
aviez fait tout très bien ce que je
constate simplement c'est que les
excédents de la branche famille eux ils
ont été détournées de leur finalité est
que à tout le moins ils auraient pu
servir où vous auriez pu les affecter à
une revalorisation d'élite prestation
c'est pourquoi chers collègues je
voterai sans réserve ce texte qui
replace dispositif des allocations
familiales dans leur philosophie et leur
vocation initiale d'accompagnement à
l'éducation de soutien notre démographie
de solidarité envers les familles qui
font le choix d'avoir des enfants sans
lesquelles aucun pays n'a d'avenir je
vous remercie
merci
nous passons à la discussion du texte de
la commission
à l'article 1er alors mes chers
collègues j'ai beaucoup de demandes de
parole je vous rappelle qu'après ce
texte il ya encore un des bras la
demande du groupe union centriste qui
dure une heure 45 et nous ne suspendrons
pas ce qui veut dire qu'il ya quelques
malheureux qui je l'espère reste
jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire jeu tout près
de 22 heures donc si chacun pouvait
rester dans une brièveté de bon aloi ce
serait très bien la parole est à
monsieur stéphane demi pour le groupe
union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur la
présidente à la lecture de l'exposé des
motifs de cette proposition de loi de
mon collègue et ami olivier non je me
suis posé quatre questions y at il
vraiment un problème de natalité en
france 2 le montant des allocations
familiales est il de nature à influencer
le taux de fécondité
3 faut-il une politique égalitaire ou
une politique équitable et enfin 4 le
système de protection social peut-il se
permettre une dépense supplémentaire les
réponses m'amène au constat suivant tout
d'abord notre taux de fécondité en 2020
qui est de 1 87 et le meilleur indice de
fécondité en europe cela s'explique par
le fait que notre pays a su intégrer le
fête familiale dont les besoins
quotidiens des familles je pense au
travail à temps partiel aux cantines
dans les écoles au développement des
crèches aux aides pour les vacances ou
encore à l'évolution de notre droit du
travail c'est la conciliation entre la
vie professionnelle et la vie familiale
et la vie sociale qui permet aux
familles de réaliser leur désir d'enfant
et si le gouvernement allemand
d'ailleurs cet aspire avec succès de
notre modèle ce n'est pas un hasard il
me paraît donc très rapide de faire un
parallèle entre rétablissement des
allocations familiales pour familles
aisées et incidence positive sur le taux
de fécondité en france tel victor hugo
qui nous rappelle dans les misérables
que la première égalité c'est l'équité
notre pays a opté pour le principe de
redistribution verticale pour promouvoir
une plus grande justice sociale un
retour à l'universalité des allocations
familiales marquerait un changement de
cap à contre-courant de l'histoire du
modèle social
enfin au delà de renforcer un sentiment
d'injustice sociale déjà grandissant
notre système de protection sociale déjà
déficitaire de plus de 38 milliards
d'euros dont 2 pour la cnaf n'est pas en
mesure de digérer une nouvelle inflation
de dépenses si j'entends les arguments
de nombre de français qui ont le
sentiment de données sans jamais
recevoir je ne suis pas sûr à titre
personnel que cette proposition soit des
plus judicieuses sur le plan
démographique social budgétaire et
politique c'est la raison pour laquelle
je traduirai mon scepticisme en
abstentions
puis dire la parole est maintenant
monsieur olivier paccaud merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre sur à
porter une réforme de justice et de
responsabilité
voilà les mots employés en 2014 par un
gouvernement socialiste est prétendument
réformateurs à propos de la modulation
des allocations familiales juste et
responsable la remise en cause d'un
principe fondateur de notre modèle de
politique familiale
juste et responsable la fin de la
reconnaissance universelle de l'état à
l'égard des français qui font le choix
tant d une famille juste et responsable
de faire du foyer une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire en ne sacrifiant
aux logiques comptables de réduction du
déficit public non il n'était ni juste
ni responsable ni équitable de moduler
cette allocation en distinguant les
enfants du seul fait de leur origine
sociale postuler le contraire c'est
oublier que ce dispositif vieux de 77
ans a permis à la france de bénéficier
d'une dynamique démographique puissante
est offert à des millions de françaises
les ressources nécessaires à la
maternité la justice sociale est
ailleurs elle est notamment dans l'impôt
qui détient une réelle fonction
redistributive et d'atténuation des
inégalités de revenus la solidarité se
sont aussi les nombreuses prestations
sociales dont la vocation est là aussi
d'apporter une aide aux plus fragiles
aux plus modestes d'entre nous mais en
aucun cas les allocations familiales
pierre angulaire de l'architecturé
française de la protection sociale ne
saurait être équitablement légitimement
moduler et pour cause avoir renoncé à
l'université rue l'universalité de cette
tête de la nation à toutes les familles
c'est avoir ouvert une brèche
pourquoi dès lors ne pas moduler l'accès
aux soins à l'enseignement public ou
encore le droit à une retraite pour tous
en fonction des conditions de ressources
c'est l'esprit de la sécurité sociale
lui même qui est ébranlée lorsque l'on
estime qu'un enfant né dans une famille
aisée entre guillemets ne mérite plus de
bénéficier de la solidarité nationale or
si notre modèle social nous honore c'est
précisément parce qu'il est universel
parce qu'il embrasse toute la diversité
des formes familiales alors contribué à
sauvegarder en votant cette excellente
proposition de loi de notre collègue
olivier henno
c'est la parole est à madame martine
filleul
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la cour des comptes
révèle dans son rapport sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale que la prévalence de
la pauvreté chez les couples avec un
enfant est supérieure à celle observée
chez les couples sans ou avec deux
enfants
cela est d'autant plus vrai pour les
familles monoparentales qui constitue
près d'un quart des familles françaises
la moitié ne compte qu'un seul enfant
contre 36% pour les familles recomposées
ou traditionnel et un tiers d'entre
elles vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
rappelons que ces familles
monoparentales sont à 85 % des femmes
qui élèvent seules presque 3 millions
d'enfants se sont donc encore une fois
les femmes qui sont les plus touchés par
la précarité
c'est pourquoi une réforme juste de
l'allocation de soutien familial
consisterait non pas à soutenir toutes
les familles quelles que soient leurs
revenus et par voie de conséquence les
familles aisées mais plutôt d'ouvrir le
droit à cette aide dès le premier enfant
comme c'est d'ailleurs déjà le cas dans
les départements d'outre-mer plusieurs
pays européens ont fait ce choix comme
la belgique la suède le danemark ou
encore très récemment l'italie
cette mesure demandée lors du grand
débat national de 2019 et figurant dans
ma proposition de loi pour une meilleure
inclusion des familles permettrait de
soutenir les familles monoparentales
notamment et les femmes si souvent
deux familles qui en particulier dans
cette période de crise méritent toute
notre solidarité
merci la parole est à madame valérie
boyer merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente la
politique familiale en france est un
levier essentiel de nos politiques
publiques savent y est être dit cette
politique soutient le dynamisme de notre
économie et contribue aussi à la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
par répartition
la france est ainsi l'un des pays au
monde où le taux d'activité des femmes a
été le plus élevé sans que cela n'ait eu
pour autant pénaliser la natalité
pourtant le nombre de naissances est
effondrée passant de 800 18000 en 2014 à
740 millions en 2020 la politique menée
depuis 2012 a remis en cause des
fondements de notre politique familiale
nul n'est besoin de le nier le haut
commissariat au plan le dit la politique
familiale soutient la natalité celle ci
a été mise à mal mais la politique
familiale ne peut plus continuer à être
la variable d'ajustement de nos
politiques sociales en matière de
politique familiale emmanuel macron
malheureusement est bien le fils
spirituel de françois hollande alors que
le taux de natalité est en baisse
constante le gouvernement a poursuivi
une politique qui pénalise les familles
baisse du montant de la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant baisse de son
plafond et de la prime de naissance des
indexations des prestations familiales
en 2019 et 2020 refus de rétablir
l'université des allocations familiales
et le plafond du quotient familial mis à
mal par françois hollande logique
comptable la branche famille de pour la
branche famille et qui brise le pacte
social s'en prendre à la famille c'est
aussi s'en prendre à l'avenir à l'avenir
de nos enfants et de notre pays c'est
aussi une violence qui est faite aux
femmes d'aujourd'hui parce que choisir
entre travail et avoir des enfants et le
dilemme que se posent les jeunes femmes
aujourd'hui et ne pas assez de ne pas
être assez bien accueilli pour avoir les
enfants ou non le nombre d'enfants que
l'on souhaite quand on le souhaite voilà
une société qui n'est pas accueillante
pour les jeunes mamans aussi
l'universalité des allocations
familiales repose sur l'idée que chaque
enfant est une richesse pour notre pays
et son avenir et ceci quel que soit leur
source de ces deux de ses parents mais
nous devrions également développer les
modes de garde et pour remédier à ces
injustices qui bride la vie des femmes
sur le plan professionnel
allons plus loin en augmentant le
quotient familial de façon significative
osons des mesures salaire pour toutes
les femmes qui ont un enfant et qui
travaille à temps plein ou à 80% par
exemple en exonérant leurs salaires des
charges patronales salaire jusqu'au 6
ans de l'enfant j'avais chirac jacques
chirac le 17 mai est un pilier de notre
société non non non non madame boyer
j'ai bien dit deux minutes ces deux
minutes c'est pas de mur va aller
excusez moi merci infiniment chers
collègues la parole est à monsieur mène
en ville merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je me réjouis que notre assemblée se
saisisse d'un sujet aussi important que
à l'initiative notamment de notre
collègue olivier neau ce texte dénonce
une rupture progressive de la
philosophie qui a prévalu à la mise en
place du système de sécurité sociale par
le conseil national de la résistance
après la première et la seconde guerre
mondiale une à une les allocations
familiales bénéficier alors sans
condition à toutes les familles ayant au
moins deux enfants de moins de 20 ans
est à charge
l'universalité des allocations
familiales a été détricoté en 2015 en
effet un amendement du plfss a introduit
une modulation de l'allocation familiale
selon les revenus de la famille les
montants octroyés aux familles des
passes à certains seuils ont été divisés
par deux et par quatre en effet cette
transformation de ces aide a été
subordonnée à un besoin cette évolution
constitue ainsi un réel aso a fait
blissement donc de notre politique
familiale il donc au point opportun
aujourd'hui de revenir à l'universalité
des allocations familiales
merci chers collègues la main 92e madame
mélo
à la mélo c'est à vous sur l'amendement
beau merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement a pour objet de supprimer
l'exonération d'impôt sur le revenu dont
bénéficient jusqu'à présent les
allocations familiales il permet
d'intégrer les allocations dans
l'assiette de l'impôt sur le revenu par
cet amendement il n'y a pas d'atteinte à
l'universalité qui est tout à fait
légitime dans une politique de natalité
mais ils rétablis une justice sociale
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cet amendement vise à
assujettir à l'impôt sur le revenu les
allocations familiales qui à l'instar de
toutes les prestations familiales ne
sont aujourd'hui pas prise en compte
dans leur revenu imposable
cet amendement conduirait donc à imposer
le montant des allocations selon l'auto
marginal d'imposition des ménages
augmentant selon le revenu il va donc à
l'encontre de l'objet de la proposition
de loi qui vise à soutenir les familles
sur le seul fondement du nombre
d'enfants à charge en outre ils
réduiraient leurs revenus disponibles
pour les familles à revenus moyens voire
modeste qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
concernés par la modulation et c'est
pour le moins paradoxal cet amendement
ne vise donc pas une politique sociale
familiale ambitieuse ni même lisible
puisque le message envoyé aux familles
serait contradictoire avec la fin de la
modulation des allocations familiales
avis défavorable donc chers collègues
merci à vis du gouvernement
je à monsieur chassaing
sur l'amendement monsieur le président
c'est sur l'amendement donc
effectivement le découpage entre le
revenu le niveau de revenu et le montant
les locaux l'allocation familiale a été
mis en place par le gouvernement du
général de gaulle et donc 73 % des
familles de plus de deux enfants
bénéficier de cette prestation jusqu'en
2014 l'idée de mettre en place les
conditions de ressources avait été
proposé par lionel jospin en 1997 et
adopté en mai en 2015 avec une économie
de 760 millions d'euros je suis
favorable à redonner aux allocations
famille leur caractère universel à
condition de les considérer comme des
éléments de revenus soumis au barème de
l'impôt cette mesure a été défendue par
raymond barre en 87 et alain juppé en 95
en contrepartie de la fiscalisation des
allocations familiales je souhaite
étendre à l'ensemble du territoire
le versement des allocations familiales
dès le premier enfant mesure qui
s'applique aux départements d'outre-mer
donc l'université d'allocations
familiales ne paraît être une mesure
essentielle pour soutenir la natalité
compenser le coût de l'éducation des
enfants pour l'ensemble des familles
favoriser la conciliation entre famille
et travail je vais entrer en faveur de
l'amendement visant à concilier vocation
universelle des allocations mais aussi
je le pense justice sociale concernant
cette ppl si la maman n'était pas
accepter ce qui est possible et bien je
m'abstiendrai très bien je mets au voit
donc cet amendement numéro 2 avec deux
avis défavorables commission et
gouvernement qui et pour
qui compte
il est rejeté je mets aux voix l'article
1er qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté je mets aux voix l'article
2 non modifiées qui pour
[Musique]
des contres
il est adopté je vais mettre voit
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
je mets aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi dans la commission a
rédigé ainsi l'intitulé proposition de
loi tendant à renforcer
l'universalité des allocations
familiales
qui est pour
[Musique]
et qui est contre
qui s'abstient
la proposition de loi est adopté
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre merci madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
l'ordre du jour appelle madame la
ministre je vous salue appelle le débat
sur le thème l'amélioration de la prise
en charge des personnes atteintes du
trouble du déficit de l'attention à la
demande du groupe union centriste
où
elle que dans ce débat le groupe union
centriste disposera de huit minutes de
temps de présentation le gouvernement a
la faculté s'il est juste nécessaire de
prendre la parole immédiatement après
shocked orateurs première est de 2
minutes l'orateur disposera alors à son
tour du droit de répartie pour une
minute le temps de réponse du
gouvernement à l'issue du débat est à
cinq minutes le groupe auteurs de la
demande de débat aura également 5
minutes pour conclure
je veux lui dire parler tout d'abord
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat madame jocelyne 10 days pour le
groupe union centriste pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'amélioration de la prise en charge du
trouble du déficit de l'attention qui
s'accompagne non d'hyperactivité c'est
le sujet qui nous réunit ce soir dans
l'hémicycle le trouble du déficit de
l'attention après géantes et des âges
présente au moins trois volets déficit
de l'attention impulsivité ou
hyperactivité
ces symptômes peuvent provoquer une
souffrance durable au quotidien il peut
constituer aussi un handicap invisible
pour l'enfant ou l'adulte dans son
apprentissage ses relations sociales ou
sa vie professionnelle force est de
constater que ce trouble pourtant
fréquents et méconnu très mal reconnue
est sous diagnostiquée et concerne
environ 5% des enfants puisque 2,5 de la
population adulte soit environ 2
millions de nos compatriotes
il exista significatif retard français
en matière de diagnostic et
d'accompagnement par ailleurs les signes
évocateurs du tdah peuvent être
semblables à ceux des troubles anxieux
de la précocité intellectuelle
aussi le thé d âge est souvent associée
à d'autres to land is telle la dyslexie
le syndrome des jambes sans repos et
c'est ce qui rend particulièrement
complexe diagnostic et induit parfois
une certaine errance médicale c'est la
lutte ils vont inciter à déposer une
proposition de loi visant à améliorer le
dépistage de ce trouble à prendre en
compte sa singularité à faciliter sa
prise en charge grâce à une meilleure
formation des professionnels de santé et
d'éducation en systématisant les
consultations pour les enfants concernés
selon un proverbe chinois mieux vous
allumer une bougie que maudire
l'obscurité notre collègue collègues
années que jacques mais à qui j'adresse
mes sincères remerciements pour son
engagement sans faille à réaliser un
délai andere très court des auditions de
qualité pour certaines associations la
concertation sur ce sujet à la fois
complexe et sensible n'avait pas été
assez large n'est assez précoce je peux
comprendre leur position néanmoins je
suis surprise de certains concurrence
entre associations comme l'a si bien dit
simone veil aussi longtemps qu'on
s'entend qu on partage on vit ensemble
non seulement on vit ensemble met en
outre en avance ensemble je salue la
décision du groupe union centriste de
transformer l'examen de ce texte en
débat cette volonté des discussions est
une note d'espoir l'objectif final étant
que la situation de nombreux amis
s'améliore enfin le dépôt de ce texte
n'a pas été inutile puisque nous parlons
du tdah au sénat et nous en parlerons de
plus en plus désormais j'en suis
persuadé je tiens à rappeler les
répercussions de ce trouble dans
diverses sphères familiale scolaire et
sociale commençons par le familial en
raison de son omniprésence dans la vie
de l'individu concerné l'entourage se
retrouvent aussi affecté les parents
sont en premier chef frappé par la
souffrance de leurs enfants et le regard
que les autres portent sur lui l'enfer
c'est les autres pour reprendre la
fameuse phrase de jean paul sartre ces
regards extérieurs perçoivent l'enfant
quand la mal élevés en raison de son
comportement ne parvenant pas à
appréhender d'emblée le fonctionnement
d'un cerveau atypique le diagnostic
apparaît alors comme un soulagement pour
les parents qui doivent entreprendre
ensuite un parcours du combattant il
difficile de tout concilier le travail
les rendez-vous avec l'école les soins
et leur gestion au quotidien ses parents
sont obligés de travailler à temps
partiel voire de renoncer à leur vie
professionnelle pour s'occuper de leurs
enfants cette situation creuse les
inégalités sociales scolaires dans le
cadre scolaire l'enfant rencontrent des
difficultés
anxiété dépression harcèlement
décrochage phobie vomissements fatigue
pleurs stress crise d'angoissé avant et
après la classe de nombreux vins qui
s'ouvre ne lui permettent pas une
scolarité réussie en général les parents
dialogue avec les enseignants les
informent diagnostic de leurs enfants
ainsi que de ses différents symptômes
malgré ces efforts de part et d'autre
l'inclusion scolaire n'est pas toujours
effective sur le terrain les demandes de
la sache ne sont pas partiellement
accepté faute que réels moyens alloués à
l'intégration des élèves ayant des
besoins spécifiques la scolarité de ses
enfants en structures spécialisées ou en
école privée n'est pas financièrement
possible pour tous les parents ce qui
met en péril le principe d'égalité des
chances
socialement nombreux sont les risques
liés à la non prise en charge des
enfants risque plus élevé d'addiction de
dépendance de délinquance et dessus
suite d'alcoolisme il semblerait qu'il y
ait chez les adultes davantage
suspension de permis de conduire
d'accidents et d'arrestations on observe
aussi chez les adultes à risque
d'addiction deux à trois fois plus
important selon certains études
internationales la prévalence du tdah
dans la population carcérale s'élèverait
à 26%
malheureusement pour la majorité des cas
le viennent aussi n'a été établie ni
durant l'enfance nés durant
l'adolescence cela a des conséquences
négatives sur la vie professionnelle
arrêt de travail plus fréquent des
pressions chômage répété en ce qui
concerne le parcours de soins il s'agit
d'abord de mesures psychologique
éducative et sociale si celle-ci ne
suffisent pas un traitement
médicamenteux peut être prescrit par
certains spécialistes bien évidemment je
m'inscris dans la mouvance qui évite de
suivre l'exemple américain et s'efforce
d'éviter le recours massif aux
médicaments le tdah reste le parent
pauvre de la stratégie nationale pour
l'autisme et les troubles de neuro
développement lancés par le gouvernement
en 2018 la réalité est décevante il
semble que le tdah n'a été que
tardivement inclus dans cette stratégie
sur un même pied que les autres troubles
il s'avère que les actions de ce plan ne
suffisent pas
les plates formes de coordination et
d'orientation dédié aux enfants de 7 à
12 ans ne sont pas encore opérationnels
a su que la circulaire
interministérielle des concernant
n'ayant été publié qu'en septembre
dernier je regrette tant d'années
perdues pour les familles combien de
temps auront elles été abandonnés à leur
propre sort ce n'est plus admissible les
délais moyens d'attentes dans les centre
d'action médico sociale précoce ou les
centres médico psycho pédagogique
peuvent dépasser une année voire même
plus par conséquent les familles sont
parfois contraints de supporter les
frais du suivi pluridisciplinaire
hebdomadaire afin de procurer à leurs
enfants un accompagnement immédiat cela
pèse lourdement sur leur budget et les
oblige à réduire la fréquence des soins
et autres actions d'accompagnement vous
l'aurez compris la méconnaissance de ce
trouble entraîne un retard diagnostic un
retard d'accès aux soins et une prise en
charge non adapté ses repères à la prise
en charge peuvent conduire à une
aggravation des conséquences
psychologiques scolaire et sociale ainsi
qu'à l'installation de troubles associés
il existe des inégalités territoriales
d'accès aux spécialistes afin d'établir
un diagnostic formel de ce trouble la
formation au tdah des professionnels de
santé est encore insuffisante pour une
prise en charge efficace du trouble il
faut repérer diagnostiquer et intervenir
précocement diffuser des connaissances
en formant les acteurs de première ligne
et favoriser l'inclusion scolaire ainsi
que la guidances familiale c'est
pourquoi je propose une formation
continue des enseignants une formation
plus complète des professionnels de
santé une amélioration de c'est aux
soins par un dépistage précoce et
systématique des enfants concernés afin
de mieux prendre en considération ce
handicap invisible une fois le trouble
repéré l'accès aux équipes
pluridisciplinaires dans des délais
acceptables s'avère nécessaire afin de
permettre une égalité des chances pour
chaque patient chers collègues les
enfants tdh milan et mieux identifier
mieux accompagner seraient des adultes
mieux épanouie dans notre société est
moins dépendant de notre système social
il est anormal qu'en france les enfants
soient mises de côté parce qu'ils ne
sont pas dans la norme ce débat est une
réelle opportunité pour aboutir à la
reconnaissance du dh pour que nos
enfants puissent arfa être considéré et
intégré dans une société inclusive tel
défini par charles gardou une société
sans privilèges sans exclusivité ni
exclusion je vous remercie pour votre
attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame laurence
cohen pour le groupe crc e pour cinq
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais tout
d'abord salué le travail réalisé par nos
deux collègues de l'union sans du groupe
union centriste
à l'initiative de la proposition de loi
visant l'amélioration de la prise en
charge des personnes atteintes du
trouble du déficit de l'attention avec
ou sans hyperactivité
lors de la réunion de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat les auteurs
ont estimé que les conditions n'étaient
pas réunies pour en discuter en séance
publique et ont préféré retirer la
proposition et l'a remplacé par ce débat
je souhaite que ce soit le début d'un
travail législatif que tu eux car c'est
une question de santé publique qui
dépasse les clivages politiques
les trouble du déficit de l'attention
concernerait 2 millions de personnes en
france dont huit cent mille enfants soit
entre 3 et 5 % des enfants de 6 à 14 ans
auquel il convient d'ajouter des adultes
très peu diagnostiqué un tiers des
enfants tdah présente des difficultés
d'apprentissage souvent associés à des
troubles du langage près de 25% des
enfants tdah en compte des difficultés à
lire et à écrire la prévalence de la
dyslexie est plus fréquente 25 % que
dans la population générale 6% la
mémoire de travail leur fait défaut pour
résoudre les problèmes à prendre ce qui
est dit en cours ou encore prendre des
notes toute activité qui demande un
certain type de planification leur pose
problème
cette lenteur pour traiter les
informations est un handicap sur le plan
scolaire comme personnel malheureusement
les enfants concernés par ce trouble de
neurodéveloppement pâtissent d'un
déficit de prise en charge par une
équipe pluridisciplinaire à l'hôpital
comme en libéral la pénurie des
professionnels notamment des
orthophonistes retarde l'établissement
d'un diagnostic hypothéquant une prise
en charge précoce madame la ministre
réitère l'exigence de supprimer le
numerus clausus pour les orthophonistes
appelé pudiquement quotas les centres
médico psychologique cmp comme les
centres médico psycho pédagogique cmpp
ne sont pas davantage en capacité
d'organiser des actions de prévention de
diagnostic et de soin par manque de
moyens financiers et humains la
pédopsychiatrie est sinistrée on ne
cesse de le dire mais rien ne se passe
en outre à l'image d acheter ils
connaissent eux aussi des fusions ce qui
éloigne les populations des lieux de
soins et ne raccourcit pas les délais
d'attentes loin s'en faut outre la
nécessité de mettre en place des
rééducations en orthophonie
psychomotricité
ou encore ergothérapie mais souvent
également des psychothérapies il est
nécessaire de renforcer la formation des
équipes enseignantes ainsi que les
accompagnantes et accompagnants d'élèves
en situation de handicap ash sur des
troubles du déficit de l'attention avec
ou sans hyperactivité
je profite de ce débat pour me faire
l'écho du ballet de clsh qui se
mobilisent pour de meilleures conditions
de travail et de salaire comme vous le
savez il s'agit majoritairement de
femmes en grande précarité qui subissent
des contrats à durée déterminée pendant
des années ce qui a pour première
conséquence des salaires
particulièrement bas je parle ici de 800
euros à ses salaires de misère s'ajoute
une dégradation de la qualité du suivi
des enfants puisque depuis
l'instauration des pôles inclusive
d'accompagnement localiser les ash
accompagne de plus en plus d'élèves
madame la ministre avez vous l'intention
de robes revaloriser ce métier et
d'accorder le statut de fonctionnaire ou
un os h qui exercent leur métier depuis
des années enfin concernant la prise en
charge des dépenses de santé le 21 mai
dernier le conseil national consultatif
des personnes en situation de handicap a
adopté à l'unanimité une motion
interpellant l'état en faveur d'une
meilleure prise en compte des restes à
charge qu'elle doive acquitter comme
vous le savez est particulièrement pour
les tdah de nombreux frais ampute leur
pouvoir d'achat ainsi que d'ailleurs
celui de leur famille en dépit du
respect des protocoles de soins nous
considérons que les dépenses de santé
doivent être prises en charge
intégralement par l'assurance maladie
afin de garantir l'accès aux soins y
compris pour celles et ceux qui n'ont
pas d'assurance santé c'est vrai pour
les enfants mais également pour les
adultes atteints de tdah je voudrais ce
propos madame la ministre vous
sensibiliser sur au moins deux des
revendications de la coordination
donald et dh adultes le temps mais tant
compté êtes vous prête madame la
ministre à prendre des mesures
permettant la reconnaissance du tdah en
affection longue durée êtes vous prête à
mettre en place une formation des
professionnels de santé dédiés au
diagnostic et au traitement du tdah de
l'adulte en particulier en psychiatrie
en addictologie en milieu carcéral et en
neurologie enfin pour terminer il me
semble essentiel d'un dab la mise de
financer la recherche pour étudier les
effets à long terme de l'utilisation de
la ritaline traitement miracle pour
certains et dangereux pour d'autres en
tous cas ce débat est important et je
vous en remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame annick jacques
mais pour le groupe union centriste pour
8 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues se devait
initialement rapporté la proposition de
loi déposée par jocelyne 10 days
inscrits à l'ordre du jour elle est
remplacée par ce débat j'ai reçu comme
beaucoup d'entre vous des messages de
parents nous racontant leur détresse
leurs difficultés au quotidien leurs
doutes aussi j'ai été très touché par
ces fragments de vie ses appels au
secours mais aussi ces témoignages de
parents fiers d'accompagner leurs
enfants envers et contre toutes les
difficultés je conserve des auditions
quelques convictions de tdh que l'on
réduit trop souvent l'hyperactivité est
d'abord une importante source de mal
être la has le qualifie de souffrance au
quotidien est inscrite dans la durée il
touche plus de 2 millions de personnes
on ne peut donc s'en désintéresser cette
souffrance est difficile à qualifier et
à identifier les familles sont
réticentes à parler de maladies ou de
handicaps et on peut les comprendre
ce n'est pas une maladie puisqu'il n'en
existe pas de signes neurologiques ou
physique est qu'à ces signes évocateurs
sont semblables à ceux d'autres troubles
tels ceux des troubles anxieux de la
précocité intellectuelle ou du spectre
autistique
du reste le tdah est souvent associée à
d'autres de ces troubles il s'agit
plutôt d'une association de différents
symptômes qui ne lui sont pas propres et
qui n'appellent la qualification de tdh
que lorsqu'ils atteignent une certaine
intensité entre aignan des conséquences
gênantes dans la vie quotidienne la
qualification de handicap est également
contestable pour la même raison et sur
le plan administratif les cdaph par
méconnaissance refusent très souvent de
le reconnaître il en découle une
première observation il se pourrait que
nos mécanismes de protection sociale
conçue en termes de soins financés par
l'assurance maladie ou de handicap
pris en charge par les circuits
spécifiques de la politique de handicap
maintiennent certaines infections dans
des angles morts desquels nous devrions
chercher à des extraits certes ce
trouble peut être traitée on peut
apprendre à vivre avec mais il faut voir
comment et entendre à cette fin des
psychiatres des neuroscientifiques et
des associations comme je lé fais on
s'aperçoit alors que le tdah constitue
aussi à son échelle un enjeu de santé
publique
on observe les adultes et dh un risque
d'addiction deux à trois fois plus
important les addictologues formé à la
clinique du tdah diagnostic se trouve
chez 20% de leurs patients et pour 95%
de ces situations le diagnostic n'avait
jamais été établis antérieures
antérieurement
selon certains études internationales la
prévalence du tdah dans la population
carcérale s'élèverait à 26% repérer et
traitées précocement est un impératif à
titre individuel mais aussi collectif
certains d'entre vous se souviennent
peut-être qu'un dépistage systématique
des troubles du comportement chez les
enfants avait été envisagé il ya une
quinzaine d'années par le président
sarkozy sur la base d'un rapport de
l'inserm cela avait à l'époque suscité
des réticences car il s'agissait
manifestement d'un outil de lutte contre
la délinquance mais on peut parfaitement
considérer cet impératif sous un angle
strictement sanitaires et c'était
d'ailleurs ce que proposait jocelyne 10
days qui crée dans le code de la santé
publique de nouvelle consultation
systématique au blé à thouars pour les
enfants la deuxième observation nous
avons en matière de repérage et de prise
en charge précoce des marges de
progression à exploiter qui peuvent
entraîner des conséquences favorables
sur le comportement social des jeunes le
tdah reste très mal connue d'une manière
générale et curieusement par les
professionnels de santé eux-mêmes ou
qu'en soit la recherche le terme de
retard français en matière de diagnostic
et d'accompagnement revient très souvent
dans le discours associatif et
scientifique le gouvernement a certes
doté la stratégie nationale relative à
l'autisme et au terme des deux mesures
importantes et je ne doute pas que vous
saurez nous le détail et madame la
ministre je songe d'une part à la
création d'un parcours de prise en
charge et d'autre part à la
solvabilisation des familles par la
création d'un forfait intervention
précoce on peut toutefois douter que ces
actions suffisent d'abord il semble que
le tdah n'ait été inclus dans la
stratégie à l'égal des autres troubles
que tardivement au point que les
associations contestent encore que le
livret de repérage pour les plateformes
7-12 ans leurs soins adaptés ensuite
toutes les actions du plan ne produiront
pas leur effet immédiatement les
plateformes 7 12 ans par exemple ne sont
pas encore opérationnels
la circulaire interministérielle qui les
concernent n'ayant et ont été publiés
qu'en septembre dernier enfin même si le
plan était doté d'environ 350 millions
d'euros depuis 2018 il lancé limites le
forfait d'intervention précoce le durkan
ans renouvelable une fois le
conventionnement avec les professionnels
est limitée à trois professions il
appuie enfin ses efforts de coordination
sur les ressources existantes par
exemple et pc aux sont assises notamment
sur les centres d'action médico sociale
précoce ou les centres médico psycho
pédagogique
or selon un rapport de l'igas dès 2018
les délais moyens d'attentes sont de 4
mois pour les tams et de sept mois pour
les cmpp mais peuvent dépasser une année
voire plus en conséquence les parents
impuissants devant les symptômes de
leurs enfants et leurs conséquences
dramatiques sur son éducation se trouve
dans une errance diagnostique
ils vont ainsi ballotté entre des échos
inadaptée des médecins convaincus que
leur enfant n'est que mal élevés et
lorsqu'ils trouvent des spécialistes
souvent éloignés ils y consacrent
plusieurs centaines d'euros par mois non
remboursés une telle situation accuse
les inégalités d'accès aux soins qui
existe déjà car seules les familles
aisées peuvent offrir à leurs enfants
l'accompagnement dont ils ont besoin et
ce n'est pas acceptable
il faut donc aller plus loin encore sur
le plan de la formation en novembre 2000
21 la has identifie la formation des
professionnels comme premier enjeu d'une
meilleure prise en charge de ces
troubles la stratégie nationale a engagé
des efforts intéressant mais il faut
être plus systématique c'était l'objet
des deux premiers articles la
proposition de loi d'origine qui
précisaient les obligations de formation
initiale et continue du personnel
enseignant et des professionnels de
santé sur le plan des connaissances la
diffusion des 5 du savoirs théoriques et
pratiques relatifs à chacun des tnd
devra tendent à s'homogénéiser la
stratégie nationale a prévu la création
d'un groupement d'intérêt scientifique
et de cinq centres d'excellence ainsi
que le développement de réseaux
d'excellence et de collaboration
internationale il faudra veiller à ce
que le tdah il soit bien pris en compte
sur le plan de la scolarisation
l'autorégulation déployés dans une
trentaine d'écoles donne d'excellents
résultats sur le profil des enfants tdh
les méthodes d'intervention utiliser
fonctionne sur tous les enfants atteints
de tnd et les groupes d'entraidé
mutuelle ont été ouverts aux autres
troubles le chantier de l'adaptation du
travail en classe au respect des
différences des enfants restent
néanmoins largement ouvert
je voudrais en conclusion dire à toutes
les associations que j'ai rencontrés
ainsi qu'à celles que je n'ai pas eu le
temps de 10 y aune et que nous restons
mobilisés avec elle sur cette question
si importante pour le bien-être de nos
enfants est d'une part notable de nos
concitoyens et à vous madame la ministre
vous poser quatre questions comment
permettre l'adaptive l'adaptabilité de
notre protection sociale
nous avons su en faire preuve pour l'aco
vide nous devons désormais nous
organiser pour ne plus laisser personne
dans l'errance quitte à nous améliorer
au fil de l'eau comment rendre les
métiers qui entourent notamment les tdah
plus attractifs pour qu'il existe une
offre satisfaisante permettant un
dépistage et un accompagnement et
comment s'assurer de la formation de ses
personnels enfin comment assurer un
principe d'égalité en assurant aux
familles une prise en charge de leurs
frais par la solidarité nationale je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à madame véronique guillotin
pour le groupe r d est ce pour cinq
minutes
ça marche monsieur le président madame
la ministre collègues c'est d'abord avec
une pointe de regret que le groupe rds a
accueilli la transformation de l'examen
de la proposition de loi en débat car
nous étions convaincus de pouvoir faire
bouger les lignes pour rouler deux
millions de personnes atteintes de
trouble du déficit de l'attention avec
ou sans hyperactivité
le droit d'amendement et la navette
parlementaire aurait pu permettre de
faire évoluer le texte et mieux répondre
aux demandes des associations en tout
cas le nombre conséquent de
sollicitations reçues ces derniers jours
démontrent l'intérêt fort pour ce sujet
et le besoin de reconnaissance qui lui
est associée nous espérons donc que ce
débat permettra de mettre en avant les
nécessaires actions entreprendre pour
améliorer la prise en charge des
personnes atteintes de trouble du
déficit de l'attention
ce qui dans un contexte de campagne
présidentielle ne peut être complètement
inutile ces troubles du
neurodéveloppement se caractérise par
trois symptômes principaux l'inattention
l'impulsivité l'hyperréactivité mais il
regroupe une variété de situations et de
comportement les rangs temps difficiles
à diagnostiquer cela a été dit par les
orateurs précédents peu connu et très
mal connue et très mal reconnus font
pourtant au deuxième rang des troubles
en pédopsychiatrie touchant 5 % des
enfants et 2 5% de la population
générale or s'ils se caractérise par des
troubles du comportement
il augmente aussi significativement le
risque d'accident d'arrestation
d'addiction en plus de la question de la
prise en charge d'un handicap viennent
donc s'ajouter des questions de sécurité
et de santé publique
malheureusement comme dans beaucoup
d'autres cas je pense par exemple à
l'autisme le constat d'un retard
français est relativement souvent
partagés je ne m'étendrai pas sur la
nécessaire amélioration de la formation
du personnel éducatif cette formation
est de toute façon insuffisante cela
fait des années que tout le monde le dit
si l'on veut rendre effective l'école
inclusive et je crois que c'est
l'ambition de la quasi-totalité de
l'échiquier politique on doit mettre le
paquet sur la connaissance de tous les
types de handicap et sur les moyens de
s'adapter au quotidien et aux
particularités de chaque élève je ne
m'étendrai en revanche sur l'amont à
savoir le diagnostic on le sait la
précocité du repérage du tdah est
cruciale un retard de diagnostic et donc
de prise en charge peuvent conduire à
une aggravation des conséquences et a
des répercussions délétère sur la vie
entière conséquences familiales sociales
scolaires et professionnelles ou
professionnel la pose d'un diagnostic
nécessite l'intervention de plusieurs
professionnels de santé un forfait
intervention précoce permet désormais de
diminuer le reste à charge lors des
consultations avec les psychologues
psychomotriciens ergothérapeutes
mais ce forfait demeure insuffisant et
marquent surtout les difficultés d'accès
à un accompagnement publics gratuits par
les centre d'action médico sociale
précoce et cmpp et les centres médico
psycho pédagogique
obtenir un rendez-vous aujourd'hui peut
relever du parcours du combattant peut
prendre plusieurs mois et cette lenteur
est insupportable et elle conduit
certains se retourner vers des
diagnostics et des rééducations non
remboursés en plus de renforcer les
inégalités sociales car de nombreuses
familles ne peuvent se payer le luxe
d'un reste à charge même minoré cette
réalité nous prive d'un service public
de qualité accessible à tous or dans le
cas d'un trouble à la fois répandu est
mal connue il semble indispensable de
recentrer diagnostic sur une offre
publique en quantité est également et
surtout en qualité cette réalité mérite
en effet un point de vigilance l'état
doit reprendre la main sur le diagnostic
et la prise en charge pour éviter tout
surmédication jeu mais bien sûr de côté
les troubles graves qui peuvent
nécessiter un soutien médicamenteux mais
pour les autres la sensibilisation
l'accompagnement des parents peuvent
représenter une partie de la solution je
pense par exemple aux écrans qui on le
sait jouent un rôle croissant dans le
développement des troubles du
comportement
un accompagnement éducatif dès les
premiers troubles de l'attention peut
permettre de freiner le développement
des symptômes et éviter une prise en
charge plus lourde par la suite l'enjeu
est d'éviter de coller des étiquettes à
des très jeunes enfants quand la clé
peut résider dans de simples ressources
éducatives l'état et les collectivités
sur ce point grand rôle à jouer au plus
près des familles c'est donc un appel à
plus d'engagement de la part de nos
services publics à l'heure où nous
inventons la france de l'après vide une
réflexion de fond sur notre système de
santé doit encore et toujours être mené
les patients les associations les
professionnels ont des idées pour nous
faire avancer dans ce domaine c'est avec
eux que le débat doit se faire désormais
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame corinne
ferrer pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour neuf
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis à présent pour débattre d'un
sujet majeur est pourtant largement
méconnu celui de la prise en charge de
ces millions de français qui souffrent
d'un trouble du déficit de l'attention
avec ou sans hyperactivité
je ne vais pas vous cacher que je suis
triste ce soir car j'aurais aimé que
nous avancions et légiférer riom enfin
pour aider toutes celles et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui en attente d'un
diagnostic en attente de poser des mots
sur ce trouble neuro développe
développementale pardon qui les mine au
quotidien quel dommage de ne pas avoir
profité de la proposition de loi de
notre collègue madame la sénatrice guide
est certes imparfaite proposition de loi
mais que nous pouvions amendé pour aider
toutes ces familles dont calvados comme
ailleurs qui aimerait tant que leurs
enfants soient pris en charge par des
frais professionnels de santé
spécialisés qui aimerait surtout que
l'école soit plus douce plus
accueillante bienveillante avec leurs
enfants trop souvent considéré comme un
élément perturbateur
le mauvais élève dissipé qui n'écoutent
rien oui c'est triste car dans un pays
comme la france des familles emmène
chaque jour leurs enfants à l'école avec
la boule au ventre avec l'espoir que
tout se passe bien qu'il n'y ait pas une
énième punition un énième mot dans le
carnet en espérant aussi que leurs
enfants ne soient pas laissés de côté
isolés voire harceler en temps
parlementaire nous avons tous reçu
notamment par mail les témoignages de
familles ou de personnes directement
concernées qui attendait temps de
l'examen d'une proposition de loi
spécifiquement consacrée au tdah c'est
un rendez vous manqué je le regrette
combien de personnes sont concernées
cela a été aussi évoquée on estime que
ce handicap touche entre 3 et 5% des
enfants d'âge scolaire auxquels il
convient d'ajouter les élus encore
troupe diagnostiqués certes la loi de
2005 pour l'égalité des droits et des
chances la participation et la
citoyenneté des personnes handicapées a
permis la reconnaissance de ce trouble
en tant que handicap cependant il reste
beaucoup à faire et nous avons le devoir
de parler vrai concret ce soir ce
faisant je souhaite ici pointé trois
grandes difficultés en centrant
volontairement mes propos sur la
situation des enfants et des adolescents
tdah tout d'abord force est de constater
qu'on ne connaît pas suffisamment ces
derniers leur nombre réel leur parcours
scolaire le problème est que beaucoup de
ces enfants compensent leur stratégie
entre guillemets font que leurs troubles
peuvent apparaître comme légers là aussi
entre guillemets dissimulant des
difficultés plus importantes uniquement
identifiable au travers de bilan
pluridisciplinaire réalisé par des
spécialistes
aussi une telle compensation par l'élève
ne dure qu'un temps et le risque pour
lui et des choux et durablement de
décrocher au fil du temps les enfants
concernés comme souvent dans la
dépression à l'adolescence car ils ont
tiré sur la corde faisant d'énormes
efforts pour compenser ils peuvent vite
être en échec lorsque personne ne
reconnaît leur valeur ni leurs efforts
pour connaître il n'ya bien sûr
nécessité de mieux recueillir la parole
la parole des familles pour savoir
comment l'école est vécue notamment
comprendre aussi qu'il ya une vie en
dehors de l'école et les difficultés
rencontrées dans le quotidien des
enfants avec l'enfant en situation de
handicap les familles sont encore trop
souvent pointé du doigt culpabiliser
sur ce premier volet je crois qu'il ya
surtout nécessité de mettre enfin un
terme à certains amalgames les enfants
tdh et je pourrais dire la même chose
des 10 ne sont pas autiste de même qu'il
y a un il n'ya pas pardon de même qu'il
n'ya aucun effet de mode à être
diagnostiqués tdah je trouve dommage que
l'on en soit encore là en france en 2022
de même j'ai regretté qu'il existe une
stratégie nationale globalisante pour
l'autisme et les troubles du nord au
développement cette situation est
susceptible d'entretenir des confusions
selon moi deuxième point important et
même centrale du diagnostic beaucoup
tour de familles sont en errance ne
comprenant pas ce qu'à leurs enfants
indisciplinés fait n'ayant ne pouvons
pas travailler ni faire des efforts non
il peut être eu simplement on va dire
tdh la précocité du diagnostic des
interventions est un facteur clé de
prévention sur ceux sur du sur handicap
il lettrisme sortis du système scolaire
conduites à risque n'ont accès au marché
du travail on voit bien qu'il faut
encore réfléchir à ce qui permettrait
d'éviter des années d'errance perdu par
les enfants et leurs familles et donc de
mieux
dépister puis de diagnostiquer un point
de vigilance tout de même je sais qu'il
peut y avoir de la part des familles des
de la défiance vis-à-vis des cmpp
notamment qui sont pas suffisamment
formés aux troubles tdah d'obédience
psychanalytique c'est un vrai sujet en
pratique l'enfant le jeune a souvent
besoin d'un bilan pluridisciplinaire au
coût élevé beaucoup de familles ne
peuvent assumer ce coût elles ne
connaissent pas les dispositifs
existants les plates formes de
coordination d'orientation qui existe
depuis 2010 9 ne sont pas encore
suffisamment connue on ne va pas se le
cacher il ya surtout un réel manque de
professionnels spécialisés
orthophonistes ergothérapeutes neuro
psychologue psychomotricien pour guénot
diagnostic et puis prendre en charge ces
enfants pire même avec des diagnostics
posés certains mdph rechignent à
reconnaître d'un point de vue
administratif le handicap de l'enfant de
plus la caisse en plus de la question
des délais de traitement des dossiers
cette disparité selon les départements
est aussi un vrai problème en troisième
en troisième point je souhaite évoquer
spécifiquement l'école car c'est le lieu
où l'enfant passe minimum huit heures
par jour il ya encore fort à faire pour
améliorer la détection puis la prise en
charge par les équipes éducatives pour
cela il conviendrait de revoir la
formation des enseignants qui devrait
mieux connaître les troubles du nord au
développement il faut une véritable
montée en compétence et non une simple
sensibilisation aux difficultés des
enfants j'aurais pu évidemment dire la
même chose pour les accompagnants ash
notamment et les autres personnels qui
sont présents dans ces écoles en amont
du diagnostic le rôle de l'enseignant
est majeur car il devrait être à même de
repérer les troubles ce qui ne s'y fie
ce qui ne signifie pas diagnostiqués
mais détecter des signes il devrait
ensuite pouvoir orienter la famille vers
un diagnostic est laissée aux
spécialistes le soin de réaliser un
bilan pluridisciplinaire avec des
préconisations adaptées sur lesquels
s'appuient on parle beaucoup d'écoles
inclusive mais même lorsque le
diagnostic posé il ya encore trop de
disparités dans les accompagnements les
prises en charges entre les écoles les
classes aujourd'hui les aménagements
relève encore trop de la bonne volonté
de l'enseignant qui est souvent très
présente enfin je veux terminer sur une
note positive positive car j'ai appris
qu'un avis favorable au remboursement de
la ritaline ltée pour l'adulte avait été
adopté récemment lors de la commission
de transparence de la haute autorité de
santé il est indispensable en effet que
ces traitements soient enfin remboursés
pour les plus de 18 ans qui en ont
besoin bien sûr voilà les quelques mots
que je voulais évoquer dans le cadre de
ce débat je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur qui savait iacovelli
pour le groupe air des pays pour six
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues
hyperactif c'est souvent le terme
employé bien que réducteur pour désigner
les enfants quelque peu turbulent
parfois distraits ou qui peine à
maintenir leurs intentions ce terme trop
souvent utilisé à tort ou à raison sans
bien savoir quelle est cette pathologie
réellement les implications cas là pour
les enfants et leurs familles
hyperactif un chemin du combattant
singulier derrière ce mot pluriel la
réalité pourtant plus complexe et le
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui dans
notre hémicycle permettra en partie d'y
répondre ont toutes eu au moins envoyer
un signal fort pour ces milliers de
personnes souffrent parfois en silence
d'un manque de reconnaissance
vous n'êtes pas seul le trouble du
déficit de l'attention ou avec ou sans
et par activité est encore largement
méconnu il est chez les enfants et il
l'est encore plus chez les adultes il
est méconnu puisque toute la difficulté
réside dans le repérage et le diagnostic
du tdah ainsi l'association tdah france
rappelle que le diagnostic de celui ci
ne s'appuie pas sur un simple examen de
type prise de sang permettant de dire
barils là où il n'a pas c'est bien plus
compliqué c'est bien la persistance des
symptômes au fil du temps leur présence
dans différents environnements et le
retentissement au quotidien qui
caractérise le tdah la haute autorité de
santé précise qu'il s'agit d'un trouble
un syndrome associant trois symptômes
dont l'intensité varie selon la personne
outre le déficit de l'attention il
associe l'hyper activité motrice qui se
manifeste souvent par une agitation
intense ou par la capacité à rester en
place ainsi que l'impulsivité c'est à
dire une difficulté à attendre le besoin
d'agir ou la tendance à interrompre les
activités des autres
le tdah toucherait ainsi deux millions
de personnes dont huit cent mille
enfants
il concerne trois à cinq pour cent des
enfants scolarisés et peut-être une
source de souffrance car il engendre
souvent des difficultés et une
frustration chez l'enfant le repérage et
la prise en charge effective sont donc
deux éléments fondamentaux et
indissociables pour permettre aux
enfants et aux adultes d'appréhender ce
trouble et d'atténuer ses effets sur
leur vie quotidienne
agir plus précocément auprès des enfants
consiste et constitue un enjeu majeur
puisqu'il ya un retard de diagnostic et
une absence de prise en charge peuvent
avoir des conséquences dommageables sur
le plan psychologique tout d'abord
puisque l'enfant qui n'arrive pas à se
concentrer ou à terminer une tâche peut
perdre confiance en lui et se renfermer
sur lui même sur le plan scolaire avec
des redoublements plus fréquent alors
même qu'un accompagnement personnalisé
permettrait un épanouissement scolaire
des enfants atteints de tdah sur le plan
familial puisque les parents ne seront
comment comprendre et appréhender leurs
enfants sur les agissements et donc ça
engendre forcément des situations de
conflit sur le plan social enfin les
enfants atteints de tdah ayant parfois
plus de difficultés relationnelles ce
retard de diagnostic et l'absence de
prise en charge peuvent ainsi avoir des
conséquences sur la vie entière de la
personne notamment en matière d'accès à
l'emploi ou d'insertion sociale
construire une société toujours plus
inclusive dans la ministre reste la
priorité du gouvernement et de la
majorité présidentielle
c'est pourquoi dès 2018 le gouvernement
a adopté une stratégie nationale pour
l'autisme au sein des troubles du nord
au développement qui a permis entre
autres de réaliser des avancées
concrètes notamment dans le champ du
repérage à travers la mise en place d'un
parcours de bilan et d'intervention
précoce celui ci permet de poser un
diagnostic précis avant c'est en
associant médecin traitant médecins de
crèche ou pmi médecin scolaire
psychologue ou psychomotriciens et vise
à éviter tout avance de frais pour les
familles
cela est assurée par des plates formes
de coordination et d'orientation
s'adressant à l'ensemble des personnes
susceptibles de présenter des troubles
du nord au développement vous l'avez
souhaité madame la ministre élargir ses
plateformes aux 7-12 ans ce qui permet
de répondre plus précisément aux besoins
des enfants puisque nous savons
désormais que l'école élémentaire tend à
rendre plus visibles les signes
évocateurs du tdah il s'agit d'une
mesure forte qui permettra à
l'amélioration du quotidien des enfants
et des familles grâce aux 9 millions
d'euros destinée au renforcement de ses
plateformes afin d'accélérer encore
davantage les démarches du diagnostic
vous avez par ailleurs publié lundi un
livret pédagogique à disposition des
professionnels et des parents celui ci
permettra d'aboutir à un repérage encore
précoce des d écart inhabituel de
développement chez les enfants de 0 à 3
ans d'identifier les besoins spécifiques
de l'enfant et de mieux orienter les
parents parfois ce sont tant démunis et
peut accompagner en quelques minutes je
viens de citer de multiples avancées
concrètes afin d'assurer la prise en
charge exhaustive et facilité des
personnes atteintes de tdah il est
essentiel de poursuivre ses efforts mais
un ministre je me réjouis donc de la
tenue de ce débat au sein de notre
musique même si j'aurais préféré
effectivement que ça soit dans le cadre
d'une proposition de loi je voudrais
d'ailleurs remercier mes collègues
mesdames guidel et jacques mai ainsi que
le groupe union centriste de nous avoir
donné l'opportunité de mettre en lumière
ce sujet essentiel nous avons tous reçu
chers collègues d'innombrables
témoignages de familles touchées par le
tdah nous avons tous dans notre
entourage ou nos propres enfants
étaient effectivement touché par cela
démontrant du coup l'importance cruciale
de ce débat il s'agit d'un sujet de
société qui impacte le quotidien de tant
d'enfants dans notre pays avec des
répercussions lourdes pour eux et pour
leurs familles la formation du personnel
éducatif et des professionnels de la
petite enfance ma nana ministre joue un
rôle majeur puisque vous l'avez rappelé
il est essentiel d'agir le plus tôt
possible pour garantir une prise en
charge effective des enfants il est
également nécessaire de mieux
sensibiliser la société toute entière
sur tdah ce débat permettra je l'espère
de démontrer notre implication en faveur
d'une meilleure reconnaissance de ces
troubles à cet égard la journée d'été dh
dont la première édition s'est tenue le
12 janvier 2021 et qui aura désormais
lieu chaque année permettra d'éveiller
les consciences et de changer le regard
sur celui ci parle parce que hyperactif
doit être plus qu'un terme lancé parfois
au détour des conversations
il est une réalité qui nécessitent tout
notre engagement pour l'améliorer pour
améliorer le diagnostic l'accès aux
soins et l'accompagnement de tous je
conclus pourriez vous madame la ministre
dresser un bilan des trois années de
mise en oeuvre de stratégies nationales
pour l'autisme au sein des troubles de
nouveaux développements et en
particulier sur l'accompagnement des
familles dans lors des matchs une
intervention
iacovelli une fois un seulement prendre
cinq secondes oui c'est vrai je suis
d'accord la parole est à monsieur daniel
chaise sain pour les indépendants pour
cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
je voulais vous féliciter
jocelyne guidait et annick jacques mais
pour avoir déposé et rapporter cette
proposition de loi visant à améliorer la
prise en charge des enfants atteints de
troubles du déficit et de l'attention
avec ou sans hyperactivité
et pour le travail d'auditions très
approfondie il s'agit d'un problème
relativement fréquent puisque 5 % des
enfants sont concernés
2,5 pour cent des adultes ce texte ce
texte a été rejeté par la commission en
ce qui concerne j'étais favorable mais
bien sûr ce comprend la volonté de
renforcer la concertation auprès des
associations d'enfants autistes le tdah
caractérise par trois composantes
l'hyper activité motrice l'inattention
et l'impulsivité les difficultés de
concentration sont souvent associées à
une opposition permanente à des
dyslexiques ce trouble du nord au
développement a parfois des conséquences
importantes sur la scolarité la vie
sociale de l'enfant puis de l'adulte
avec le risque plus important de
décrochage scolaire et de désinsertion
professionnelle
le dd moyenne de diagnostic et de deux
ans et demi trois en france avec souvent
des errances le dépistage précoce est
pourtant primordiale mais nous avons un
manque évident personnel médical
pédopsychiatre par exemple et
paramédical orthophoniste
psychomotricien notamment pour une prise
en charge plus professionnelle
l'accompagnement de l'enfant souvent
coûteux pour les parents le sessad les
cmpp
se trouvent souvent démunis faute de
personnel adéquat pour une véritable
école inclusive
nous devons aussi renforcer la présence
des avs former tout au long de la
journée scolaire et périscolaire y
compris à la cantine les enseignants
sont les premiers à signaler bien sûr
aux parents les problèmes d'inattention
en cas cette agitation
les élèves concernés peuvent être mis de
côté et parents sont parfois en très
grande souffrance nous devons donc mieux
les accompagner pour les aider à
comprendre des troubles de l'enfant leur
permettent d'adopter une attitude
positive
avec bien sûr les des soins pour
l'enfant une stratégie nationale pour
l'autisme et des troubles du
neurodéveloppement été lancé par le
gouvernement en 2018 elle vise
précisément à renforcer l'information
des professionnels
coordonnées des soins et diminuer le
reste à charge pour les familles faut
saluer ces avancées pour repérer mais
nous devons aussi renforcer la prise en
compte des tdah et former autant les
professionnels de santé que les
enseignants l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi prévoyait d'instaurer
deux consultations de dépistage
obligatoire des troupes d'une rolls
développement c'est bien mais je voulais
rappeler qu'il existe en plus du bilan
de trois ans un bide un bilan de santé à
6 ans et la cour des comptes indique
dans son dernier rapport sur la médecine
scolaire que seulement 18 % de ces
visites ont été réalisés en 2018 faute
bien sûr de médecins scolaires
disponible
avant d'ajouter donc de nouvelles
visites médicales obligatoires nous
devons aussi régler le problème de la
pénurie de médecins scolaires et
permettre à tous les enfants avant 6 ans
d'effectuer leurs bilans de santé
madame le ministre
j'aimerais aussi évoqué
un mot je dire un mot appelez votre
attention sur les élèves que l'on
appelle surdoué ou à haut potentiel dont
certains présentent ce trouble de
l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
certains pays identifie très tôt ses
enfants elle leur propose une scolarité
adaptée
la solution
proposée historiquement en france
consistait à faire sauter une ou
plusieurs classes c'est pas forcément
idéal il faudrait décloisonner davantage
à scolarité de ses élèves sans forcément
brûler des étapes en nous inspirant des
initiatives qui ont fait leurs preuves à
l'international je souhaite en
conclusion remercier particulièrement le
groupe union centriste de nous avoir
offert cette occasion de débattre de la
prise en compte des tdah dans ses
différents aspects merci merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
monsieur philippe mouiller pour le
groupe l'est républicain pour cinq
minutes
on n'avance pas on va faire passer
madame poncet monge pour le groupe
génération écologie solidarité
territoire pour cinq minutes aussi
d'ailleurs
mais il passera par l'eba dame bon c'est
bon je venais madame pour ses manches
monsieur philippe mouiller la prochaine
fois ne bougera pas de son siège
à d'aller prendre un café pendant qu'on
reste largement y est
c'est pas grave allez vous passer juste
après merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre chers collègues les
écologistes se félicitent qu'un débat
sur les troubles de l'attention et dole
et par activité remplace la proposition
de loi qui en est à l'origine non que le
sujet ne mérite pas notre intérêt mais
nous car nous avons entendu le désarroi
des familles l'errance médicale les
coûts non remboursés associés aux prises
en charge et nous remercions le groupe
centriste d'avoir mis à l'ordre du jour
mais le législateur doit se garder de
devenir prescripteur normatif en partant
d' approche théorique et clinique qui ne
représente pas toutes les pratiques
soignantes et du katyn le dépistage
précoce dix tdh porté sur le carnet de
santé de l'enfant ou la capacité pour le
médecin généraliste de porter de
diagnostic à partir d'un module de
formation de quelques heures
apparaissent comme des préconisations
qui escamote les présupposés théoriques
sur lesquels elle s'appuie d'après un
neuropédiatre spécialiste des troubles
neurodéveloppementaux un quart des
élèves d'une classe souffrirait soit de
troubles dys ou de l'attention ou de
l'hyperactivité faudrait-il dépister
pour autant systématiquement à
différents âges comme on dépiste une
déficience visuelle l'étonnant d'un
trouble héréditaire
prédestinant mécaniquement à des
difficultés voire à toutes sortes de
déviance drogue délinquance préconise
logiquement une politique de dépistage
de l'enfant symptômes porteur d'un
dysfonctionnement d'une région de son
cerveau évalué à grand renfort de tests
et des sels mettant à jour les déficits
et jamais les ressources mobilisables
par l'enfant suzanne de son histoire
le diagnostic posé il est possible
d'orienter parfois vers une
reconnaissance de cet handicap invisible
et souvent cette approche issus des
sciences neurocomportementale conduit
naturellement thérapies
cognitivo-comportementales
force est de constater que comme aux
états unis bien avant nous cette
approche tend à devenir hégémonique dans
beaucoup de dispositifs tendance contre
laquelle le mouvement des psychologues
cliniciens s'est élevée n'ont pas et
c'est important pour en contester la
légitimité mais pour défendre la
pluralité des approches scientifiques
qui font la richesse de l'enseignement
et des pratiques thérapeutiques en
france car ce qui est mis principalement
en avant de la part de spécialistes du
soin psychique
d'éducateurs de pédagogue repérant des
difficultés chez l'enfant c'est la
fécondité d'une approche politique
tauriel temps des facteurs internes où
prennent place bien sur de possibles
près des dispositions que des facteurs
externes de contexte familial social
culturel scolaire
environnementales y compris la
surexposition aux stimulations
excitation des écrans des domaines
explicatif qui invite à une véritable
politique publique de prévention et à
nous prémunir d'une conception
réductrice de l'individu
les troubles de l'attention et de
l'hyperactivité font donc l'objet d'une
controverse entre plusieurs approches
qu'il n'appartient pas aux pouvoirs
publics de trancher ils doivent faire
vivre la pluralité des référentiels
théorique et non normalisés les
pratiques soignantes en orientant vers
un seul type de soins remboursée les
professionnels doivent débattre sans
accuser respire réciproquement de dénis
déni d'un côté d'une prédisposition
contre de l'autre côté déni de la place
de l'histoire singulière et de
l'environnement dans les difficultés et
leurs dépassements parle au fond il
n'est pas neutre de promouvoir le
dépistage précoce du diagnostic tdah
alors que des travaux cliniques
distinguant d'ailleurs les troubles de
l'attention et les troubles de
l'hyperactivité
alerte sur le risque de surdiagnostic et
en bout de scène de surmédicalisation
la france avait d'ailleurs adopté une
attitude prudente en limitant la
prescription et le renouvellement annuel
des médicaments psychostimulants au
pédopsychiatre hospitalier en ouvrant à
la prescription en ville il est probable
que le recours médicamenteux augmente
dans un contexte où beaucoup de lieux
pluridisciplinaire de prévention et de
soins comme les cmpp les cmp de
proximité ont vu leurs moyens péricliter
et les délais d'attentes pour les
enfants en difficulté dépassé plusieurs
mois et que dire des médecins infirmiers
psychologues scolaires affectés sur
plusieurs écoles ces réalités rendent
impossible la rencontre des
professionnels spécialisés de l'équipe
éducative et des parents autour de la
situation de l'enfant il faut bien
entendu
identifiés ou plutôt des difficultés
mais diagnostic et sans enfermer
l'enfant et déployer des dispositifs
d'accompagnement adaptées et des
propositions pédagogiques propres à sa
situation il faut enfin mettre fin à la
destruction des dispositifs ou exercent
des équipes pluridisciplinaires
embaucher massivement les différents
professionnels dont la pluralité des
regards et des pratiques est essentielle
pour permettre à chaque enfant en
difficulté de construire son propre
chemin d'émancipation je vous remercie
merci chers collègues est attardé mais
parce que madame la ministre a demandé à
intervenir donc elle
je sais pas si elle répond madame poncet
manges tu auras droit sur le coup
d'ailleurs à une minute
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénatrice et les sénateurs non
c'était pour pouvoir préciser certaines
choses parce que je sais que vous êtes
très à cheval sur le timing et que
j'aurai peut-être pas forcément le temps
bout de cinq minutes pour répondre à
tous donc je voulais juste préciser que
c'est la première stratégie nationale
pour l'autisme au sein des troubles du
développement qui prend en compte le
tdah il ya eu trois plans autistes là
nous avons souhaité vraiment élargir au
tdah dès le début 2018 2022 d'autre part
je voulais aussi répondre sur le fait
que l'engagement du président de la
république lors de la conférence
nationale du handicap a été justement
d'élargir aux 7 12 ans parce que nous le
savons sur le tbhc souvent lors de
l'entrée dans l'apprentissage en
élémentaire que nous pouvons avoir les
signes d'alerté important et c'est bien
l'enjeu de cette stratégie de répondre
et ça a été des alertes des associations
qui conte sont concernés par le tdah qui
nous a fait évoluer parce que nous
travaillons co-construction vraiment
avec l'ensemble des associations je vous
remercie de pouvoir porter ce débat
parce que je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important de prendre en compte vraiment
prendre en compte l'accompagnement des
familles de leurs enfants et des adultes
dans le cadre aussi de pouvoir avoir de
la portabilité de toutes les adaptations
qui ont été faites pendant la vie de ces
familles c'est tellement important de
faire tomber le poids des épaules de ces
familles de tout voir toujours expliquer
les adaptations nécessaires et
suffisantes dans cette continuité de
mise en route d adaptation pegasus
pédagogique depuis l'enfance jusqu'à
l'adulte que nous travaillons avec les
familles toujours en concertation avec
les associations mais en tout cas je
vous remercie de porter ce débat
s'est alors conformément aux règles de
ce nouveau débat si madame forcément je
veux une minute non la parole est à
monsieur philippe mouiller pour le goût
des républicains pour cinq minutes
président
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
j'interviens désolé avec un décalage en
tous les cas ça m'a permis d'y entendre
madame le ministre sur un sujet
important
les troubles des dh et notamment à
quelques quelques quelques heures du
prochain comité interministériel du
handicap sera l'occasion justement de
porter un message est de confirmer
justement votre engagement regard des
associations des parents concernés donc
nous sommes réunis ce soir donc afin de
débattre sur l'amélioration de la prise
en charge des personnes atteintes du
trouble du déficit de l'attention avec
ou sans hyperactivité
et ce débat fait suite au dépôt d'une
proposition de loi par notre collègue de
silguy dave qui sait tout entièrement
mobilisés sur ce sujet qu'elle connaît
bien je tiens à la remercier d'avoir
pris cette initiative
si la pro b soul loi ne sera pas
examinée dans les médias elle a le
mérite par ce débat organisé par le
groupe union centriste de nous permettre
d'aborder un sujet dont on parle peu et
qui n'est pas encore pris suffisamment
en compte mais ces dispositifs ont été
lancés celui des tdah est plus large
blanc des troubles du nord au
développement tnd alors qu'il concerne
un nombre croissant de nos concitoyens
le tdah est un trouble de comportement
qui associe souvent trois dimensions
clinique ça a été dit une attention
l'impulsivité et l'hyperactivité ainsi
suivant la haute autorité de santé le
tdf concerne 5 % des enfants et
adolescents et des dessins pour cent des
adultes soit environ deux millions de
personnes on regarde de la nature des
nuages qui portait aujourd'hui on peut
imaginer qu'avec l'évolution et
l'amélioration des diagnostics le nombre
soit plus conséquent il a des
répercussions significatives sur
l'apprentissage scolaire et des
incidences sur la vie personnelle
professionnelle et sociale de ceux qui
en souffrent mais également des familles
je souhaite également salué le travail
effectué par annick jacques mais
rapporteur de la proposition de loi j'ai
dû prendre en charge un sujet difficile
comme elle nous l'a confié lors de la
présentation de son rapport au sein de
la commission des affaires sociales elle
ne s'est pas particulièrement ce que
recouvrait le tdah
comme beaucoup d'autres nous d'ailleurs
mais si elle a pris le temps
d'auditionner les différents acteurs
concernés directement elle n'a pas
hésité également à élargir ses auditions
aux représentantes de personnes et des
familles touchées par ce qu'on appelle
plus largement les troubles dus euros
développement en effet il est difficile
d'envisager de parler des troubles de
l'attention sans aborder les troupes du
neuro développement dans leur globalité
le tdah fait partie des troubles du
développement au même titre que les
troubles du spectre de l'autisme les
trous du doublement intellectuelle et
true blood is ils sont nombreux mais
surtout les parfums les personnes
atteintes de tdh peuvent présenter un ou
plusieurs autres tdn ce qui est souvent
le cas c'est pourquoi on ne prétend que
du tdah l'approbation de loi n'aurait
répondu que partiellement aux attentes
des personnes concernées il est
difficile de porter une proposition de
loi qui ne traite que des tdah sont
pendants considération l'ensemble des
troupes du nouveau développement
tellement les liens sont importants les
grands enjeux sont les mêmes en matière
de diagnostic d'accompagnement de
scolarité d'as à sion et de
reconnaissance par les pouvoirs publics
les objets sont identiques mais chaque
trouble est spécifique et nécessite une
organisation particulière et une vue
d'ensemble sur les tdr j'appelle de mes
voeux que le futur texte que nous aurons
à examiner dans quelques mois concernant
les telle haine dans leur ensemble ils
politique ambitieuse en faveur d'une
meilleure prise en compte des tdm dresse
à écrire il revient au gouvernement de
se saisir de ce sujet complexe des
objectifs communs à mener sont
édifiantes est défini en 2018 dans le
cas de la stratégie nationale pour
l'autisme mais les résultats seront
longs attendre et je crois que il est
nécessaire d'être mobilisé les avancées
en matière de recherche de diagnostic
d'accès de prise en charge pour
l'instant timide les familles des
enfants concernés ont un besoin urgent
de réponse beaucoup d'entre elles encore
reste démuni face au trou d'un enfant
faute de pouvoir faire un établi à des
néo stick dès les premières années et
pour également une meilleure prise en
charge pour ce faire de nombreux pubs et
celle de santé et de la propre petite
enfance de tête formé ça a été dit afin
d'être en mesure de déceler des signaux
propres tnd avant qu'un véritable
diagnostic puisse être rapidement posée
par un spécialiste et ça envoie l'enjeu
du nom de spécialistes sur le territoire
national sur leur formation en matière
d'insertion scolaire la sensibilisation
et l'information des personnels de
l'éducation nationale sont des troubles
neuro développement leur permettront
d'apporter une réponse aux difficultés
rencontrées par les élèves en terme
d'apprentissage et de comportement
mais c'est vrai que l'enjeu pour le
personnel est important concernant les
nombreux types de handicap avec des
particularités dont spécifiques dont les
terrines d une meilleure prise en charge
financière des dépenses en soins avancés
par les familles doit être également
envisagée le reste à charge reste
souvent beaucoup pour tous trop élevé et
c'est également le débat de la
reconnaissance par la mdph
éventuellement la possibilité de
bénéficier des aides humaines qui reste
à ce sujet sur la table notamment
important la future proposition de loi
que nous attendons devra répondre entre
autres à ces multiples problématiques
posées et donc le groupe politique les
républicains contribuera en tous les cas
aux travaux d'évolution dans la tente
d'un texte regroupant l'ensemble des
enjeux du secteur merci beaucoup c'est
cher collègue
la parole est maintenant madame florence
lassarade toujours le groupe l'est
républicain
également pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le tdah est une
maladie neurologique complexe qui se
caractérise par une forte inattention
des problèmes de concentration
d'hyperactivité et une impulsivité
chronique générant des troubles de
l'apprentissage
le tda/h touche principalement les
enfants et les adolescents mais
également les adultes on considère
qu'ils concernent 5 à 7% des enfants
persiste dans 60 à 70% des cas chez
l'adulte soit une prévalence de 3 à 4%
de la population adulte c'est un trouble
que les pédiatres pédopsychiatres
connaissent bien son repérage est
complexe car il n'existe pas de signaux
logique ou physique spécifique de plus
le tdah peut être associé à d'autres
troubles neuro développement l'adie
compliquant à la fois son diagnostic et
sa prise en charge la construction du
diagnostic est complexe car il faut
essayer de comprendre le sens l'origine
des symptômes ces symptômes peuvent
d'ailleurs dans certains cas être
aggravées par l'influencé des écrans
lorsqu'il est établi ce trouble est à
l'origine d'une altération des relations
l entourage et de l'apprentissage
scolaire etc nécessitent une prise en
charge médicale notamment quand les
symptômes deviennent un handicap et on
sont une source de souffrance cette
prise en charge repose d'abord sur un
traitement non médicamenteuses l'aide de
psychothérapie de rééducation si cela
n'est pas suffisant le méthylphénidate
peut être prescrit dans certains cas
cette molécule a été largement prescrit
aux états unis mais peu en france car
elles peuvent provoquer d'importants
effets secondaires toutefois les
prescriptions de méthylphénidate
s'envole d'après le rapport sur les
données d'utilisation de sécurité
d'emploi en france publié en 2017 parle
nsn les chiffres ont bondi en 25 ans le
nombre de boîtes vendues est passé de 26
mille ans 96 à 220 milles en 2005 et
plus de 600 milles en 2014 même si une
augmentation des chiffres de ventes
continuent d'être observés l'utilisation
de médicaments en france restent
cependant faibles notamment comparaison
à d'autres pays européens
la prise en charge du tdah doit être la
plus précoce possible adapté aux
symptômes à l'âge et au co morbidités du
patient je vois deux axes principaux à
partir desquels nous pourrions
travailler à une meilleure prise en
charge ce trouble il faut premièrement
améliorer le repérage puis dans un
deuxième temps avoir une prise en charge
efficace des enfants des adolescents
mais aussi des adultes la formation
repérage du tda h par les professionnels
santé reste encore insuffisante selon
une étude d'impact réalisée en 2021
seulement 14% des troubles neuro de
développement seraient repérés par les
professionnels de santé de première
ligne pour améliorer le repérage précoce
des tdm dé la délégation
interministérielle propose un module de
sensibilisation formation en ligne à
destination des professionnels de santé
c'est un premier pas mais ils restent
insuffisants
la mise en oeuvre de plateformes ne
pourra pas compenser le manque chronique
de pédiatres de pédopsychiatres sont les
mieux à même de diagnostiquer et de
soyez enfants souffrant de ce trouble
d'après le repérage les patients tendons
des le repérage les patients et les
familles devraient bénéficier d'une
meilleure prise en charge
malheureusement 15 à 17 % des
adolescents souffrent d'un tdah sont
dirigés dans un service d'adulte car on
manque de structures spécialisées pour
une prise en charge des adolescents je
pense qu'une amélioration de la prise en
charge du thé d'âge pourrait aussi
passer par une pratique sportive plus
intenses comme c'est actuellement le cas
dans les pays anglo saxons par exemple
ensuite le tdah ne disparaissent pas
subitement à 18 ans quid du suivi à
l'âge adulte des pâtissiers ont déjà
diagnostiqués enfin ce trouble est très
largement sous diagnostiquée chez
l'adulte soit parce que le diagnostic
n'a pas été posée de l'enfance soit
parce que les conséquences du trouble ne
se déclare qu'à l'âge adulte concernant
ceux ci le manque chronique de
ressources entraîne là aussi des délais
de consultation très long et une forte
inégalité dans l'accès aux soins la
filière de soin nécessite d'être
structuré et harmonisent sur l'ensemble
du territoire pour permettre une égale
une égalité d'accès les conséquences de
ce trouble ont un impact tout au long de
la vie son retentissement et variés peut
constituer un réel handicap une
instabilité des trajectoires
professionnelles des accidents des
addictions précoce voire des tentatives
de suicide j'ai évoqué plusieurs pistes
pour améliorer la prise en charge du
tdah pour conclure je voudrais insister
sur deux points premièrement si nous
avons si nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de pédiatres de pédopsychiatres et
psychiatre pour prendre en charge ces
patients la mise en oeuvre des
recommandations et des différents outils
proposés ne permettrons malgré tout pas
une prise en charge efficace des
patients sur l'ensemble du territoire
ensuite il existe aussi des mesures
simples pour aider ses patients telles
que celles qui favorisent la pratique
sportive dès le plus jeune âge ce n'est
pas la solution miracle mais un soutien
nécessaire et adaptée à la prise en
charge de ce trouble et qui a le mérite
d'être relativement facile à mettre en
oeuvre je me réjouis que le débat de ce
soir est plus mettre en difficulté en
lumière les difficultés de ses patients
et de leurs familles afin de nous
puissions réfléchir ensemble à une
meilleure prise en charge de ce trouble
qui se traduira ensuite par des mesures
législatives et réglementaires
je remercie en particulier jose qu'il
n'y ait c'est la lame jacquemin pour
pour leur travail sur le sujet merci
merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur
françois bonhomme pour les républicains
pour 4 minutes
et
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues s'il est un
phénomène aujourd'hui bien présent dans
notre société c'est bien le trouble du
déficit de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité
celui ci est pourtant qu'on méconnu et
bien souvent douloureux pour nos
familles ce syndrome constitue un
véritable enjeu de santé publique c'est
un enjeu de santé car ce syndrome
concerne jusqu'à 5% des enfants en
france c'est sans doute 2,5 pour cent de
la population adulte soit 2 millions de
nos compatriotes
ce trouble neurobiologique ne disparaît
pas avec l'âge un enfant atteint
deviendra au contraire un adulte avaient
des symptômes plus ou moins marquée des
conséquences différentes selon la
sévérité des symptômes et la précocité
de la prise en charge à ce titre les
adultes atteints sont davantage enclins
à faire l'objet de suspensions de permis
de conduire ou d'accident et
d'arrestations que le reste de la
population
le risque d'addiction serait par
ailleurs deux à trois fois plus
important les médecins leur diagnostic
enfin plus fréquemment des troubles
anxieux dépressifs bipolaires ou encore
du sommeil de la personnalité ces
dispositifs existent à l'image de la
prise en charge par l'assurance maladie
d'un parcours de bilan et d'intervention
précoce pour l'accompagnement des
enfants de la mise en place de
plateformes d'orientation et de
coordination dans le cadre de ce
parcours ces plateformes doivent être
déployés pour proposer une coordination
une orientation aux enfants jusqu'à
l'âge de 12 ans les professions médicaux
de premier recours sont impliqués dans
le parcours de soins des personnes
atteintes ils peuvent repérer les
symptômes et leurs différentes
expressions et orientées celles ci aient
participé encore au suivi cependant
malgré des progrès indéniables il
importe d'améliorer le dépistage et
mieux accompagner des familles en
pratique on assiste en effet à une
véritable errance dès lors que ce
syndrome reste sous diagnostiquée à la
matière la france accuse d'ailleurs un
certain retard les médecins spéciale de
ces troubles sont à ce titre peu
nombreux et mal réparties sur le
territoire si bien que les délais
d'attentes peuvent atteindre jusqu'à 18
mois pour obtenir un premier rendez-vous
et deux ans pour un diagnostic or de
nombreux obstacles causés par ce
syndrome pourrait être franchie voir et
vie grâce à un diagnostic précoce car
l'enfant en prendrait au plus tôt à
vivre avec lui ce qui limiterait de ce
fait des conséquences sur sa vie
d'adulte il est également possible
qu'une absence de prise en charge
provoque une manifeste sommes plus grave
du trouble notamment à cause des
comorbidités comorbidités comme la
dépendance des comportements à risque ce
syndrome constitue un facteur de risque
pour développement d'addiction et
d'autres comment comorbidités
psychiatrique département important
d'établir un diagnostic précoce car ce
dernier peut littéralement changer le
cours d'une vie si à titre d'exemple
parmi lés 5 % d'enfants atteints seule
une petite partie aura la chance de
bénéficier d'un outil précoce une prise
en charge optimale et donc une vie
d'adulte que l'on peut qualifier normal
pour les autres le retentissement
restent variables certains sont
longtemps traitée sans succès pour
troubles bipolaires d'autres pour
dépression ou pour des addictions avec
ou sans substance certains se
retrouveront même un présent du fait de
leur impulsivité une étude britannique a
montré au demeurant que lorsque ces
adultes étaient traités il ne restait
décidé à récidiver pas et leur insertion
était bien plus facile que ce mille sous
placebo dans cette optique la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
justin guidait ce propos dans son
article 3 la création de deux
consultations obligatoires de dépistage
des troubles neuro développement
remboursés par la sécurité sociale le
mécanisme proposé s'inspirant de celui
prévu pour les examen bucco-dentaire de
prévention on ne peut que souscrire à
l'objectif poursuivi par ce mécanisme
qui constituerait de toute évidence le
coeur de la stratégie de dépistage et de
prévention contre le tdah madame la
ministre pourriez vous en ce sens nous
indiquer les mesures envisagées par le
gouvernement afin d'améliorer le nain si
précoce de la tvh et ainsi assurer la
prise en charge optimale susceptibles
d'offrir une trajectoire de vie normale
aux personnes atteintes de ce trouble
merci chers collègues
pour conclure le débat la parole est
d'abord à madame sophie cluzel
secrétaires d'état chargés auprès du
premier ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées pour 5 minutes puis ce sera
madame 10 days qui conclura également
pour cinq minutes
la parole
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
d'abord de vous dire le plaisir qui est
le mien d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
afin de débattre d'un sujet prioritaire
pour le gouvernement celui de
l'accompagnement de la prise en compte
des personnes atteintes du trouble de
déficit de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité
je souhaite ainsi remercié le groupe
union centriste d'avoir fait le choix de
mettre en avant cette thématique dans le
cas de cette journée de discussions
parlementaires comme vous l'avez rappelé
ce débat est issue d'une proposition de
loi présentée par la sénatrice jocelyne
guedez dont je connais l'engagement sur
ces sujets organisé trois sur trois axes
amélioration de la formation des acteurs
au contact des enfants et des adultes
atteints du trouble de déficit de
l'attention
l'établissement d'un diagnostic précoce
et enfin les différents dispositifs de
repérage et de prise en charge pour les
tdh vous proposer en ce sens d'organiser
au même titre que le handicap en général
la prise en compte des tdah dans les
parcours scolaires la formation des
professionnels enseignants et de santé
et l'organisation de l'accès au repérage
au diagnostic et au remboursement des
soins des personnes avec tdh néanmoins
je souhaite rappeler que les troubles
liés au tdah ne donne pas lieu
nécessairement une reconnaissance au
titre du handicap souvenons-nous en ce
sens de l'esprit de la loi de 2005 qui
n'est pas de distinguer les typologies
de handicap mais de porter un esprit
global commun bien sûr certains types de
handicap ont des nécessités qui ne
saurait être prise en compte dans des
lois générales c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis 2010 est des plans
d'action et des stratégies nationales
sont déployés en ce sens les trouble du
déficit de l'attention étant une
catégorie des troubles
neurodéveloppementaux nous avons veillé
à ce que leurs enjeux et besoins soient
notamment traité dans la stratégie
nationale autisme et troubles de de niro
développement 2018 2022 en effet la
première ambition de cette stratégie ont
été d'inscrire la science au coeur des
pratiques en structurant une recherche
d'excellence vous l'avez cité et je
tiens à vous rassurer dans le groupement
d'intérêt scientifique en effet l'été
les âges sont bien pris en compte elle a
permis devra réaliser des avancées dans
le champ du repérage et des
interventions précoces à travers la mise
en place d'un parc de bilan et
d'intervention précoce nous avons créé
pour ce faire les plateformes
d'orientation et de coordination qui
s'adresse à l'ensemble des personnes
susceptibles de préserver présentent un
trouble du nero développement y compris
les personnes tdh elles sont donc
extrêmement identifiées comme cible du
dispositif et leurs besoins ont été
prises en compte elles ont été
accompagnées ses plates formes de la
création d'un forfait précoce permettant
le remboursement des interventions de
tous les professionnels de santé
participant fonctionnement sans reste à
charge pour les familles l'intervention
des ergothérapeutes psychologues
psychomotriciens non conventionnés avec
l'assurance maladie sont donc
intégralement remboursé douze mille
enfants étaient prises en charge par le
forfait afin d'orienter les familles
vers ces dispositifs nous avons créé un
guide de repérage des signes d' alerte
il est mise à disposition des médecins
de première ligne pour permettre
d'orienter l'enfant et sa famille vers
une plateforme dans le plfss 2022 nous
avons souhaité consolider les crédits de
la stratégie et avec 9 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui ont participé au
renforcement des plateformes et surtout
à leur déploiement pour les enfants de 7
12 ans aujourd'hui c'est plus de 20
mille enfants avec un trouble du nero
développement qui ont été repérés par 76
plateforme oui nous les déployons avec
cette extension du 7 12 ans et c'est
pour ça que nous avons entendues et
travailler avec les familles un guide de
repérage différent du 06 ans a été
élaboré avec des experts avec
l'éducation nationale il a été travaillé
en lien au plus près des besoins des
enfants et sera testé durant ce premier
3000 2022 dans les pc au il sera
renseignée par les enseignants des
familles et le médecin et permettra une
orientation vers une plateforme outre la
création des pc au d'autres avancées ont
été ont été faites mais en place d'une
consultation dédiée aux troubles de
l'enfant effectué par le médecin
traitant sur la base d'un tarif
supérieur à une consultation habituelle
de zéro à 70 euros pour rémunérer ce
temps nécessaire et suffisant de
repérage et enfin améliorer la formation
des acteurs de l'éducation nationale les
actions spécifiques sont menées avec
l'éducation nationale je ne peux pas
toutes les citer mais le livret parcours
inclusif qui se développe pour pouvoir
justement avoir la portabilité des
adaptations avec le ministère de la
justice pour sensibiliser les émetteurs
d'informations préoccupantes et bien
d'autres bien sûr j'entends vos
préoccupations s'agissant du soutien
apporté aux familles et nous y
travaillons également dans la stratégie
nationale pour les aidants nous
déployons les dispositifs de répit est
également destinée aux parents d'enfants
tdah vous le voyez énormément d'action
qui sont inscrits dans cette stratégie
que se déploieront et pour laquelle nous
nous évaluions le reste à faire
justement avec les familles avec une
enquête ipsos importante 2020 et 2021
sur cette stratégie pour pouvoir
justement évalué et ajuster et c'est
ainsi que nous continuerons de
travailler avec les associations pour
les familles pour leurs enfants et pour
les adultes donc je pense notamment à
cette véritable enjeu d'accompagnement
et de déclinaisons sur le terrain dans
chacun des territoires au plus près des
besoins des personnes
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
ah c'est pas moi qui fais les règles
c'est vrai
l'amdi days pour cinq minutes également
pour conclure cette séance
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je tenais à
vous remercier pour ce débat constructif
et enrichissant malgré la sensibilité et
la complicité de sujets je remarque tout
au long de notre débat un accord général
sur le bien fondé de son inscription à
l'ordre du jour je tiens aussi à saluer
l'engagement la volonté de madame
l'analyste ajouté qu elles soient sujets
relatifs au handicap mes chers collègues
de la prévention un coup ne pas faire la
prévention à un coup également humain
car enfants parents et enseignants sont
fragilisés politique car la lutte contre
le décrochage a un coût social par la
karl l'addiction la délinquance c'est le
suicide ont un coût est donc tout à fait
judicieux d'investir aujourd'hui pour
que toute la société soit demain à
renforcer alors de l'école s'ouvre
inclusive il est temps de former tous
les enseignants à ce trouble qui affecte
5 % des enfants il est temps d'accorder
nos enfants une égalité des chances
réelles de rendre l'organisation du
travail en classe respectueuse des
différences à toutes les associations à
toutes les familles je voudrais dire que
notre combat ne se termine pas ce soir
il y encore beaucoup à faire étant
d'encourager le gouvernement accroître
ses efforts pour garantir des ressources
aux familles assurer la mise en pratique
des obligations de formation existantes
développer des centres experts de tous
les troubles du neurodéveloppement mes
chers collègues avec le soutien de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
restons mobilisés sur la question de la
prise en charge du tdah la mise en place
d'une mission d'information permettrait
d'entendre des psychiatres des
neuroscientifiques ainsi que des
associations dans l'optique d'apporter
collectivement des solutions plus
adéquat pour la prise en charge des
enfants et des adultes atteints de ce
trouble il est temps de faire de la
solidarité et du vivre ensemble une
priorité il ya une attente très forte
des parents épuisés qu'ils nous ont fait
des témoignages accablants j'en cite de
quelques-uns
le personnel éducatif n'est formé ni eau
trouble ni aux aménagements scolaires
possible mon enfant est découragée
déprimé ce sont incapables d'autonomie
ce qui l'angoissé pour son avenir il est
devenu le bouc émissaire de toute une
classe il a le droit d'être aidé il a
droit d'être heureux je ne souhaite pas
que mon enfant soit musique inventée
pour pallier les manques de moyens
auquel il a le droit c'est une double
sanction nous sommes des parents ignorer
de la république nos enfants tdh en
maths était par le système éducatif et
sont les oubliés du gouvernement la
méconnaissance de ce trouble dans notre
société est très dur à gérer personne ne
peut imaginer ce que nous subissons les
préjugés habituels parents laxistes
enfants turbulents ouh le vilain petit
canard un quotidien effréné pesant sur
de nervosité avec de l'ignorance ou de
l'indifférence
en face le sentiment de ne pas être
compris d'être démunis d'être rejeté à
tout cela s'ajoute une bataille
permanente avec un passage quasi obligé
par la case zéro écoute pour faire
connaître le tdah
dans de temps et d'énergie seraient
gagnés chez à bilan systématique étaient
effectués à l'école primaire pour des
enfants pour ces enfants concernés est
d'ailleurs fréquent que diagnostic des
parents ou d'autres membres de la
famille suivent celui des enfants chers
collègues une attendu pour toutes ces
familles serait pour elle une bouée de
sauvetage cette situation mérite qu'une
proposition de loi soit étudié pour
favoriser la prise en charge de ces
personnes pour leur permettre de
s'épanouir de leur éviter les addictions
en tout genre les problèmes
psychologiques et les graves dépressions
on ne peut pas laisser 2 millions
d'individus sur le bord de la route les
laissant dériver devenir des adultes
dépendants du système je connais bien le
quotidien de ces enfants puisque un de
mes petits schiste pourtant les haines
aussi du tdah au potentiel bénéficient
d'un suivi pluridisciplinaire
hebdomadaire tous les enfants n'ont pas
la même chance parce que toutes les
familles n'ont pas les mêmes moyens de
prendre en charge le parcours de soin de
leurs enfants quand il faut attendre
deux ans pour faire un bilan et ça c'est
la réalité seule une volonté politique
pourra éclaircir le paysage les
associations qui oeuvrent aussi au
terrain ont déjà bien déblayer le chemin
il leur faut juste un coup de pouce et
le sentiment d'être entendus avec ma
collègue indique jacques mais nous
sommes convaincus que l'accent porté sur
le tdah n'enlèvera rien aux actions
conduites pour lutter contre les
difficultés d'insertion liées aux
troubles autistiques nous pourrons
continuer notre travail et nous comptons
sur chacun de vous et sur votre
mobilisation afin de faire avancer la
cause des personnes atteintes de tdh ce
problème de santé publique mérite notre
attention soutenue je termine mes propos
avec une station de wilson cherchent ils
l'une des célébrités sur lesquelles le
diagnostic a été porté à posteriori le
succès c'est d'aller d'échec en échec
sans perdre son enthousiasme avec la
collègue éric jacquemet mais j'ai
compris que
monsieur mouillé en tous les cas serait
prêt aussi à venir travailler avec nous
nous avons la fermeté et la volonté de
continuer à travailler sur cette
problématique nous resterons vigilants
sur le développement des plates formes
de coordination et d'orientation sur
l'efficacité du parcours de prise en
charge de ces enfants par le
gouvernement nous sommes à l'écouté de
toutes les associations vous pouvez
compter sur notre engagement je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance la prochaine séance aura lieu
jeudi 3 février à 10h30 pour les
questions orales la séance est levée